oh
oh the system's working wonderful
okay good morning everybody uh on the
committee and those uh members the
public that are present
uh just for an update uh the education
committee has to this point heard
approximately 41 bills
we have 102 to accomplish
so we're getting there it's like well
it's it's starting to feel like we're
there but i'm sure everybody up here is
feeling a little bit of exhaustion
and uh
so um we i want to adhere to this
schedule as best we can so with that
being
right at a few minutes after nine
i'd like to go ahead and and start
today's meeting and the first bill we
have is hb
uh 1015 relative to school district
policies regarding objectionable
material
welcome representative cordelli uh thank
you mr chairman and honorable colleagues
for the record i am state representative
glenn cordelli representing tuftonboro
moultonborough and sandwich in the
beautiful lakes region
we often talk about
enabling legislation well this is
clarifying legislation if i might
current law allows parents to opt their
child out from specific
instruction and to arrange alternate
instruction that would be agreed upon
between the parent and the school
there is some disagreement about the
course instruction covered by
rsa 186 colon 11
roman 9
dash c
and if you want to follow along it's on
page
30309 in your
laws books
it has been read by some to apply only
to sex education
but most view the ability to opt out to
any instruction
the paragraph prior
9b
clearly applies to sex education as in
to
indicated in the paragraph heading and
the language and i quote from that
allowing to an exception to a particular
unit of health or sex education
instruction
9c
however is headed
require school districts to adopt the
policy allowing an exception to specific
course material based upon appearance or
legal guardian's determination that the
material is objectionable
the language following
simply specifies to notify the school
principal or designee in writing of the
material to which they object
parents have should have the right to
have input as to what is being taught to
their children
to think that they just put their child
on the school bus and have no say as to
what goes on behind the schoolhouse
doors is just plain wrong
1015 clarifies that 9c applies to any
course of instruction
and also that adds new language that
granting of an alternate
alternative to a lesson should not apply
to an entire course but just to a
specific lesson
and
what i think was handed out around the
committee table
is a comparison of the current law and
on the back is
hb
1015 and i tried to break it up into
sections
of the uh law and the proposal so that
it's easier to compare uh language
uh between the two
and basically in the
uh
bill that we are looking at um it
removes the uh language
for instruction of human sexuality or
human sexual education
um and inserts the uh paragraph excuse
me the sentence at the bottom of the
uh bill
about
that this is uh for a specific lesson
and not an entire course that can be
opted out
uh from
uh
in terms of clarifying
um
there is a uh
frequently asked question document put
out by the department of education
commissioner for human rights and the
department of justice
dealing with uh last june's hb2
and the
anti-discrimination sections
addressing addressing that
but also um
includes the question can parents or
guardians refuse to allow their children
to participate in a specific course
material and the answer is yes
where parents or guardians object to
specific more
course materials they are encouraged to
follow school policies related to
uh 186 11 9c
uh so with that um i thank you very much
uh for your uh attention
thank you very much representative
cordelli uh i do have one question first
uh and i've i've spoken with you about
about this
um
the area of removing for instruction
human sexuality or human sexual
education with the two weeks notice i'm
concerned that
i oftentimes am called upon to present
at woodsville high school they have a
class in military history
and as a veteran of vietnam they
oftentimes will call me but there might
be only like two or three days notice to
that
and and it's sort of sliding people into
the schedule who are available it could
be the governor that's coming and
visiting uh that's all sudden and you
would like to have the governor of
course
speak to kids there's a wonderful
opportunity there
so would this bill then restrict that
type of spawn spontaneity that we have
in schools to
bring in uh
portions of instruction that really
benefit and take advantage of the moment
i i do not believe so
the current language um also
requires the two weeks uh advanced
notice um so
uh it would apply
uh currently to uh
um
that same uh issue um i believe um i
have not
heard of any problems in relation to
that and um
we are attempting to
make sure that
curriculum
materials are available
well in advance of two weeks
so i don't
see that there would be any problem
if something comes up in terms of
a speaker that is suddenly available or
a
topic
related to current events
i do not think that there would be an
objection
to that thank you very much further
questions right now and going around the
table representative porter
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative cordelli um i have
two-part question number one
the school has to give a two-week notice
do the parents have to give any kind of
notice ahead of time that their child
will not be participating in that lesson
yes i think in
the statutes there's a
provision that the parents
or the guardian have to provide
a written notification of that with a
reason for their objection and follow up
on that yes so
if i'm in the classroom and i'm teaching
a lesson and i have one or two children
whose parents object to that lesson what
do i do with those children while i'm
teaching the lesson
there is to be
worked out an agreement between the
parents in the school as to an
alternative
lesson during that time
it could be in the library
or something else
except the library isn't always
available for those kinds of things
and that's my concern is what do i do
with those two kids
and who's going to be teaching that
lesson to them
so i'm just wondering if you know how
that's handled
in various schools
i am not aware of that but
that is current statue also that
it's an agreement between
the school and the parents as to what is
to be done during that time rep
representative hobson and then
representative ellison uh i don't um i
don't know if it's appropriate or not i
just have a comment about rep porter's
question
um there's a provision on line nine that
answers that i don't know if you saw it
or not
but
just the basics of how to handle it
thank you
that was not a question for the
for the presenter representative ellison
thank you mr chair
thank you for taking my question
looking at lines six through eight
uh on the bill
by removing human sexuality and human
sexual education
and sort of making the bill applicable
to anything
are we asking that
every single course at any level
in a school all of those curriculum
materials must be made available to
parents
at any given time we asking the
kindergarten teacher to send out her
materials on reading and math and so on
i mean
it i think or i ask you do we open that
up that possibility by removing the
specific
reference to human sexuality and human
sexual education
i believe that the
current law
applies more broadly than that and my
attempt here is to clarify that that is
the intent of the law
um
i
uh
i'll leave it at that
further questions from the committee
i have a question for you then uh
representative cordelli do you recall
that when we've had discussion on this
particular statute in the past
we've had questions asked do do i have
to have a two week you can have this all
curriculum delivered to parents online
at the beginning of the school year is
that correct uh that is correct and i i
think that
we've seen or are in the process of
seeing
several
bills clarifying that curriculum needs
to be made available to parents
thank you further questions of
representing court yes representative
didn't see your hands down there okay
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
i want to speak to your statement that
that
parents send their kids off to school
and um they have no say in what happens
behind closed doors was the was the
quote i believe and i would like you to
um
uh
know
from my point of view that uh that did
not happen uh any parent that came in
that asked for things got it but i was
wondering if you had
um
an idea of how how often that happens in
in new hampshire
thank you for the question
i i believe my comment was that they
should have the right
i i do not know
how many times
that occurs but
certainly there have been times when
parents have requested materials and
have
received
not
all the information that's requested or
objections to providing the materials
that are available
and i i think that that is is an issue
yes may
um
do you believe that most schools have a
policy in place um
for
uh parents coming in or parents
requesting or objecting to materials
after particularly after this law was
first written
i would hope they do
i i think that
you know when a new
statute is
passed and signed
there should be a
local policy developed
thank you representative mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
the way i read uh 1015 is not that the
curriculum needs to be put online at the
beginning of the year what i'm reading
is
shall require the school district or
classroom teacher to provide parents and
legal guardians not less than two weeks
advance notice of
curriculum course material and to me
that speaks to
readings written assignments the
worksheet that's going to be handed out
[Music]
so
are are you concerned at all that you're
sort of hobbling classroom teachers to
making a decision and then what happens
if within 10 days of the lesson they
discover materials that they consider
are better
um
thank you for the question but that is
that is current law
so um i i would expect that they are uh
dealing with that now and uh i don't
think that uh if they uh
uh alter a lesson plan or change the
sequence of a lesson um i i do not think
that
there would be a huge problem in that
yes follow-up
uh
the current law specifies human
sexuality and reproduction and and uh
uh are
are you saying that we already have in
place a statute that requires all
materials that are being used by all
classroom teachers to be available two
weeks in advance
i think that the current 186 11 9c does
provide for that um in that
looking at the title of the uh
section um as well as the uh detailed
language um and it further uh
down in the um the paragraph says um
uh
that it would also cover
sexual um educational materials the word
also was in there
thank you
represent tanner
and then represent thank you um
as a as a teacher uh what do you think
um
i guess yeah what do you think a teacher
does
uh in order to prepare
for
uh usually just the next week
there's there's usually a unit plan
where you
similar to what
representative representative
uhlery gave us for the
civics the civil rights
but then uh lesson plans are usually
drawn up uh
a week in advance i i would say is
probably normal what do you expect to
see in a teacher's lesson plans
and how can they
how do they then extend them to two
weeks out because if you don't cover
some of the material one day
or if the student doesn't understand the
material one day
bulk of the students then oftentimes
your lesson plans are
junked in the paper and you start out
again uh revising what what you did so
what do you expect
would be let's say you went in and
objected
to
um
something other than human sexuality
which
again i taught and we had numerous times
when people came in
um but let's say uh you you objected to
uh in high school literacy literature um
literature class the discussion of
of maybe a movie they saw like
schindler's list
okay what would you expect the two-week
in your
two weeks of lesson plans
uh i would think um that in the
curriculum materials
that should be available made
made available
to
parents at the beginning of the year
materials such as
films
recordings things like that would be uh
included in that
um
you know and i'll go back to an example
that i think i mentioned one time here
in that
back in connecticut when i was a school
board they wanted to show the godfather
movie
as an illustration of early 20th century
america
if that had
been
in um
passed by the board
i certainly think that that
should have been um notified to the
parents in terms of um the curriculum
that was going to be um for that course
so that the parents could see
um that movie was going to be shown and
i know i would have gone in and objected
to that movie being shown and i i think
it would be perfectly within my rights
and my responsibility as i see it as a
parent
could i have a follow-up to that we we
have a uh some other questions here and
we're running a little tight here so
i'll come back to you if um we have that
time represent hobson
or represent like us excuse me
thank you
mine is sort of a follow-on to
reptanters
um
i'm just curious
as to how detailed
of um
the material needs to be is it just like
when i was teaching math was it just the
math book or i for instance based on
what my students were having trouble
with
wrote up my own problem sets and
everything
to address the particular things they
were in trouble with and i would often
do that the night before
based on what happened that day in class
and i'm wondering how detailed
you know this actually is expected to be
um
i think that the current
language in the bill now
um discusses curriculum course material
i don't think that it has to be every um
worksheet
um as you um mentioned um would have to
be included in that in terms of the
material that is uh made available to
parents
thank you thank you further questions
represent tanner you have one now
yes i do i want to um thank you
representative lakers for kind of
following up on that but i just want to
make it clear
what you expect teachers to turn over
two weeks in advance if i'm if i have a
student teacher i'll i'll take it from a
point where i actually taught student
teachers or had student teachers come
with me okay they had to set goals for
each day
they had to set talk about how it
related to the particular competency or
whatever we were doing
they had to
outline
usually by
by a period of time like i'm going to
spend five minutes getting the kids
warmed up we're going to talk about
maybe ask some questions on you know
what's your favorite food then the next
10 minutes maybe we're going to do
uh a b and c
um
give them a time a period to get
together to discuss what we've gone over
etc etc and then at the end homework for
the next day or you know what we're
going to do for the next day and again
usually that evening
or right after that class you jot some
notes down as a teacher
what went well what didn't go well and
then how you're going to reform
the lesson plan for the next day so so
those are the things that that i see
as curriculum materials and instruction
materials i guess instruction materials
is that what you expect teachers
to present to parents if they just go in
and say
oh you have a unit on
um
you know whatever uh certainly human
sexuality like is a blinking red flag
but um
on anything and that they want exactly
what you're going to do i i really think
uh you need to know what you're asking
for
um
again that is
part of current law um in terms of uh
uh some of the things you mentioned i i
think that that goes beyond what would
be expected but certainly in terms of uh
uh human sexuality
if they're doing
certain types of
demonstrations or
film strips even i would expect that
to be
available to parents and i think that
parents have a right to know what's
going in the classroom and it should be
well in advance of two weeks
i think
curriculum materials should be available
at the beginning of the school year
every school year
thank you very much either further quite
represent hall
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question so
i'm new to this but
it sounds to me that you keep saying
everything is current law
so
what is not current law
you know you're taking out the
right um you could explain that right
sure
current law
um does um include the two weeks notice
right of curriculum materials
what i am removing is this uh
section
or the phrase below that um about uh
instruction for human sexuality and
sexual education
um and adding that um it is not expected
that a parent would uh be able to opt
out of an entire entire course like they
couldn't opt out of
english 101
but a particular lesson but your
interpretation right now is that
teachers should be
always giving two weeks notice for
anything they teach
all the classroom materials is that what
you're saying that it is in current law
that phrase is in current law currently
yes
okay thank you
further questions of the representative
representative cordelli i'm i'm confused
i i hear that you're saying that this is
already in current law though i don't
know that this is current practice that
classroom teachers are providing
materials two weeks ahead of time
and i certainly understand the
sensitivity of teaching human sexuality
and why that would be something that
parents would want you know advanced
notice of i have no problem with that
whatsoever
but how am i as a classroom teacher
supposed to determine what you find
objectionable
um i don't think that you would have to
try and read my mind
um
hopefully you
can't very often um
and uh
i don't think you have to be a mind
reader as long as the information is
available to parents and they can make
their own determination as to
what they believe is objectionable
all right thank you you're welcome are
there further
questions thank you very much
representative cordelli
we'll have our our next speaker our
reverend
dr gail kinney
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee for the record
my name is gail kinney i'm a resident of
canaan
i am a pastor with the united church of
christ um which is the old
congregational churches that people are
probably more familiar with that term
it's the the united church of christ is
the largest protestant denomination in
the state of new hampshire
i am also a former school counselor
a former school board member and former
school board chair and also former chair
of a school administrative unit
board
so i just want to say generally that
this particular bill is uh
completely from my multiple perspectives
including my faith perspective but also
my educator perspective um
completely unworkable and chaos inducing
and i want to first start by saying that
i after i saw this bill
i went back and looked at current law i
printed it out i read it and i reread it
and i reread it to try to understand
what it was doing versus what this bill
is doing
and
despite what has been said the um the
particular provision that is being uh
for which this bill is going to
substitute what's currently in law
that that particular um piece of statute
starts off with just some general
verbiage about that school districts
need to have policies
about how students can object to
material and then it goes on and is very
specific and it says this policy
shall also require the school district
or classroom teacher to provide parents
and legal guardians not less than two
weeks advance notice of curriculum
course material
used for instruction of human sexuality
or human sexual education that is
specific the beginning is general this
particular current statute says two
weeks notice only only only
on for
teaching of human sexuality or sex
education it does not cover anything
else in the curriculum in terms of a two
weeks notice but
the current bill before you 10 15
does in fact um require two weeks notice
of everything
and it's not clear what that means it's
not clear at all that's a part of why
this is chaos inducing in my perspective
but think about that for a minute
beyond the first two weeks of school in
every any given school year
the two-week clock starts ticking
and so it's like every day from that
point onward if if a teacher is coming
up with new classroom material for
whatever reason including the question
about something that's happened
currently or a speaker that comes in is
made available
that is something that according to this
could be
required that that that
that information has to be posted again
and if it's every class think about the
chaos of every teacher having to post
new things uh to to meet the the
two-week requirement because
that is not what the current law says
but that's what 1015 says um
the other things i think very
specifically that this committee needs
to ask itself is what does objectionable
mean and who
decides and also the the
house bill 1015 ends with the words of
that uh that there there can be you can
require um an alternative course
for any lesson that violates a student's
convictions and i just said what does
that mean and i just want to think back
i was a feisty student in my day and
frankly
i had a very strong conviction that i
shouldn't have to to be part of a
biology class if i had to dissect a frog
you know that violated my conviction
and that their my conviction that i
should not do that but there's so
such a lacking of um
of specificity here number one but
number two
just the uh
it makes no sense it is completely
unworkable and if there's this ongoing
thing of two weeks notice for classroom
material meaning things that are
introduced in the classroom
who's going to do that how much time is
it going to take on for every class and
then how much is it going to cost the
school district to comply with the way
this particular bill is written and if
there is a cost factor of constantly
every two weeks of
introducing a letting uh letting there
be notice of every every worksheet every
film every speaker etc um
that cost it strikes me is also an
unfunded mandate but again i would say i
i implore you from my multiple
perspectives
this is a bill um in search of a problem
that doesn't exist number one this is a
bill that's completely unworkable this
is a bill that would create chaos for
teachers and
it it just it screams
despite us perhaps well-intent it
screams and expedient to legislate so i
implore you
please do just that with this particular
bill thank you so much thank you very
much for your testimony uh are there
questions of the reverend
thank you very much
and i will leave the um the current law
do you have written uh do you have
written comment or were you speaking
spontaneously about the bill if you have
written comment it would help the clerk
and correct okay i just wondered if you
wanted a copy of the bill that with the
staff we have that we have the rsas
thank you very much you're welcome
uh megan tuttle
good morning good morning thank you um
chairman lad members of the house
education committee um so i do written
comment it's gonna be a little different
i'm speaking a little different than
what i had prepared for this but megan
tuttle for the record president nea new
hampshire
representing more than 17 000 educators
in the state of
new hampshire and a 8th grade social
studies teacher there's really just two
kind of points i guess i want to make on
this or two questions
good teachers adjust their lessons daily
they look at what happened during the
day any any grade level kindergarten
through higher ed they do the same thing
so you look at what happened during the
day whether it's a block schedule you
know whole class whatever it is and you
reflect on it and you adjust your lesson
the next day based on that
what's happening or what you plan two
weeks in advance isn't always what's
going to be happening in the classroom
an example of this could be current
events and so i taught 8th grade social
studies for 18 years current events was
part of what i had to teach as a social
studies teacher and those you can't plan
two weeks in advance if something is
going to be objectionable to a parent
and you have to let them know two weeks
ahead of time just for example
an article that comes out in the boston
globe or the monitor or any newspaper
you want to pick or
cnn has i apologize i can't remember
what it's called but it's a 10-minute
news segment that's made just for
students other stations might have the
same thing i did use that in the
classroom we watched the 10 minutes of
what was going on and then we talked
about what the current events were the
kids would pick something and they would
write a reflection on it they'd write
you know at that point it was five
sentences on what they thought and then
we picked one of the current events to
talk about that was something i had to
do as part of being a social studies
teacher that you can't plan two weeks in
advance and that's kind of a problem
it's a big problem you can plan out your
units and i always had a curriculum map
in the beginning of the the year saying
these are the units that i'm teaching or
the themes that i'm going to be teaching
but the specific course material to have
it for two weeks in advance is really
hard to do because it's just not
reasonable it's not natural for what
good teachers do they reflect daily and
they they adjust their plans based on
that
um
that's it
thank you very much uh i got a question
for you
when i was a school administrator
elementary grades k through 8.
we had every morning after our morning
exercises a student would come down and
we'd do our daily oral
geography we'd talk about a place or an
event in geography it could have been
human movement it could have been
physical geography etc very simple we
also had daily current event
is there a difference between
curriculum
describing this area that we were doing
daily oral geography and specific
instruction
which
follows and supports those objectives
but
can be changing
uh at the
moment thank you for the question i
think you know i think they're they're
the curriculum i see it is what you're
the kind of broad things you're going to
be teaching um the instruction could
change daily as you're saying the way i
read this is you have to have the
materials which to me if it says the
curriculum course material to be used to
me
that says you have to give the parents
two weeks notice of everything you're
using in your class so it could be part
of instruction is how i'm reading this
which i just don't think is realistic
so a follow-up uh
follow-up um
so if i were talking today about daily
current events and talking about
the ukraine
what what may happen would could i be in
in your interpretation could that be
done
according to this
you could talk i think you could talk
about it but i don't think you could
give two weeks well no actually the way
i'm interpreting this is you don't know
two weeks ahead of time that there's
going to be a story on the ukraine
today so you might not be able to be
talking about it depending on where you
got the story from or something like
that if i'm understanding your question
i'm trying to get there there's a
there's really pillars in in getting
everything aligned in school curriculum
instruction right accountability
and instruction and career and and
curriculum are two separate components
of that stool and
we could have written in at the
beginning of your parents know we're
going to be doing daily oral current
events in geography
there that's that's the curriculum with
objectives of why we're doing it and we
could go down to some of those broad
themes within those two care areas
they don't have to know that we're doing
an event today on on ukraine
is that
how you might interpret it thank you
sort of the way
i know
where we are i know the the way i'm
interpreting this is that a parent can
opt out or
have their child not be part of the
lesson because the material is
objectionable
and i think i'm interpreting that
correctly for this
my point is that
we don't always know what the material
is going to be if it's a current event
so
would the parent then opt out of every
time you do a current event because in
the beginning of the year you're saying
you're doing current events i think
that's where i'm getting
my interpretation is that you
there's a lot of i think
parents that could object to a lot of
current events today i don't think
that's
i don't think anybody could
disagree with that there are so many
topics coming up daily that are so
divisive everybody split on it um
and
two weeks ahead of time we don't know
what the daily news is going to be
so i think you know the way we're
reading this is it's specific course
material
and it has curriculum course material i
just i don't think that this is doable
or workable or reasonable
for any educator in new hampshire right
now to give two weeks
notice of everything that's going to be
used
i mean there are certain so when i
taught i did
i am
completely blanking it we did um i'm so
sorry we did we there were lessons that
i could plan out a month ahead of time
because we did um
different layers or different levels so
the the bottom level of like the
triangle was the base knowledge and you
know the next level they would apply it
and the top level was
the
essential questions for the unit
and there is a word for it and i'm
completely blanking on what the word is
right now but anyway that was something
that we did a month and a half in
advance and all that was there
but that didn't include daily current
events it didn't include you know other
things that might come up and so the
point here is it's you can't always have
the two-week notice of every single
thing that's going to be happening
because if you're a good teacher you're
reflecting on everything that happens
daily and changing it like
representative lake has said you know
making up things if the kids don't
understand something you're going to
come up with something to help them the
next day but it might not be something
that you originally planned two weeks
ago when you planned your broad lessons
thank you i got it okay
representative ellison
ah thank you mr chair uh
again just a quick question
looking at the bill as as presented
would you agree with me that
it requires
every third grade teacher in the state
to
put out their curriculum materials two
weeks in advance for anything that they
would be teaching in the next two weeks
thank you yes i would agree with that
thank you representative
tanner
um could
your statement that it's very hard to
realize what people will object to
and
i was wondering if
if
it seems like this
bill is trying to be
proactive on
objectionability um
but
what do you see happens if the objection
comes from what actually happens in the
class in other words you give the
curriculum and you've got the current
events and all of a sudden the kid goes
home
student goes home
and says you know we talked about this
today and the parent says well i object
to that
how how do you feel that this
fits into this bill and and
how is this
bill going to eliminate the possibility
of that happening
thank you for the question um i don't
know that it would eliminate the
possibility the the way i'm reading this
bill is if
the current event wouldn't even be
talked about and the child wouldn't have
the opportunity to go home and say and
have the parents say object to it
because it wouldn't have come out two
weeks ahead of time
so i'm not even sure that it would
would be able to happen that way
i think you know if
the child goes home and tells a parent
what they talked about or what they did
in class that day i mean
in an ideal world the parent would get a
hold of the teacher and ask them what
happened
and have them talk about it but
according to this i don't even know that
they would have that option because it
wouldn't be out two weeks in advance
because we don't know what's happening
two weeks from now
thank you yes representative walt
thank you
so i have a daughter who's a first grade
teacher in boston and she had a parent
object this year to circle time because
circles are a pagan ritual all right
would something like that be covered by
this bill
um i don't know that i could thank you
for the question i don't know that i
could answer that i think it would be a
question for the sponsor of it because
i'm not sure of the intent when the bill
was written for that
further questions represent boom
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
the question
to curriculum for example in your
and
representative ladd's
question
is the curriculum stat says could say
current events
and we're going to use cnn
now i would think a lot of parents will
be objectionable to using cnn not the
current events just
what the source was
i mean do you agree that could be an
issue
thank you i think parents could object
to anything they could object to the
boston globe they could object to cnn
they could object to fox news they could
they could object to anything but that's
one piece of it
further questions
thank you very yes representative porter
thank you mr chair thank you miss tuttle
um maybe
earlier on i asked what happens in my
classroom my second grade classroom when
i have a 45 minute lesson that a parent
has objected to and i have two children
whose parents objected what do
do i do with those two children
if the library isn't available if the
other classes are not available to to
absorb them even though it says in the
law that the parents have to pay for it
are the parents going to come in for 45
minutes and watch the children while i
teach the rest of them and i'm wondering
if you know how that kind of stuff
in current currently is going on and if
you know what do parents do what does
teachers do when a child is a parents
have objected to something where is the
child and what who is giving them
instruction do you know thank you for
the question um no
i don't know there's i mean we could
theoretically say they could go to the
library but like you said it's not
always available or there might not be
someone watching them you don't want to
put them in you know you can't put them
in the hallway you can't put them where
i taught in pembroke the last school
that i was in i was the only eighth
grade social studies teacher so
it's not like i could put them in
another social studies classroom for a
different lesson or something i was at
that that that was me
so i
honestly don't know
where they would go or what they would
do
oh have you reversed halloween yourself
representative hall
thank you mr chair thank you for being
here thank you for taking my question so
you represent as you said 17 000
teachers
and according to representative cordelli
that this is in law already it's current
law that we have to do this have you
heard i mean i know from
40 years in the in the classroom that
if people are really up in arms about
something you're going to hear about it
is this something you've heard from all
your educators that they are wild that
this is current law of like back
um thanks for the question no
okay
thank you
further questions representative
litchfield
thank you thank you for taking the
question
i know that has been mentioned that this
bill probably has very good intent
and i know when i first heard about this
bill i envisioned it a little bit
different although i'm not in the
classroom every day and i had looked at
it more as though
let's say
that year for the english curriculum we
plan on reading these particular books
or we plan on having these particular
speakers which granted they could be
last minute um so
me interpreting in that way i'm just
wondering is there a way even is give
thoughts on how we could make this
better um that would satisfy most
parties so you know maybe it would be
fair to say that the parents have to
seek out the information in some cases
where if we're going to have a speaker
we post it online you know taking some
of this pressure off of the teachers
but my question to you is also could it
be less than two weeks notice or
what could we do to make this you look
puzzled so
hopefully you're allowed to ask
questions
no i'm just wondering because i
understand the intent and as a parent i
completely appreciate it because there
are times when i've held a child back
and said you know what that's really not
something that's something that we
discuss in the home so i can appreciate
that so i'm just wondering if you have
ideas having been in the classroom what
could we do to make this better thank
you um i think you know and i'm a parent
too i have three kids in the public
school system grades three five and um
nine
um
i
the way i'm interpreting this isn't what
you're suggesting i think putting out in
the beginning of the year as you said
for as an english teacher these are the
books we're going to be reading i think
that's completely reasonable to do and i
know that every open house that i ever
did for any you know any school i was in
keene pembroke whatever
i did all that and we all had to do that
we had to put out our list of either
you know
books we were going to read or we had to
put out what units we were going to be
teaching for me it was usually 1800 to
reconstruction and so we put that out
for parents to come in and take
i don't know that that's what this says
though
and i think it's two different things so
to make this better would be not to have
the two weeks it wouldn't be to have all
the curriculum material in there i think
it's a different um it's a different
bill or a different topic to just say
and i think i believe there is a bill
later this afternoon about putting out
by november 1st i think
your curriculum for the year i think
that's there's one coming up on that
unless i'm mistaken so i don't know if
that's going more towards what you're
asking for um but again our intent or
i'm sorry our interpretation of this is
that the two weeks is just not
reasonable for everything that could
happen in a classroom if you're a good
teacher and you're doing that reflection
nothing wrong with putting out your your
topics for the year i think you should
be doing that i think that's a very
positive thing to do and it just it lets
everybody know what's happening and
you know and and the other piece of that
too is you know as a parent i welcome
them in my classroom anytime the
principals other teachers you want to
come in and see what we're doing come on
in more of the merrier um it's hard to
do that now with getting into the
classroom but you know so
hopefully that answered a little bit
thank you
further questions we have several more
speakers here coming up represent tanner
uh thank you for letting me have the
question i just wondered uh
megan what role the
building principle or the principal
plays
in
checking
that you know someone doesn't go off the
deep end um i know i always went to my
principal because they have your back
but i'm just wondering uh
which what you see as the role of the
principal the administrator in the
building
um according to this thank you for the
question i do see the administrator as
having a big role in it because
um they should be checking that this is
done i know that for my own personal
experience when i was in the classroom
we had 10 minute walkthroughs so my
principal would be in the classroom a
lot just walking through checking in
you know i think it also depends on the
size of the school i think it's going to
be almost a burden on a lot of
administrators if you have a large
school and a lot of staff to make sure
that they're doing this constantly i
think would be a burden on them but
for further
yes representatives
thank you
um
i was just wondering if there was a
definition of course material put in if
do you think that would help
uh thank you for the question i would
have to see it
to see no but i mean just definitely i
think it would help clear it up what was
intended right i think it could help
clarify it yes thank you yes
okay further questions
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you sorry this was longer than
yesterday's no no that's that's it's a
important topic and i do have written
material that's a little different thank
you thank you
the next
individual uh with the pink card here is
uh
rusan chester
i always know you're calling on when
someone's calling on me for the first
time because they're not sure how to
pronounce the name so there's
i hope i got the last part right you got
both right it was it's very very close
it's russ sanchester for the record it's
spelt
r-u-s-s-a-n
um
thank you for allowing me to come here
and speak today on this
very important bill
i will be completely up front and say
that i am in support of this bill
as it is written
for a couple of reasons
um i've had a lot of uh experience both
as a parent an educator and a
grandparent regarding um some of the
problems that have come up over the
years with students and classroom
curriculum
this bill speaks it's
the only thing we're really taking out
of this bill is specific to sexual
education as some of the previous
speakers uh spoke earlier
they said that a lot of things are
controversial right now well when this
bill was written it was sexual education
that was controversial now everything is
controversial the bottom line is is that
i look at this bill as an opportunity
for teachers to engage closer with
parents because parents now have the
responsibility of saying no i don't want
it and why
um that they're they're more engaged
that's something that teachers have been
complaining about for years and years
and years that there is absolutely no
engagement from the parents they should
they should be welcoming and welcoming
welcoming the parents um in the parents
involvement in their students education
um
there is more transparency if you
provide
a lot of goods a lot of schools do now
they provide the curriculum at the
beginning usually by
the the usually before the start of the
school year back in my day my parents
knew that i was reading dick and jane
long before i ever started going to
school because that was the school
identified that for the parents
it also allows the student to process
with the parents
what happened during the day
so you don't have that reactive
situation going on when a student comes
home and says oh actually i have an
example my child was in kindergarten she
came home and she said and i asked her
how was school that's what we call it
was preschool actually she said didn't
like it
i asked why she said scary man
scary man came scary man talked about
scary things scary man took me to a
scary place
this was at the same time that the
daycares in massachusetts who are being
brought up on sexual abuse allegations
i was in a roar
it took us a week and a half to figure
out scary man was officer friendly
and he talked about stranger danger
because my daughter wouldn't talk about
it she was that frightened so what is
important to one person may not be
important in weather what is traumatic
to one person may not be traumatic to
another um if you have a sexually
reactive child the last thing you want
to be doing is doing certain things in a
classroom that's going to trigger that
and then the parents have to respond to
that when that child goes home and they
have no idea what happened
so it's very important that
that teachers and parents develop a
relationship um i think once upon a time
we had that i think over over the time
of becoming busy and two-parent
household to working you know no parent
in the home um that we've gotten away
with that but it's we've gotten away
from that but it's time to get back to
it it's time to get back to that
collaboration that student is a student
but it's also a child and that child the
parent has a responsibility for raising
that child and the teacher has a
responsibility for educating that child
that should be a collaboration that
should be a community bringing that
child together and raising the child up
for success with regards to the two
weeks um advance notice it's already in
the law
the bottom line is is that if you're
going to for instance let's take the
current events issue i'm going to talk
about current events and i'm going to
use
cnn and
newsmax
for my current events if if a teacher if
if a parent has a problem with this
cnn
curriculum
and doesn't have a problem with newsmax
correct as long as both sides are being
presented the parent doesn't have the
argument that they had it also allows
for especially right now with what's
going on my grandchild came home from
daycare
really upset
i knew she was upset i asked her why she
said i have to hate i have to choose and
i said choose what she says
i can't be milk chocolate anymore
my granddaughter's biracial
we taught her that i'm white chocolate
her mom's white chocolate her dad's dark
chocolate and she's milk chocolate she
came home bawling really upset she says
i can't be milk chocolate anymore i have
to choose whether i'm black or whether
i'm white and if i choose black i have
to hate you and mommy
now that's
now that's what she took
from what she was taught
had i been given the opportunity to know
that that was going on on in the
classroom i could have done one of two
things i could have said i don't agree
with that or i could have said
i could have prepared her for it so that
she wouldn't have misunderstood and
misinterpreted the lesson plan
that's why this is this bill is so
important it puts the responsibility
back on parents it takes some of the
responsibility off of the teachers and
some of the the re
re-uh
retaliation you know if we know what's
going on in this if you're telling us in
advance if you're being transparent the
likelihood that we're going to get
really angry with you as a parent is a
lot less likely the likelihood that
we're going to come to you and say my
child
said this
can we talk about it
it won't be
a situation that's attacking and and
accusatory it'll be a collaboration
it'll be a true
true
rearing and appropriate upbringing of
the child in the whole child not just
the not just the student
not just the the good human being but
the entire child by having that
relationship between a parent and a
teacher
you are creating a well-rounded human
being thank you thank you very much are
there questions from the committee
not seeing any hands thank you very much
the last speaker which we have right now
is claudia
uh istel
welcome
thank you hello i'm claudia estelle i
live in acworth
i've been a public high school teacher
for
over 30 years
and i'm currently teaching in the as an
adjunct in the community college system
um i did not prepare a statement i
apologize for not having a written
statement for you
uh as a
long-time educator
i have and certainly
that position has evolved over the
decades as i i'm sure that those of you
are educators in this room also know
that
um
so
i would provide a syllabus at the
beginning of the semester
that would outline the topics that were
going to be covered in the course
um and that was something that both and
and also a
general outline of how the grading was
going to happen and and other details
about the course and that would be
signed by the students and by their
parents so there was a general
understanding of that the
textbooks were available
obviously students had a copy of them
and parents were welcome to come look at
those as well
but specific materials as we've
discussed were planned
sometimes in advance sometimes i use
materials that i had used a previous
previously other times i was revising
them as
as we've spoken about other speakers
have said
you adjust to your students so to be
able to make curriculum materials
instructional materials on a daily basis
available two weeks in advance
is a disservice to your students
you need to modify as you are teaching
the other thing is that i don't think
anybody's spoken about and that is that
one of the goals of teaching is to make
your students be critical thinkers to
make them not only master the material
but to become independent and critical
thinkers and i'm not positive that
the
that
it's not necessarily the intent but the
actual
making this bill work
of having to have teachers put out all
their instructional materials two weeks
in advance
would
damage the quality of the education that
we could provide
and uh that you want to be able to
adjust as you go along to meet the needs
of the students and you want constantly
to be pushing them to be thinking more
deeply and more critically that's what's
going to make um
going to make good citizens in our
country thank you thank you very much
for your testimony are there questions
of the presenter
not seeing any thank you very much for
coming today thank you
with that i'm going to close the hearing
and we will prepare for the next
yes pardon me
yes thank you mr chair um yesterday jen
was kind enough to teach me how to find
out who has signed in in support or
opposition to the different bills that
we're doing we do have for right here
the
blue shield and i and yes but what's
coming online we might want to know
about the process that's just been put
up on the web for yes i don't have
access to it i do it's in front of me
jen showed me well would you please then
announce the number one one together
that's what i was going to do mr chair
so on this bill um 20 people have signed
in in support 194 people have signed in
in opposition and zero have been neutral
thank you thank you very much
yeah that that that uh site was just put
up as a link right there in the front of
our house education house
uh general court site
yesterday
okay
we will prepare to go here into the next
bill for today which is scheduled to
occur here at
10 o'clock
relatives to state board of education
rules for the credit for alternative
extended learning and work based
programs
okay
the prime sponsor is that you represent
tanner
we need a little pink one
okay thank you
great
and anybody else that cares to speak
you're more than welcome to get a card
so with that i'd like to welcome
representative tanner to speak on this
bill
thank you mr chair
um for the record i'm linda tanner
representative
for sullivan district 9
the towns of plainfield cornish grantham
croydon
newport sunapee springfield
and unity
the learn everywhere program or
alternative education opportunities
was developed in 2020
uh by the department of education under
the commissioner edelblut
um
and at that time
i had considerable concerns about
student safety consumer protection and
information for parents
because it was taking the program
currently in schools as a work study
program or an alternative education
program
where
many schools had directors
had hired people
to be
to oversee the program
and those people
were in contact with local people
they um
set up
opportunities uh went and vetted the
the groups that were offering those
alternatives um they overs they actually
oversaw the the
way that the students set up the program
with whether it met competencies
whether it was worth credit in the
school
they troublesh
they were troubleshooters for anything
that happened
while the student was in those
alternative
uh situations
if there happened to be a problem with
the instructor or problem with
transportation anything like that and
that was my major concern was that um
not that
i don't think alternative
situations are not helpful
or needed uh for many high school or
many middle sc even middle school
students
to go out and see the world to to get
outside the
the walls of the classroom and
experience
the relevancy of what you're teaching in
the classroom
and i thought
just opening this program
you know to the world
uh and allowing parents
uh
the ability the the responsibility of
taking over
all the duties that this person in the
school that i was well aware of what
they had been doing
that now the parents had that
responsibility totally put on them
i was concerned about that and
at the time the the program was fairly
i wouldn't say controversial but it
certainly had
people had
issues with the program but the program
passed it passed the school the state
school board by a four to three
vote and one of the one of the issues
that happened was that
there was a lot of concern about okay
now you're opening it to profit
nonprofit
educational groups and we know that
just looking at colleges how colleges
recruit students and
and the slick um when money is involved
all of a sudden things get a lot slicker
and there's a lot of advertising and a
lot of um
not so real information um you get to
the college and all of a sudden it isn't
exactly what you thought it was
um
but uh
so i am glad
that the um
state school boards and the
board of education the department of
education
went about and set up a whole set of
rules
and again
as i spoke earlier in this committee i
really had difficulty finding
rules that were applicable to different
areas and
but once i found the rules i realized
that they have quite a
set of rules to vet
um third party education providers and
they have a
website on the doe that that actually
has good information about the different
groups that are offering
these educational experiences and um
their application processes is pretty
extensive
um my concern was that when i looked at
the who actually reviews these
that there was a
one teacher one teacher currently
teaching in the schools on that
committee uh and
no more than two
so i thought that was a little bit
could be changed could be looked at
but
this is in rules and i think we heard
from
attorney fenton that the rules change
and some of them expire some of them are
not kept over
and so my um one of my atten intents of
uh putting this bill in
is to put this in as
a statue
so so
the we have the doe rules um if at any
point those rules are changed or
at least the basics basics of having a
committee
that actually vets these third party um
the third party groups will be in law so
that's that's mainly my
uh intent
and i've passed out to the um committee
the rules on this from
the department of education that i
finally got a hold of thank you very
much
are there questions for representative
tanner
representative luna
thank you very much
mr chair and thank you very much
representative tanner for introducing
this bill
um
it's um
it's hard to figure this out but um and
this is sort of a somewhat related
question
to rules and and what the department um
you know is doing with respect to the
learn everywhere program
but um it's come to my attention that
the the learn everywhere program is a
copyrighted
um
like the learn everywhere term is
copyrighted for programs i believe it is
um when i when i was on the website and
everything i went to the bottom and and
i'm i'm pretty sure that it was
copyrighted there's a copyright thing
after it okay and uh follow-up mr chair
yes um
and so this is sort of a would you
believe
uh type of thing but would you believe
that if a term is copyrighted that in
order to preserve the copyright
um or to certainly
uh preserve a license associated with a
copyright
that in the first use the first
um
yeah use of that term on a web page or
in a booklet or in a manual or something
like that has to actually include the
copyright um notice
it's a would you believe no
i was just surprised that it that it was
copyrighted it was something that i i
noticed so okay great thank you very
much further questions for
representative tanner
nazi yes representative cordelli
thank you mr chairman
thank you mr chairman um thank you
representative
um
am i correct in that the one change here
is that the um
credits
must be accepted by the local school
board is
or maybe
maybe maybe right but they
um so basically
the role of the state board in this
whole process
is uh changing
in that
um
there has to be a local approval process
as well for any uh credits to be granted
um i think
the bill that we talked about before
that i believe you introduced where uh
it was mandatory
that the school ex accept uh the credits
is is
being put before us
to actually change the change the law
i think the law originally was
that they may be accepted and they could
be up to one third of the credits for
graduation
any follow-up are you good
further questions represent porter
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative tina so my understanding
is this the state board of education
does have rules of how these
organizations are vetted and you want to
make sure that that gets
put into statute so those rules
continue
continue are you at all concerned with
the language of this bill that
that those rules could change anyway
because it says
um shall adopt rules that establish a
process
so that the rules are already there
this goes in
can the department then go in and change
their rules that so still there's an
application process in vetting but
they're different than
what you see here what we see i think
that's a good question i mean i think
i think one of one of my intents was
also to bring this up for discussion and
the fact that um
a lot of the issues in the in the rules
section
you know um perhaps like the the um
panel that reviews the third party uh
you know perhaps that's something in
future
once this is in law can be amended and
or put into statute
uh i have a question for you uh
representative uh
you you have in their approval of
vendors
are we talking uh uh various businesses
which may have an individual on the
floor for example like new england wire
and a work based program
are we talking about uh
other public schools or career technical
education centers or other nonprofits
exactly what is the definition of vendor
here well i think it's a third party
uh group that that's offering uh
educational services um
and so you know certainly the career and
technical uh education that is part of
our public school system that um you
know i think that that certainly is
is not a third party vendor
but uh prenda would be a third-party
vendor
so in follow-up uh when a career tax
center has a student
gaining
competencies
through the work based program they have
established which might be nafa auto
care
is naf auto care now a vendor or or how
does that work well i think they're
that's something that the committee
that's studying uh career and technical
education and credits that would be
something that they would then approve
it's something that has legislative
oversight
versus something that is uh
putting in an application to the learn
everywhere program
uh as a third party vendor
are there any further questions for the
representative
nazi thank you very much
is sarah scott here
welcome back sarah
all right good to see you guys all again
today
um thank you mr chairman and members of
the committee for the opportunity to
testify here today my name is sarah
scott and i'm the director of grassroots
operations with americans for prosperity
new hampshire
and on behalf of afp new hampshire and
our activists all across the state
i urge you to oppose house bill 1051
which would change the rule making
authority for the state board of
education to implement the learn
everywhere program
as we talked about yesterday since
launching at the end of 2020
over 10 providers have been approved and
the majority of those were in the last
six months which has given thousands of
new hampshire students access to high
school credit for the learning that
they're already participating in
so this legislation would drastically
change the learn everywhere program by
requiring providers to be approved at a
local level as well
this creates a substantial barrier to
providers in the program and i think
would discourage many if not all from
applying to the program
the current role established a process
by which the
provider may apply to be a learn
everywhere provider and these
applications go through a rigorous
approval process by the department of
education it's reviewed by certified
teachers and then the state board of
education and by changing this to a
district level we're then asking
providers to go through an application
process at the state level and then move
down to the local level to make sure
that their students would get credit for
these classes
the application process is very time
consuming and it has been worthwhile for
these providers because it's something
that once they get through the process
their students are immediately able to
get credit from their local schools
this legislation would really create a
level of inequality among districts and
we would be left in a situation where
similar to the extended learning
opportunities not every district is able
to participate
the current process is really the
ultimate level of local control because
we're giving parents the option to
choose which classes their children
attend
so it's really for these reasons that we
ask that you recommend this legislation
as an expedient to legislate and
continue to allow these high school
students to get credit for the learning
that's taking place
representative cornell
thank you thank you for taking my
question and appearing here again today
i'm not seeing in the the bill where it
says the local district in addition to
the state board has to approve the um
the
the program i i do see that it says it
may be accepted and i think we discussed
that if it doesn't meet you know the
competencies
so could you tell me what line says the
school district has to in addition to
the state board approve sure thank you
for the question representative um so
we're looking at a situation now in
which
these providers would then have to go to
the local school to explain the program
and explain how their course meets the
competencies
and they would be dragged into a further
process of explaining their program a
lot of organizations when they
first heard about learn everywhere
were interested in becoming approved
based on the fact that they could offer
this program to all of their students
first robotics is one example of that
right now they're not operating in every
school district and this was an
opportunity because they wanted to
provide this education for all of the
new hampshire students and so by going
district by district to explain
the same thing that was just approved by
the state board of education is
something that they don't have the
bandwidth to do
representative porter
thank you mr chair and i'm really
confused about this
this line i'm reading directly from the
bill
line
seven
nothing in this sub-paragraph
shall prevent a local school district
from approving vendors offering credit
for alternative extended learning or
work based programs which do not appear
on the pre-approved list
maintained by the school board
so it's not saying in my way of reading
this that the local just the the learn
everywhere vendors need to come to the
local schools to get approval what it is
saying is the school board itself can
also approve other learn everywhere type
programs that are not on the school on
the learn any career program provided by
the state
so i'm not seeing how you can say
that this would force your learn
everywhere people to come to every local
school board
so um based on that i actually have no
disagreement with that part i think that
local school districts should absolutely
be able to approve things in addition to
the approved list by the state board i'm
looking at the line before that that
says that the credit may be accepted
currently the credit is accepted so this
would make a change to say that it only
may be accepted which means that if a
district has questions about a program
and says no the provider
would then have to go into the school
and explain what their program is that
they just went through at the state
level process thank you thank you i have
a question um and a little follow-up to
where we were yesterday with hb 1329
and i communicated so this will be a
question it was communicated to me that
there are some
schools specifically i have had it
directed to me
that a school will not accept credit
from an alternative
program
due to the fact that we teach that in
our school and this is sacred turf for
our school we will award the credit for
this particular course and subject
matter is done
have have you been aware of that
occurring in the state or elsewhere and
in in case how then would we get
help for the student who is off cycle
and scheduled in the high school and the
course they're offering isn't being
offered when they need it and they can
go and get it over here
and graduate in a timely manner with of
the rest of the class
uh thank you for the question so um in
terms of schools not approving credit i
haven't heard of any district that has
not accepted a learn everywhere credit
until like up until now i have not heard
of that but i know that this was an
issue that
was fixed last year by this legislature
to make sure that credits from all new
hampshire public high schools were
approved
so far we have not had any issues with
learn everywhere credits being approved
based on the process that they go
through at the state level it's very
clear what the competencies are and what
courses
they meet based on that i know there's a
speaker after me who can speak uh more
to that in a greater level of detail
though
thank you uh
thank you other further questions
i don't believe we have another pink
card
okay so
for me
well drew would you like to speak
thank you very much i'd like uh
welcome drew klein uh to our hearing
today uh
chairman of the state board of education
is your mic andrew
uh there you go got it all right oh
there we go
um
so i'm drew klein i'm chairman of the
state board of education thank you for
the opportunity i wanted to give you a
little bit of background on
um learn everywhere and how it works but
first say that i'm i'm strongly opposed
to this bill it would destroy the
learner everywhere program
um the way the learn everywhere program
works is
programs apply
so if somebody
private
private program non-profit or profit
wants to become part of learn everywhere
program they submit an application to
the department of education
the department then has staff that
review that application very thoroughly
they go back and forth they create a
team
that evaluates the application once it
is vetted by the department of education
um and they have to go through a
checklist to make sure it meet it aligns
with state standards that it meets state
competencies that everybody who has
contact with not just instructors
everybody in the program who has contact
with a student has to pass a criminal
background check there's a long list of
hurdles they have to to get over
then it comes before the state board of
education
the state board of education then also
reviews it
and we approve it or not
um we have had a few applications that
we did not approve we sent back because
they we had questions about how they
worked their details weren't very clear
and then we had a uh
we had them come back they were
im improved and we approved them
once a learn everywhere program is
approved by the state board we have 11
right now that are approved
um
a student can enroll in that program
receive
um
credits to get a credit
they have to demonstrate that they've
met the competencies
i think this is really important for
everybody to understand
um this is not just well you can go play
sports on some team and um you know
whatever you choose and you can you know
come in and get a pe credit for it they
have to demonstrate that they've met the
competencies and that
and that requires evaluation so every
program that is approved
has to demonstrate to the department and
to the board that they have an
evaluation system process we see which
competencies the kid meets
and we see the credits and how that
aligns uh with the credits that are
required and with the state standards it
has to be line of state standards
once it's approved
then a parent can enroll a child in that
program
once the child completes the learn
everywhere program
they
are awarded a basically a certificate of
completion that they've earned the
credit then they take that back to their
school district and the district has to
accept it
now i want to explain why we did it that
way
first that's consistent with new
hampshire's competency-based system so
all of you should know
in 2005 the state board of education and
the department of education created new
hampshire's state competency-based
instruction system
so and that was
something that began in the 1990s we had
a pilot program with 27 districts from
98 to
to test competency-based education new
hampshire
and in 2005 we adopted rules
that switched new hampshire
every school district in new hampshire
is is competency-based the rules are
competency-based
that means that students
get
credit
for high school
credit their graduation credits
based on demonstration that they've
mastered competencies
in the rule by rule that was passed in
students do not have to spend a minute
in class to get a course credit or to
demonstrate the competencies i will read
those rules to you it's
rule 306.27
credits shall be based on demonstration
of district and or graduation
competencies not on the time spent
achieving those competencies
the credit shall equate to the level of
rigor of academic necessity and so forth
students may receive acknowledgement
this is i
of achievement for graduation
competencies through student
demonstration of a collection of work
other than a assessment evidence gained
through pri i'm sorry or
other assessment of evidence gained
through prior learning activities
that's pre-existing rule we didn't write
that
that's that predated learn everywhere
learn everywhere was designed to be
consistent with that
so the way the program works is the
students
demonstrate they've met the competencies
that leads to the credit
and then they take that back to the
school district that is perfectly
consistent with the way new hampshire
has operated since 2005.
so i wanted to make that very clear
now when we started the public hearings
and the rulemaking process on there and
everywhere we had a vigorous debate at
the board of education and and there was
disagreement over whether we should
require write the rules so that the
student
could take the credit back and the
district would have to recognize the
credit and award credit for that or
whether the district may
recognize it and award credit
and
when we started to hear from the
programs that would potentially
wanted to apply
they told us in the public hearing in no
uncertain terms many of them did
that if we wrote the rules so that the
districts had an option of denying the
credit
they would not create a learn everywhere
program and first robotics did a really
good job of explaining how this would
work
in their testimony
they explained that they're already in
schools in new hampshire
and their experience i mean they're all
over the world
um
and i think this testifies to the need
for lean everywhere first robotics has
been in
new hampshire schools for years
and none of the kids was able to get a
credit
for
science math or business by doing the
first robotics program only through loon
everywhere can a student now get a
credit for participation in that program
and it is very rigorous
um they explained to us we would not
do a program we wouldn't go to the
effort of creating
cte programs because those would change
district to district we can't scale that
statewide
with learn everywhere we can create one
program
and scale it statewide and it's equal
so every kid whether you're in lebanon
or bedford or claremont or charlestown
if you have a
first robotics program you get the same
program you get the same credit so it
equalizes it out but it also makes it
um easier on
on them because if we didn't have that
they would have to go to each individual
district
and tailor the program to that
district's needs that's not workable for
a group like first robotics so that's
why we did it this way it creates equity
it creates a level playing field every
child in the state has access to the
same or everywhere programs and
um
from an investment of the of the
family's time
and money and resources and energy it
also makes it worthwhile so this way we
prevented and we heard this concern too
that we prevented a situation where a
parent would enroll in a learn
everywhere program
and then
find out that their district had a
problem with it and wouldn't accept the
credit
so this guarantees that kids will get
the credits if they go through the
program and it is very thoroughly vetted
and i can i can share with you if you'd
like i don't want to take up too much
time the examples of some of the
programs that we have um authorized
they're fabulous programs um
uh there's a list on the state website
that
you know outlines them all but
uh
so i just i want to highlight just a
couple real quick um new hampshire
academy of science and lyme
so
prior to lint everywhere kids were going
to the hampshire academy of science and
lime
where science is taught by dartmouth
professors
and it is rigorous lab based science
program and they were not allowed to get
academic credit for that they had to go
back to school in their high school
wherever it was and take that same
science class over again
now they get credit for that
seacoast science center we approved so i
don't know how many of you familiar with
this fabulous program they have a marine
biology program kids can get credit for
now it's fantastic
first robotics the boys and girls club
of souhegan valley
has a theater program
they created a learn everywhere theater
program so you can now get academic
credit for participating in their
theater but it is not just for showing
up and acting in a play
they had to create a structure that
showed that the kids got competencies
there they have
instructors there are volunteers but
they have
instructors with bachelor's degrees in
arts and one who's got a master's in
education so it's a it's a rigorous
program
um seacoast united
uh the soccer and i think the baseball
two um program they have a very rigorous
program to get pe credits and i was very
skeptical of the pe stuff i have to say
right off the bat because my thinking
was right how are you going to
demonstrate that you've got to
competencies but they gave us a very
thorough rigorous proposal that outlined
how the kids are going to be evaluated
they demonstrate progress on their
health and their capabilities
and whether they gain skills and they
have a wellness component of the program
it's very good program and we vetted it
very fairly and so those are the kinds
of examples of programs that you can do
through and everywhere and get credits
statewide and we've approved some some
online programs cooman academy for
example has a very rigorous math program
now the benefit of this statewide is
that you can take this online so no
matter where you are in new hampshire
you can get access to kumon academy and
you can take algebra and trigonometry
and get credit for that so that's how it
works and if there are any and the
reason why this bill would destroy the
program is because it would give
districts ability to
to not accept that credit and um and
that was just not workable
thank you very much chairman uh
represent luna
thank you very much mr chair thank you
very much chairman klein for joining us
this morning
um
just a
couple of um a couple of questions
tied in with your um with your testimony
but you'd mentioned the
competencies and alignment with state
standards i was wondering on the um in
the uh
uh where where the improved programs are
listed does it also include the uh the
competencies and alignment so that um
um
out of transparency so that parents and
teachers and students
uh can understand um to what level of
rigor these were approved by the state
board so on on the website are you
asking is it is that on the website just
just anywhere available um i'm not sure
how
we lost at the department a
communications person a while back and
then we so our website is a little
lagging but it is in the packet and in
the program approval itself um if it's
not posted online i agree with you we
should we should post it online i'm not
sure i mean i can click through but i
want to spend time doing that right um
but
uh
it
so when you when you enroll in this
program
you should get
um you know a
a sort of layout of how it works right
if you're a student you're enrolling so
you will see
how it progresses what the assessments
are and that kind of thing but um i'm
not sure if the parents can actually see
you know like so when you when you take
a course in a regular public school you
don't
see okay we got the quiz here the quiz
aligns with this competency that's not
how it's you actually
you do get that in the course but the
parent what i'm saying is the parent
doesn't necessarily see that
um when they have the the syllabus so um
i'm happy to to make sure that that is
included if it's not okay okay thank you
and uh and just one follow-up on that mr
chair sure um and and thanks for that
thanks for that that information should
be available certainly from a
transparency standpoint but do i don't
and i'm like i said i'm on uh i think
the same page that you're on now with
approved um courses
and um
do any of these um
learn everywhere um
um
opportunities come at a cost to the
student yeah some of them have a have a
tuition cost okay and a final follow-up
but we have asked and just to clear to
to clarify some of them do have a cost
we um
ask every program when they apply if
they have um
any sort of scale or reduced costs and
all of them that we've approved
have uh reduced cost for for kids who um
you know have struggled for that some of
them offer it free some of them offered
a reduced cost
thank you and follow up on that i
promise this is my last but but based on
that
um and based on the londonderry decision
how is a cost to a student for a
graduation credit even constitutional
so the learn everywhere program
was created to make sure that students
can get credit
for stuff they're doing and learning
outside of the classroom so
again because we have a competency-based
system right
as i read in the rules from
you know 8327
all a student has to do to get a credit
is demonstrate that they've mastered the
competency so they don't have to enroll
in any program they can take a test and
demonstrate that they've mastered a
competency so this program
allows them
to demonstrate that they've mastered
gives them a certificate at the end of
the program to allow them to do that
but it doesn't exclude
doing that in other ways right outside
of this program so in other words i
don't think there's a constitutional
issue here
because
it is simply a means of allowing them to
demonstrate that they earn the
competency okay thank you sure thank you
i do have one question for you and then
i'll get representative porter um
knowing that the concept of our the uh
principle of competencies was put in
effect back in virginia barry's days as
commissioner correct prior to 2005 and
it was a move forward to get away from
seat time
uh required seat time before you go on
to the fourth grade and sixth grade et
cetera right um so when we're looking at
the competencies which we're offering
for the the high school level for a
course let's say in chemistry
and and hypothetically there may be five
or seven competencies built in for that
course or program
when we're at the learn everywhere
program and a student has mastered like
four out of seven
competencies do they get partial credit
or
how does that work
no to my understanding the way we
structured it is um
well i'm going to do this this way
when you
competencies and credits are different
so
the learner program is designed to get
you a credit
at the end that you can then get you
know get counted towards your graduation
credits
if you have demonstrated
competencies that maybe four of the
seven as you said you won't get the
credit
so i don't know i mean i suppose a
student could go to
their school and say look i've
i've learned i've earned the
competencies i think the school could
could probably say well you know
it's not a credit
you'll have to pass our test to show
that you actually know the company says
i think that probably would be how it
worked um
you know but i don't
i don't know of an instance of that
right now but the way this program's
structured you have to get it's the
credit at the end
that you take back and get full credit
for
i i understand
and for that and that competencies might
be spread over and the student may have
missed the first three or four
took that through learn everywhere
program right and then could pick up the
other uh in the second semester that was
just the
question and a concern i think it can be
found yeah i mean i think that's
something the parent can and the family
can work out with the school we've we've
earned these competencies we can
demonstrate that the student has earned
the competencies and we can count that i
mean i think that would be appropriate
thank you very much uh representative
porter thank you mr chairman thank you
mr klein for for indulging me here a
little bit sure um
one denigration of our local public
schools that we've been hearing a lot is
to call them government schools
so our schools are no longer being
referred to as the public schools but
the government schools
by
bypassing
local school boards
in this process
my fear is that you're propagating that
image of government schools because we
have the state approving what you need
what you can use for graduation and i i
i applaud the um competency-based
education i think sounds like the
programs that you're using are wonderful
my concern is that somewhere along the
line
the local schools and the local
communities have been left out of this
learn everywhere process
so that they no longer
feel that the schools are theirs
and that the the
insult of calling them government
schools becomes more real and i'm
wondering if you can address my concern
on this because i'm i'm deeply
passionate about our local public
schools and i'm deeply hoping that our
local control can make be maintained
through these stressful times that we're
experiencing now with funding and those
sorts of things um sure thank you for
the question um i i don't believe i've
referred to the schools that way and
um and i just want to know we have heard
i have heard it several times in this
room okay um
that's just not i think conceptually i'm
not sure i would fall in that category
um
so
i i guess i'll back up a little bit um
again to go back to the competency-based
system we have we already have rules and
these were nonpartisan
non-controversial i mean you know maggie
hassan when she was governor was a very
big proponent of competency-based
education
um i i don't
i just don't think there's a partisan
divide here i think everybody's pretty
much on board and so those rules uh
learn everything is perfectly consistent
with
the way we do competencies in new
hampshire and that is
um and i think there's some
misunderstanding i mean i know i've had
conversations with folks outside of the
system who don't quite understand
um
the credits and competencies are
structured first
and then the curriculum is written to
meet those so it's not the other way
around so i think that's just
conceptually
what some people don't understand so
when we were doing learn everywhere we
were told well this is you know you're
bypassing the curriculum but that's
not the way the system works the system
works so that the student
demonstrates competency
the curriculum is written to get the
student to the competency but our system
is structured before learn everywhere in
such a way that a student could come in
and demonstrate that they know the stuff
and not have to sit in the class and go
through the curriculum i mean that's
just the way the system works
so
and so i think thinking of it in in
conceptually that learn everywhere
is
taking away local control or bypassing
that control over curriculum is not the
right way to think of it because again
learn everywhere is consistent with the
competency-based system where we're just
saying students
can demonstrate that they have a
competency and they get credit for that
yes but
okay so yes please so i i'm a kid and i
go and i have a competency in the
russian language and i go in and i meet
the competencies
for for
demonstrating that i have enough
competency to whatever
i go to my local school board
to get that credit
that's how that works outside of this
program somebody has to approve that and
say yes indeed this child has met these
competencies and my understanding has
been that in the past
that's the role and the function of the
local school board and
and i'm just so conflicted because now
they're not in it anymore anything that
you say is okay has to be okay and
anything
but
it just feels like they should be in
there somewhere so that the local
control can be maintained at least
superficially
well i i guess i would again just
address it um
from the standpoint that
the the rules the 300s i mean the way
the rules are written
for public school districts are i mean
every almost everyone starts with shall
right so
superintendents shall the school board
shall district shall the teachers i mean
it's all shall shall shall
and um
just conceptually again
that's the way our system has been
forever and the company the cte programs
that were created
um
read through the rules on those it's all
the district shall the school shall
um you know there was resistance in the
beginning from some districts to do the
cte programs so the cte rules are full
of districts shall do this they shall
make these available they shall do so
so the idea that
the districts have total
control outside of the state for
deciding these things is just not
accurate the state sets the rules and
guides what the districts can do and
can't do
and
and how competencies are to be met and
that's just the way the system has
worked for a very long time and so learn
everywhere is just a way to say
we're recognizing that students are
learning and earning
competencies outside of
the school itself in this other way so
we're going to create a program that can
scale statewide
and allow kids the opportunity to
demonstrate that they've done that so
again i just i don't think it's really
that inconsistent with the way we've
done things before
sure
thank you
very quick i think
thank you for taking my question
i think going back one question you did
say that if all the competencies weren't
met like if they only met
three out of the seven the school
district does not have to accept that as
a credit yeah because they didn't me
they didn't get the credit so the school
district can't say no
not if they get the credit
but if they don't meet the if they don't
meet the competencies the school
district can say no you did not meet the
competencies for this credit so i'm a
little the way with the rules was all
geared towards um the credit
right so the kid so the rules are if
they can if they earn the credit
then the school has to accept the credit
now we have pre-existing rules that
govern demonstration of competencies
and so and again i'm
i wasn't prepared and think of it that
way so i don't want to give you a
definitive answer but my guess is that
if you've met some of the competencies
but haven't earned the credit
then you would have to show the school
district that you've met those
competencies and that would be something
you'd work out with the district i think
i that's just the way i kind of
understand it because the way the rules
are written they're all geared towards
the credit
but i could go back and check
and have somebody get back to you if
you'd like that would be fine
thank you mr chair and welcome to house
education
um and thank you for taking my credit
my question give me credit for the
question um
so
um
chairman klein is there any provision
for instructor evaluation in the learn
everywhere program
off the top of my head
i'd have to go back for the rules and
see how we how we wrote that um the
instructors are not required to be
certified teachers obviously
they are required to pass criminal
background checks
and the way we've worked it
with
with these applicants is that
we do ask them
we want to see who their instructors are
and um
you know what their qualifications are
so we get that i'm not sure
off top my head how the rules address it
can i just have one quick follow-up mr
chair um
so with regards to um
instructional materials yeah
they give that to us are there rules or
is there a process by which you're
looking at instructional materials and
does it come within two weeks of
instruction
[Laughter]
actually
so
one of the things that's fun about doing
these roles at the state board and
having the flexibility to write the
rules ourselves and making sure that
that's not all written in law is that we
have the flexibility to adjust and so
one of the things we learned from our
application process last year was that
we needed to tighten up the rule around
materials so we actually um in november
i think it was we proposed changes to
the river rules that would clarify
um that they have to give us their
instructional materials and curriculum
we have to see that we were getting it
beforehand but it wasn't written in the
rule and we just wanted to clarify that
i was in a rule so we are getting that
um and it is going to be going forward
part of the rule that's finalized and
then
um
i don't think the rule spells out
specifically that
they have to show that to the parent
because they give it to us and we
approve it but i don't see any objection
to making sure the parents see all the
materials ahead of time
thank you sure
thank you representative
very quick thank you very much mr chair
um thanks for taking my question
mr chair um do um do non-public schools
under contract with a school district
have to accept these credits
no
under contract with the school district
so you're talking about pinkerton
academy
pinkerton would be an example but but
i'm sure there are are others under
contract with public schools um i'd have
to go back and clarify i believe that
would be correct if you are um
a public academy
i assume you're included but i i'd have
to go back and check follow up just to
clarify
i'm really not limiting it to public
academy i'm limiting it to non-public
schools
which which i believe encompass
everything except
public schools
okay so all non-public schools whether
that be anything that's not a school
district not a public no no we're not
regulating non-public schools on this
this is for public schools so so if you
have if you had a contract in the
republic academy and you were
functioning as a public school i think
you'd be covered but if you're just in a
non-private school we don't make no no
i'm saying a non-public school under
contract with a with a school district
um if you could if you could follow up
on yeah i can i can find that out for
you i gotta
i can definitely get it
on maybe a lot of other questions
sure happy to get that thank you very
much okay uh are there any further
questions
this is the last question
representative ford
always leave it to a president of a
college go ahead thank you mr chairman
and thank you mr general to take you
back
my question has to do with a different
subset of students than we've been
talking about so far this morning
there are increasing numbers of students
who come from cultures countries where
they speak languages we don't typically
teach
hindi urdu things like that
we focus usually in the schools on
european languages
so french spanish german that sort of
thing
and i'm wondering if this process would
allow someone who
had a very high level of competency
which can be ascertained there are
companies that do that and the colleges
and universities use them and wanted to
assert
that he had fulfilled a foreign language
con
competency which the school system does
not offer
in that language would he nonetheless be
able to do that he or she well uh right
now we have no foreign language programs
approved through learn everywhere so um
in that program itself no but we do have
an applicant that has come in for
spanish so hopefully we'll have a
spanish program approved soon
but under so under learn everywhere you
can only do it through the approved
programs but
under the 30
6.27 i think um
or 329 forget the name but under the
competency-based rules um
theoretically
you could go to a school district and
say um yeah i've demonstrated the
competency in this language um
but if that school district doesn't
offer that language i'm not sure
about that
but that's outside of learn everywhere
that's yeah yeah well healey is my reach
too for one they don't teach but
that's that's what concerns me though is
because there was a superintendent
recently who had gotten a fight with his
board and one of the things they accused
him of was wanting to teach the students
spanish
well um hopefully we'll have a learn
everywhere program that will allow them
to get that credit
thank you very much this hearing is
closed
we're going to take a three-minute break
or four-minute break for the committee
members who've been sitting here for a
long time to get up and stretch a little
bit and then we'll start the other
hearing up i believe that's one that
represent cordelia's going to be doing
at 11 o'clock
thank you
as part of being chair you know when you
take a break getting all the squirrels
back is kind of tough
okay
so uh marching on along our agenda for
today we have uh hb 1125 in front of us
it's relative to school emergency plans
and i'd like to
welcome representative cordelli to the
committee
thank you always
nice to testify testify before the
education committee
uh for the record uh glenn cordelli
state representative for tuftonboro
moultonborough on sandwich in the
beautiful lakes region
and uh hb
is legislation that i worked with the
department on
school safety is
always
a high priority for all of us
and several terms ago um some of you
might remember um there was a
requirement uh passed for uh school
emergency plans to be provided uh to the
department
um they got off to a little bit of a
rocky start um in terms of compliance
but it
finally
got accomplished
but
the
law required
that the plans be sent to the department
of education
and the way things have worked is that
that's not really
the path that has been followed and that
the plans go to homeland security
so this bill was
put in
to reflect the process
and i know there are people behind me
who will testify more to that
but i'll just mention also that i do
have an amendment because the process
has um
uh caught up with technology uh maybe
we'll put it that way and there is now a
portal for the department of homeland
security department of safety and plans
are provided in that fashion and access
can be provided to the department
via the portal so that they have access
to these plans as well and that's what
is addressed in the amendment um but
with that um
i'll end my testimony and i know uh
others can
testify in more detail if there are
questions are there questions for
representative cardelli
years ago a representative cordelia when
director plumber perry plummer and we
put this together
and we had
that homeland security
digitizing all our emergency plans which
was wonderful and we finally did get
them together a little bit of a
hammer to do that but we got them
collected
now with that process occurring and with
what you're offering here
is your amendment going to move to the
point where the doe is
the plans don't shoot straight to
homeland security they
there's a way for
the department also to have access to
that information for various reasons i
won't go down all those sure um yes the
actual
addition uh in the amendment specifies
access to all plans shall be provided to
the department of education thank you
thank you
any further questions
not seeing any thank you very much
thank you for uh short testimony
i'd like to have caitlin davis please
from the department
welcome to both of you
good morning for the record i'm caitlin
davis i'm a director of the department
of education and uh for the record my
name's amy clark and i'm with school
safety and facility management with the
department of education
welcome thank you for taking the time to
talk to us i do actually want to point
out there's a third person um behind us
and i believe she filled out a pink card
as well director harper from homeland
security um so she might be a part of
kind of this conversation um we're
having so
would you like to have jennifer up here
right with you at the same time we could
put a third chair yeah i think i think
we would well and i can maybe step back
and i'll explain it and then we'll i'll
let amy and it would be good
and jennifer went for amy's been a part
of that for quite a while exactly
exactly so um first of all i would like
to thank representative cordelli for
putting this bill in um
the
as he explained kind of historically the
department of homeland security and
department of education have worked
together to collect and review
um school emergency operation plans but
there's still a little bit of
challenge with the way that the current
law reads and i think a little bit of
confusion with the agencies that could
be straightened out in the legislation
going forward so in the past the
department of education was the person
or the group that was required to um
collect the plans
we at the time didn't have a great way
of doing it and homeland security took
the time to develop this very beautiful
portal that i think we would like to use
at the department of education for other
reasons too
and we they're currently using that
portal to collect the
school emergency operations plans they
also have the staff that review the
school emergency operations plans
but the weird kind of delineation is is
the department of education collects the
information the contact information with
the schools
um and a lot of times receives questions
back from the department of age from
from schools and whatnot relative to the
work that's being done by homeland
security
um we also um
you know we work with homeland security
to give them the data and whatnot that
they're they need
for con or for contact or we would if
you know we do what they need and what
they request
but there's still just a lot of
confusion about what the department of
education does versus homeland security
for the external participants
another um
kind of challenge is that
both agencies i think spend an
extraordinary amount of time
following up to make sure that these
plans are collected on time and neither
agency nor the department of education
or homeland security have the ability to
do anything if we don't receive
a plan on time so the amount of staff
personnel time that it takes to follow
up and make sure these plans are
collected
is quite a bit and we have had meetings
with homeland security you know asking
if we had any teeth or if there were
anything that we could do at the
department of education if we didn't
have a plan and there's nothing that we
can do right now
that we believe either so
um as far as the process and whatnot i'm
going to sit back i'll let director
harper come up here as well
and amy can provide any questions or
answers to the committee as far as the
process or what we're kind of looking
forward going forward and the way that
the bills are in right now
is not necessarily what needs to be done
in the long term but there's just areas
of clarity that need to go one way or
the other as far as what the legislature
would like the process to be between the
two agencies just because of kind of
where we are right now thank you very
much caitlyn
so we'll replace you a jennifer harper i
also know there was a hammer that we did
have to make sure those plans got in
there was no infrastructure funds are
provided
until those plans were received and
within a couple weeks all of them came
on board so thank you for helping do
that amy and jennifer and amy welcome
can we
have any testimonies do you want to
present to us on this bill sure good
morning my name is jennifer harper i'm
the director for homeland security and
emergency management
so
caitlin
kind of started out a little bit but i
would
just like to say that
up front
i had to check whether i oppose or
whether i support the bill i support it
but not as written
so
um i think that as it's written it
doesn't address an all-hazards approach
to planning
that meets an established career
criteria used in the field of emergency
management
so we weren't asked for any fiscal
impact statement on this change and we
feel there is an impact to taking on
this additional responsibility
contemplated in the bill
so according to 189 64
hsem it says shall
assist school districts in conducting
training for and providing support to
school districts in the development
implementation review of emergency
response plan as may be needed so one of
the things that we need to correct is
that term emergency
response plan it's not an emergency
response plan it's the emergency
operations plan so a little bit there
anything outside of that piece in 18964
is above and beyond what hsem is
authorized
or funded to do by statute
so
for example the current repository for
submissions like caitlyn said
is at hsem we host that platform the
plans come in we share them with doe
[Music]
then
doe goes back to the schools says hey
you haven't submitted they come in to us
we report back to them so it's a lot of
back and forth
um
as caitlyn said they get a lot of
questions that come in to them about
school plans and looking for guidance
those questions come to my staff
to answer them so there's a
increased burden to ensuring that i have
the staff available to make sure that
when the submissions come in
they get the technical assistance on how
to develop their plan that meets a
statute
and so it we're looking to
clarify the legislation a little bit so
that it's not just a check mark right we
want to make sure that schools are safe
that teachers administrators sau
all the people there and the leadership
responsibilities
know what to do if something were to
happen within their school which their
emergency operations plan
outlines
um as caitlyn said the back and forth is
a little much the date in the
rsa
currently says september 1st
we might suggest moving that date a
little bit
2020 and 2021 i have some statistics
that um
not so many plans were submitted by
september 1st but by
the middle of october
that number almost doubled so
if we move the date a little bit we
would suggest that schools would get an
opportunity to come back into session
get into their routine have the ability
to pull their local emergency planning
team to include the sau
together to review the plan and submit
it
thereby enhancing compliance with the
rsa
so with respect to the workload impact
from my staff in particular
and trying to tighten this up just a
little bit so that
the schools the state
are
all on the same page
we would suggest that we would need to
do some research based on best practices
as it relates to the new version of
the federal emergency management
associate
agency's comprehensive planning guide
that we'll have to do
we would also be required to
update
and provide a functional template or
resource guide to the schools
so that they can
ensure that their emergency operations
plan
is within
criteria that is
meets emergency management regulations
and that they can keep it up to date on
an annual basis
so we have that it has not been updated
since august of 2020 um so
but just remember
that us doing this now is outside of our
scope within the rsa
um and then the last um
bigger big piece
next piece
would be doing outreach uh an education
of the law
which hasn't been done to date
which we think is pretty important my
staff were out at a school
the last school in the state that had
submitted a plan
last week and we talked to them about
that and they said we have no idea what
you're talking about that a plan is due
on september 1st so
i don't know if there's a change in
administration i don't know the details
about it but that was the conversation
so i think some education and outreach
about hey it's due on this date this is
what it should include we should do
so with these and other changes that
we'd like to discuss and propose to the
committee
we feel that doa should absolutely
remain involved in the process
specifically there's an rsa it's 189 28
that if a school doesn't submit a plan
um
doe has the ability to hold back um some
funding now
if they're not included in the bill
and i know caitlin said that it's you
asked the question uh
representative are you still involved so
i think they're still going to be that
nexus if uh it's passed as is but
if the committee is looking to make
changes
the bill doesn't seem to quite capture
the necessary planning requirements
and we'd be glad to work with the
sponsors to ensure that the intent is
clear and its expectations for the
schools so they know how to meet the rsa
requirements
and lastly i guess i already said it we
would love d.o.e to still be involved in
the process
school emergency preparedness activities
we both have
investments in what happens in the
schools and the safety of the school
kids
so thank you for your time thank you
very much jennifer harper and i will
assure you
that our primary goal is for safety and
security in these schools
it needs to be tightened up
and as chair of that commission which
had that 30 plus million dollars we will
make sure if they won't get anything out
of that pot they better get these plans
in
uh it's it's imperative it's every child
in this state counts
right and we want that to be safe and
safe so correct me if i'm wrong amy but
there is no more money in that pot we
have some money in that pot okay then
you know something so we'll put the word
out that and you know if statue says
something should be in by a certain date
we understand there's going to be a
little give and take on that however
we don't want these to be late there you
know it's
yeah so maybe a little slide in the date
to allow them to come back and and well
you know you come out of brakes or you
probe it and all that but you know it's
not really an excuse to default on
safety and security um that we need to
be on top of right but i think there's
also the problem there's no i think
caitlyn senate there's not a way to
enforce that i think it's
whatever it is that i just said um
yes i understand that so we've got to do
it through other means and there are
other ways the word can be gotten out
great
so thank you now amy do you have
anything from the department amy clark
uh so i would just as the one of the
people that gets the plans um they are
we do consider them confidential pieces
of information so for me it's just a
really just talking about process-wise
simply process-wise when the school
district currently has to submit them
both to department of education and
homeland security it just makes a
process problem for me because
right now homeland security has the
secure portal
and they have granted me access to it so
we have no problems behind the scenes
homeland security department of
education working well together it's
just the law currently says they have to
submit them to me so which means i have
to receive this set of plans that i
don't have anywhere to store then i have
to shred it i have 600 schools so um
just think about 600 plans coming at me
that i have to shred
because i already have them in a secure
portal so it's really just a process
piece that um
for me that's important just providing
access is great
which i already have but if you want to
confirm that in law that's great
so i guess that's the only thing i would
add
okay are there any questions from the
committee regarding this issue
confidentiality was a major issue when
these first came in and
when i went over to the operational
center it's like walking into nasa
you know with what you have over there
on the other side of town but that was
and
initially our site floor plans and all
that weren't being submitted due to
confidentiality and
issues
however i think we've overcome that now
there is a need to collaborate between
the two departments
absolutely we have training
various policies and how these plans
work operational plans work or don't
work
it's got to be a collaborative effort
so
we encourage you to work together we
will represent cordelia will be in touch
and if you have some amending language
that you perceive needs to be put in
there let us know that we'd like to have
it uh
represent cordelia will co contact you
immediately and we'll get something
together
thank you thank you
any further discussion
well thank you very much do we have any
other pink cards on this
so we don't have any other pink cards on
this so we will go into the next bill
thank you very much ladies
okay
okay so we need to have
the prime
well we'll have all reps first
so here's a rep right here too
um
is leon speaking on it hey there
yeah
okay uh when we go into this bill here
um
we we are aware that this uh bill has
attracted a lot of attention and uh
we're also aware that we're trying to
operate within the facility where we're
having uh
room for people to spread out a little
bit and
if we have folks that would like to
testify that
we're going to try to get everybody up
here
we may have to you know depending upon
the number cards maybe cut it to like a
three minutes
uh limit for each we're going to ask
that people don't
replicate what the person just before
you said
uh try to add additional information and
speak directly to the bill that would be
appreciated so with that i'd like to
welcome
permi
oh yeah if you have the written
testimony that's that's kind of a policy
we have up here we'd like to have any
written testimony
presented to the clerk but don't go
through and read it please you know we
will be reading your testimony along
with all that that's being submitted
electronically
so with that i'd like to uh welcome
represent like us to present the bill
thank you very much for the record
uh representative alicia lecus
from hillsborough 37 which is hudson and
pelham thank you very much
first i want to say that this bill as
written does not capture my intent
i ran out of time to get this ready i
was down helping my brother who had
heart failure i was staying with my mom
who didn't have internet access and
trying to do this on my phone was very
difficult and i ran out of time and was
told
just submitted amendment so that's what
i'm working on
um
so yes some of the things objections
that i've seen and that i know are
because of the way it ended up being
worded which does not express
my intent
so why did i
why was this even something that was on
my radar and it was from talking to and
hearing
combination of talking to and hearing
complaints from students and teachers
but also from conversations i'd had with
both high school students and adults who
thought that slavery for instance only
happened in the united states
and we had a war and it's done
and clearly that's not the case we have
slate we've had slavery just about since
the beginning of humanity
we have
slavery currently in the world we have
it in the united states and we have it
in new hampshire and so
i consider the idea that it only
happened here in the united states we
fought a war and it was done to be a
very dangerous learning
it probably wasn't intentional it was
probably just because in the curriculum
you're teaching american history so
that's part of american history but the
whole setting is not given and if we
don't realize that just um fighting the
civil war ended some slavery but it did
not end all slavery in the united states
just making it illegal didn't end it
slavery is a horrible despicable thing
always was always will be and unless we
are alert to what is happening what has
happened in the world and what
is happening now
we will not be on the lookout for it and
i could be our neighbor and we wouldn't
even know and yes i have spoken to
a woman who was a slave a sex slave
throughout her junior high in high
school
and
nobody knew because nobody was looking
for it it's a horrible thing
and we need to be on the lookout so my
intent was to expand when i when i put
in
um
[Music]
not limited to teaching well no no when
i put in um
worldwide context that was my goal was
to get it out there so that we weren't
limited to oh the us did this this
happened this was horrible and now it's
over but
you know it's ongoing
we need to be always vigilant to make
sure it doesn't happen again to make
sure it doesn't happen to our neighbor
another thing
that
really
got me was that a lot of times under the
idea of teaching
there are
hopefully it's rare but it definitely is
happening in our state teachers who are
not educating but indoctrinating
and i see that as very
harmful
to students
and to thought processes
and all of that
there's a big difference between
education and indoctrination and so just
to
clarify that i'll talk about
education of religion
so if you're educating religion you
might
come up with a list of the various world
religions you might ask your students to
each pick one
go away do research come back report to
the rest of the class on it you might
have your class look at all of the
various religions you've looked at and
find similarities across them
differences across them depending upon
the age group you're working in you
might go into wars that were fought in
the name of religion talk about whether
that
actually
was legitimate according to those people
who professed that religion you could
talk about was that really what the war
was about you could get into underlying
were there other things economic etc
you could get into genocide that has
happened in the name of religion and etc
you could go very in depth with that
that's teaching okay you're engaging the
students you're asking them questions
they're having them do research you're
having them think you're all of that
that's teaching on the other hand if i
were to try to persuade you that my
religion is the right religion
if i were to ask questions on a test
that if you didn't go along with that
then
you know then you got a bad grade
that's indoctrination and i think pretty
much everybody in this room would agree
that that's wrong when i talk about
religion but it's the same thing whether
i talk about political ideology whether
i talk about economic ideology
any ideology any theory
that's taught that is taught that is
educated that asks students
that engages discussion that does all of
that that's education when i start
pressing for my point of view my belief
system my political belief system
economic belief system whatever when i
start doing that then i'm indoctrinating
when i only accept an answer that says
that my political beliefs are right and
your beliefs are wrong
that's indoctrination just like we
wouldn't want to do it with religion we
don't want to do it with any theory with
any
[Music]
ideology
any of that and so that's what i'm
hearing is happening in some places
hopefully not many but they're certainly
it's not a school it's not a teacher i'm
hearing it from numerous different
schools and numerous different teachers
that they are indoctrinating
not teaching
and so that was
the intent of this
and i'm sure it's going to come up
in the bill i had
said not limited to teaching the united
states was founded on racism that is
actually an a theory
and i would suggest that if it was
founded on racism the word founded as
opposed to
had
racism existed when the country was
founded those are two very different
statements racism definitely existed
when the country was founded that's why
we had slavery
but we also had people from the
beginning who fought against slavery we
had people who fought against that if
the world was not divided if the united
states was not divided on that issue if
there were not a huge number of people
like half the country at least who
believed that slavery was wrong and
despicable and evil we wouldn't have had
a civil war so to be able to say it was
founded on racism when clearly half of
the country
you know disagreed that's hardly founded
on that's founded with the existence of
those are two very different things and
i just want to get that out there that
you know that's another that's teaching
a theory or an idea as opposed to a
proven reality
at any rate that's um that was my intent
i am working on a
amendment
it is still not worded to my
satisfaction i want to make it clear so
that nobody can misread or misinterpret
what it says thank you very much and
i'll be willing to take it thank you
very much are there any questions for
the presenter representative tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question i was wondering if you'd expand
a little bit
on your statement theory versus proven
reality and what a proven reality
how we would know it was a proven
reality rather than
a theory well i gotta say i have to say
as a physicist
and a mathematician
it's very difficult to have a proven
fact and that's why it's very important
to introduce things as a theory and not
a fact now if i had an apple and an
apple and i said that one apple plus one
apple is two apples i think most of us
would agree that that was a fact but
there's an awful lot of stuff even
somebody said to me the other day what
about the theory of relativity and i
said there's a reason it's called that
there are still physicists who disagree
with that
who don't think that's true and are
still trying to find exceptions
if
you can find an exception and exception
that disproves the rule
so if i can find an exception to your
theory then it's still just a theory it
is not a fact
follow our uh another any other
questions represent corneli
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative
um
it is my understanding that this statute
dates back to the cold war
and
from your testimony
am i correct to understand
that
you're in the midst of ongoing attempts
to find language to update this statute
that is exactly right in fact it was
originally from the 1940s
and um
and it and there was involved a teacher
oath of loyalty which swore loyalty to
the constitution of the united states
and new hampshire that part's been taken
out it's been updated a number of times
and yes i'm working to further update it
and try to make it clear
but
current
thank you thank you further questions
representative ellison
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
you mentioned that there are many case
you have reports of many cases of
indoctrination of students
what schools in new hampshire is that
taking place in
you've caught me on the spot i did not
come up with a list i have read
letters from
parents i have talked personally to
parents but i'm not real good at
remembering and i would not want to name
a school that and say the wrong one
i can get you the information for some
of them if you would like i can go back
through my emails
and i i'm sure i won't get all of them
but i can give you some
thank you
further questions
thank you very much representative oh
represent porter
thank you mr just one quick one uh
representative and thank you for taking
my question in the list at the beginning
and i know this comes from that earlier
law
you have no teacher shall advocate
communism socialism or marxism and those
are all philosophies and things that are
to the very far far far left i'm
wondering why you didn't think to
include things like fascism and
totalitarianism and authoritarianism and
not white nationalism on the far far
left right
thank you very much um actually those
are in my amendment some of them and if
you would like to give me the rest of
that list i'll be glad to add it yes
that was just a first draft like i said
those were put in somebody else said
well what about fascism and i was like
great idea and so yes they should yes
absolutely
thank you represent luna
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you very much representative uh for um
uh taking my question um something that
we uh frequently asked um two years ago
in this committee when uh when when a
bill was being introduced
is um is what is the intent what is your
intent as the prime sponsor and so i'd
like to ask you that question what is
your intent as the prime minister okay i
thought i had covered that but i will
say it again my intent is to make sure
that teachers are educating and not
indoctrinating
that's basically it
further questions
thank you very much representative thank
you
the next uh we have several reps i know
that have to get back out to committee
so i'm gonna try to get you through
quickly here represent leon is she here
thank you mr chairman and thank you
members of the education committee i
miss that i wasn't able to meet in
person with you last year when i was a
member here
i am here today to speak in favor of
house bill 1255 and the evolving
amendments the intention here is to make
certain that in our schools our teachers
are doing what has happened for a long
time
teaching how to think not what to think
i've heard cases of teachers speaking
about the founders all being racist and
this country is bad because of it
that's not how to think that is telling
them what to think and that should not
be acceptable that teacher i believe was
disciplined that happened many years ago
but these things do happen in our
schools
as we address this issue i like the idea
that we're expanding it not just into
these economic and social models but
also including it to fascism and these
other
areas that we need to discuss
but we can't
hold the students to
follow the teacher's belief
or know what the teacher is advocating
for so that they answer the test and
they start parroting lines that say
this is what i believe because i think
it will get a better grade
i come from a time when teachers hid
their affiliations and their personal
viewpoints so that the students might
try and figure out
actually so what does this teacher think
because they're curious not having it
come at them all the time
i
i believe very much in free discussion
and i believe that the less that the
more that we can make sure
that the teachers opinions are not
coloring the lesson plan the more that
we can have honest discussions and truly
understand why
some of these things are so truly awful
if they can discuss and play around with
the ideas instead of just hearing that
it's bad
if we can discuss the context and the
way that these atrocities have happened
in our world we can better see them if
they're coming down again in history
because history repeats and our job
is to avoid the major mistakes of the
past
and to try and write them and without
honest discussion we can't do that
so thank you
thank you very much are there any
questions represent ellison
thank you mr chair thanks for taking my
question
i think you started by saying you
support the bill as written
and
amendments that are forthcoming have you
seen amendments that are forthcoming to
this bill
thank you for the question i said that i
support the bill and the evolving
amendment process
in the presentation from the prime
sponsor an amendment was discussed in
order to try and address these issues
and i agree that the intent i'm a
co-sponsor we worked on this but we were
up against serious family issues as we
as we were trying to get this out the
door
so i i do expect that something that
that takes all of the insight that we've
had ever since you know people started
talking specifically about this bill we
had wonderful insight there was some
great discussion from a board of
education member and incorporating
that will make this a much stronger bill
that does what we want it to do make
sure the teachers are teaching what to
think not how to think
thank you
you reversed i'm sorry
i did june and july's in option trading
and that cost me a lot of money when i
mixed up my words so yes
teach how to think not what to think
thank you very much are there further
questions
nasini thank you very much thank you
representative horgan
thank you very much i'm representative
timothy horrigan from stratfor county
district six the towns of durham and
madbury the home of
home of unh and the oyster river
cooperative school district um
first of all there should be uh
i mean i think uh obviously even the
prime sponsor when the co-sponsors
expressed misgivings about this bill and
there um supposedly there's gonna be an
amendment i from what i've heard i don't
know
i don't i don't think just anything's
going to come out of it that i'm going
to be too eager to vote for even though
there may be some what about ism by
putting in fascisms and stuff i i think
um
i think this whole uh
i think this whole statute should go so
the appropriate thing to do with rsa 191
is not to
add the sexual language
to it but to just to delete the whole
thing um
actually i went to a private uh
religious high school in massachusetts
north american school and actually my
favorite teacher
um
when i was there in 11th and 12th grade
was senor shepard who was uh
the ice hockey coach and also a i think
he actually really was a communist he
did uh go to cuba in the
early 1970s with the
um
but um he was uh
and he did i mean he didn't indoctrinate
us i'm not sure the term indoctrination
means other than teaching students
something that you don't approve of he
certainly didn't indoctrinate this he's
a fine teacher but i
will say he didn't do that much harm
because
um i'm not a communist i
can't skate and my spanish is still
atrocious so the amount of harm that was
done by having a communist
teaching me spanish in 11th 12th grade
at least is pretty minimal so
um those
we have um this uh
the 1949 bill passed at the height of
the cold wars others have correctly
noted uh just mentioned communism
another adding socialism and marxism and
you know being
you know being an adherent daniel's
philosophy is um it's not illegal um
there's
um it's not even not even wrong
especially in the case of uh
socialism and marxism a lot of the ideas
behind it insofar as those terms of any
meaning at all
are deeply embedded in our society in
fact i even heard
so from ways and means a couple of days
and we were there's a debate about uh a
bill about remote
new hampshire residents who work for
massachusetts companies and he was
the prime sponsor
i'm sure he's getting that as several
moves this wasn't intentional he
actually gave me an explanation for why
the actually actually feels needed they
came right out of marx's labor theory of
of of value like as uh as as
embodied in das capital a lot of others
i'm sure he didn't uh
i'm sure he wasn't getting it directly
from dos capital but it was kind of an
amusing uh amazing thing we said about
the role of
labor and creating value and
um as for the uh
racism slavery did exist elsewhere it
still uh
it still exists uh in other parts of the
world but uh it was deeply embedded in
the founding of the 13 colonies and the
united states and
one of the many factors that led the
revolutionary war was uh you know
you know great britain was
uh liberalizing its policies about
slavery and we weren't ready to go we
weren't ready to go along with it even
even here in new england we
financed the plantations
our uh
our entrepreneurs owned the
on the ships brought to slaves to the
south so we're not our hands aren't and
there were many slaves who lived up here
in the north so like our hands aren't
clean of that uh
are aren't clean of that either and that
probably uh
probably should be taught and then also
um
and also like the threat to uh
the threat to the teachers that they can
be vying for ethics if somebody objects
to their political views that's also
very chilling that uh
really is out of this of the cold war
and i'm um
also just for the sake of sake of uh
full disclosure i'm old enough to
remember the cold war so i was born in
1956 when you know the cold war was
still going on and um
the uh
and there was definitely a great fear of
communism now we're
and we're still afraid of uh russia and
china but they're very different from
what they are now certainly the soviet
union in spite of what's going on the
board of ukraine no longer exists in
that form china has been continuously
ruled by the chinese communist party but
you know it's a very different
place than it was in miles miles here
so i'm going
so i just i just don't
know that it should be illegal to teach
those things in school because they have
had a lot so that's
um that's what i heard you do probably
just uh uses opportunity to delete the
entire obsolete statute from the bill
the fact that we're
struggling so much with the uh
with the uh
struggling wording probably indicates
not so much that um
anything wrong with our drafting
attorneys probably this was just uh not
a good idea and uh it's the best thing
to do
uses an opportunity to strike
the entirety of rsa 191 from the uh from
the law books that would be i think a
great blow for
academic freedom and for good education
at all levels so um
that's why that's my testimony thank you
very much representative are there any
questions for the representative
not seeing any
hands thank you very much and as usual i
ran over my two minutes but i apologize
but thanks
representative i'm on
see here
thank you mr chair i'll be very brief
i pass around to the committee
the history of the statute
so you should have a copy of that
as it was referenced it goes back to
1949.
on page
it's the
the seventh page it has 1108 at the top
left corner
there's a discussion about amending the
statute so originally it had
the prohibition it had an oath that was
required for teachers to take
and it had
a penalty if you didn't take the oath
and enforcement was to be done by the
attorney general's office
and there was an exception if you
weren't a citizen so that's basically
the the full statute that existed at the
time
what's interesting on that seventh page
there's a discussion uh the senate
record
and it talks about leaving in
senator humphrey
removed the other stat the other
provisions of the statute
but he left in
this idea
that
we wouldn't want teachers to
indoctrinate children with communism so
that was uh
that was
decidedly left in so i thank the sponsor
for
updating the statute
and again it's about indoctrination
that's that's not something that we'd
want uh teachers to use their position
to do so what's interesting in that
discussion also is that
it points out that public school
teachers are government employees
and you know originally this was an oath
that they took
we all took an oath to our office
we were sworn in by the governor
we had to raise our hand and take an
oath so it's not something that's
uncommon uh to do so
we're not asking for the oath to be
brought back but we are asking for
uh and as a co-sponsor this bill we're
asking that the stat should be updated
uh to to reflect current reality so with
that i'll
take any questions you may have thank
you very much are there any questions
not seeing you thank you very much thank
you representative moffat
thank you mr fritting me and i'm
bouncing around between three committees
um
for the record uh representative mike
moffatt uh representative canterbury and
loudoun merrimack district nine
as a legislator as a columnist who
values the first amendment
is a professor who values academic
freedom i cannot speak in favor of hb
1255 as it is currently worded
and i have set this testimony
electronically to the committee uh words
matter
but words matter beyond just the wording
of hb 1255.
when folks
pejoratively mischaracterize for example
the efa program school choice program
and repeatedly refer to it as a voucher
program
they do a disservice to citizens
who deserve honesty
it's not about your program look up the
definition of voucher words matter
when people repeatedly
refer to the new
so-called divisive concepts law
they do a disservice to citizens who
deserve honesty
those words are not in statute but i
keep hearing time and time again in this
committee and elsewhere about the
divisive concepts law there is no such
thing
those words are not in the statute which
simply calls for everyone to be treated
the same to be treated equally under the
law that's what is in the new statute
with no groups being favored over other
groups
who can argue with that
words
matter
when people repeatedly claim that
critical race theory is not being taught
in new hampshire they again do a
disservice to citizens who deserve
honesty
words matter
elements of critical race theory are
parts of instruction all over the state
a constituent of mine sent me a video
she claimed was shown to her seventh
grade
son's class it was entitled an
uncomfortable conversation with a black
man i watched it
an african-american male justified
lawless behavior made the case why it's
okay for some groups to to break the law
and sometimes be violent
people had to understand why laws didn't
apply the same way to some groups as
they did others that is classic crt
and it is out there i have witnessed it
i've watched it
schools that deploy written materials
such as the discredited 1619 project
are absolutely promoting crt
why is this being denied
words matter and the truth matters
yes
as you've heard earlier many folks are
concerned about proselytizing in schools
and colleges to captive audiences
and there's much to be concerned about
now we understand that many here are
unsettled by the notion of loyalty oaths
but there were valid reasons
historically why these came about
and and i understand those who favor
hb 1255 which i do not at this time
i understand that they seek to be
reassured that academic people are not
working against our nation's
institutions and interests recently a
harvard university professor is charged
with hiding his ties
to a chinese
run recruitment program and he was found
guilty on all accounts a professor
engaged in espionage
i choose my words carefully here when i
ask if that is not seditious a professor
working secretly with our chinese
adversaries why is that okay is that
covered by academic freedom here in new
hampshire controversial dartmouth
professor mark bray
of that school's gender research
institute
defended egregious antifa violence he
somehow described that as legit
legitimate self-defense
dartmouth's president here in new
hampshire understandably condemned
professor bray but then over 100
over 100 dartmouth faculty people
signed on to support their colleagues
words i think there are unfortunate
words and words matter i just received a
message from a fellow state rep
describing how another professor
assigned an essay to his class to
explain why the taliban is not a
terrorist organization and to argue
otherwise it
would result in feeling great i served
in afghanistan i've seen the taliban
i've seen their work
it's hard for me to hear professors use
such words
but tolerating such people is part of
the wonder of america in our first
america first amendment freedoms which
is why i cannot support a speed 1255 as
it's currently worded
blm materials and science can be seen
all over to include classrooms
go to blm's website if you haven't
already i have
it's a marxist racist organization
read what they have posted it they rail
against quote
white supremacist capitalism although i
note on their website they have a
there's a button corporate sponsors can
hit if they want to make corporate
donations interestingly
blm wants to change our economic system
our judicial system our political system
they even
oppose a traditional nuclear family so
when teachers display
logos or signs supporting blm
then they invite scrutiny regarding
their judgment their values and maybe
yes maybe their loyalties
i once took an oath to defend our
constitution against all enemies foreign
and domestic i take that oath seriously
words
matter
so maybe hb 1255 can be admitted in a
way that could get more people
like me to support it i cannot at this
time we'll see in the meantime we should
not be afraid
to shine some light and raise some
awareness
sometimes in lieu of laws just shining
some light on things
can get the result we need and i'll
close with a quote from thomas paine
those who expect to reap the blessings
of freedom must endure the fatigue of
supporting it
thank you for your time i'd be happy to
take any questions if there are any
thank you very much uh representative
moffatt are there any questions for the
presenter
not seeing thank you very much thank you
uh i'd like to invite heidi heath
good afternoon honorable members of the
committee
thank you for receiving my testimony
today
you have a written lengthier version of
this testimony included in your packet
i am here today on behalf of the new
hampshire council of churches
nhcc is an ecumenical christian
organization
comprised of nine denominations of
churches and hundreds of clergy across
the granite state
we pride ourselves on working across
lines of difference for the common good
of all granite staters
i rise today in opposition to hb 1255.
hb 1255 is dangerous
harmful and bad policy for new hampshire
hb 1255 threatens teachers ability to do
important curricular and classroom work
robustly and well
there is a grave lack of clarity in the
bill as it stands around what
constitutes ideology
as currently written the bill allows
teachers to be penalized and targeted
for a wide variety of content
who will decide
who will decide what constitutes quote
any doctrine or theory promoting a
negative account or representation of
the founding and history of the united
states of america in new hampshire
public schools
this language is dangerously vague
the new hampshire council of churches
has been engaged in a wide variety of
difficult conversations on topics like
racism across our state you have
examples in our written testimony of
that work
we have seen what is possible when we
rise to difficult conversations and when
we face our discomfort rather than
backing away
it is not easy to face the realities of
systemic racism in our founding
our state or our nation but it is a
moral and an ethical imperative that we
must do that work
only then can we grow together toward
the more perfect union that our founders
sought
i trust our public school teachers to
teach this history and this information
in a rich and a robust context that
helps our students more fully understand
themselves and one another
what after all is the goal of public
education if not that
as a religious leader i believe deeply
in the power of truth-telling and i want
to empower our teachers to tell the
truth
nothing more and nothing less
i fear instead that this bill only seeks
to silence
to divide and to punish some of our most
dedicated public servants
on behalf of the new hampshire council
of churches i invite you to vote no on
hb 1255. we believe it is the faithful
response
thank you thank you very much other
other questions
not seeing thank you very much thank you
like to invite megan tuttle
is megan here there she is
thank you chairman lad members of the
house education committee for the record
megan tuttle president for any new
hampshire i have written testimony that
i will submit so i'll just summarize it
um we are here i'm here on behalf of any
new hampshire to strongly object to
passage of house bill 1255.
we see it as a doubling down on the
banned concepts law enacted in house hb2
a law that's already subject to two
federal lawsuits because of the chilling
effect it's had on our students
receiving an education they deserve the
hate that it spun on its wake
for one example the bounty that was put
on the heads of our teachers
similar to the ban concepts law that
precedes this one this bill raises many
many questions about what it prohibits
particularly in a classroom setting
where is the line between the teaching
and discussion of history versus
advocating i've testified on this before
educators are contacting me many times
multiple educators from all across the
state
about the fact that they're not having
discussions in their classroom they're
afraid to have discussions
critical thinking isn't being allowed
because they're afraid that they're
going to be reported for something
in addition the passage of the bill
would also not only mean teachers would
have to navigate yet another big
classroom censorship law but they would
be doing it with the same threat of
punishment using the educator code of
conduct just like in the banned concepts
law our students deserve an honest and
accurate education that enables them to
learn from the mistakes of our past to
help create a better future legislation
like house bill 1255 inhibits this with
its language this seems to indicate that
past mistakes were anything other than
what wrongs this should not be repeated
and whose effects still on our nation
today
as educators if we're going to prepare
our children for the future we need to
teach them both the good and the bad of
history so that they better understand
the lives cultures and experiences of
different people house bill 1255 would
inhibit this from happening
so on behalf of the educators across new
hampshire whose loyalty is to their
students i ask that you find house bill
1255 and expedient to legislate thank
you thank you
from the committee any questions justine
thank you very much
uh tom newkirk
you want to both come up at the same
time
that that'd be fine it might expedite
things
could you define both of your names then
we can add the second on to the sheet
here okay great
my name is tom newkirk
i'm
served on the ursa river school board
and i was previously a university
teacher at the university of new
hampshire
i'm dr jim morris i'm the superintendent
oyster river i have served in that
capacity uh for 10 years thank you
welcome
okay
um
i feel a bit at a disadvantage because
it seems to me that this text that we're
supposed to be discussing today is some
evolving text that there's some future
text that we haven't seen so my comments
are about the text that was presented so
there may be some future text that
resolves these questions but we we
understand that i have not seen it
either okay okay
it's not been written
um
i'm here to speak against this bill
any bill has two requirements it should
be clear on the kind of action it
addresses
and it should be clear in what is
required
this bill fails on both counts
and i want to focus on one sentence
that's been referred to already it's in
the second part of the bill and it reads
no teacher shall advocate any doctrine
or theory promoting a negative account
a representation of the founding and
history of the united states of america
in the new hampshire public schools
which does not include the worldwide
context of now outdated and discouraged
practices
a difficult sentence with a double
negative at the center of it
now imagine if a history teacher wanted
to teach about the internment of
japanese americans during world war ii
120 000 of them placed in internment
camps for the entire war if they had
even one sixteenth
japanese heritage
this internment is viewed now as an act
of xenophobia which prompt prompted a
review by our government and a
reparations bill signed by president
reagan
so is it covered by this bill
it is a negative account of
representation
and there are sociological theories of
racial trauma to explain and
to explain the internment and their
effect on those in turn
is it covered
maybe
maybe not
terms like promoting a negative account
of representation are highly subjective
is it a negative account
or an honest one
but suppose we decided that it is
covered
that this teacher is doing something
that's covered by this law
what is required of this teacher
the teacher must quote
include the worldwide context of now
outdated and discouraged practices
unquote
i have no idea what that means
worldwide that's a gigantic task
indonesia australia
who would have the time the knowledge
base
what are quote now outdated and
discouraged practices discouraged by
whom
could any of you explain it to this
teacher what's required
the language is impossibly vague a pile
up of undefined terms
there is a particular danger in this
vagueness and the vagueness of this
proposed law
teachers will not know what is
prohibited and what is allowed and with
their teaching credentials at stake
who would blame them if they didn't
touch topics like japanese internment
which would be a disservice to new
hampshire students
these stories need to be told and they
were surely not part of the history i
was taught when i was in school
any attempt to regulate in a few
sentences
something as complex as the teaching of
history is destined to be misinterpreted
and contested
i urge you to designate this laws and
expedient and i would also like to point
out
that
there are policies you know coming from
the new hampshire school board that
prohibit the advocacy of personal
beliefs whether that is marxism and
communism but also republicanism and you
know democrat being democrat
that prohibit you from using your
position as a teacher to advocate for
those our school board has passed those
the school boards association has
you know is given us the language there
and so i think these policies are in
place and i think that
the greater danger is not it's not that
they're isolated cases where peace
teachers may cross the line i think the
big danger
is that because of these bills
teachers will be reluctant to teach
subjects and parts of american history
that have been suppressed that
desperately need to be taught
just
and i would just add that you know the
equivalent to what you do here is school
board policy that's our legislative
language
and annually i send out a message to my
staff reminding them of this policy
because inevitably somebody will call me
and say you know xy teacher is doing x y
and z
so i am always preempted with this law
i'm concerned about this policy
but we do it at the at the local level i
would suggest that legislation should be
passed that fits the majority
not anecdotal records because anecdotes
are addressed at the local level and for
you all to try to pass a piece of
legislation from concord that addresses
anecdotes those anecdotes will always be
there and a good superintendent is
always going to address them so i would
suggest that
the law as it's written
along with tom is vague and and quite
frankly i think it's unnecessary because
we already have policies that address
this at the local level
thank you very much i have one question
for you or a request from your
superintendent um
if you if you're echoing a boilerplate
policy coming out of the new hampshire
school boards association or if you've
developed your own there could you
provide a copy to the committee please
i'd be glad to do that thank you
representative
any questions from committee members
thank you very much thank you thank you
uh jennifer given
would you would you please uh just you
know try to cut it from five to three
minutes please yes sir and that would
help i'm also gonna for clarity's sake
remove my mask
um
so my name is jennifer given i am a
history teacher so it's always nice to
actually talk to the people who are
doing the work that is being legislated
um and so i have given up a personal day
today to be here to represent myself but
also to uh represent my kids both my
biological teenagers who i live with and
my students who i teach
i teach world history i teach ap world
history and college prep world history i
teach slavery
of rome china egypt
all like all throughout all of human
history we compare different types of
forced labor systems because sometimes
forced labor isn't defined the way we
would kind of define just slavery so i
take real
issue with the idea that there are
anecdotes and
vague assertions that this is not
happening and that the legislature is in
my view over
solving the problem
by reaching so far into my classroom as
to tell me what i can and cannot say
in order to try to address
some kind of vague assertion that people
have made or somebody watched a youtube
video like i can pull up a youtube video
on any topic
it doesn't mean that that's fact which
is a skill that i'm actually teaching my
students by demanding that their level
of evidence far exceeds the evidence
i've currently heard today
i'm frustrated that i'm here for a bill
that is poorly thought through
poorly defined vague
that would not fly in my classroom i
don't know why we're wasting our time
with that when we could be working on
real problems in schools
and so that i find frustrating um i also
am insulted by the idea that teachers
should be
loyal
questioning my loyalty is demeaning
questioning my loyalty is an insult the
idea that
i show up to work every day for low
wages and in unsafe conditions and i'm
not loyal
i mean
i would love to know what your
definition of loyalty is if it's not
that
right
in addition
this is a law that is regressive
mccarthy would be very excited about
this law
right
this law is overly simplifying complex
issues for the sake of chilling teachers
speech
let's be clear it has no real effort to
try to clarify history
what you are attempting to do is silence
discussion
whitewash our curriculum
and tolerate intolerable views
i teach my students that there are lines
that slavery was wrong that nazis were
wrong that fascism is wrong
i do not indoctrinate them but i do tell
them that when people lose their lives
for expressing their ideas that's wrong
and that's exactly what this law is
attempting to do
thank you
thank you very much for your teachable
moment you're welcome
uh are there any people on the committee
to have a question
thank you
devon chaffee
welcome
thank you chairman ladd and under
honorable members of the committee my
name is devin chafee and i am the
executive director of the aclu of new
hampshire
a non-profit non-partisan organization
that's worked to protect civil liberties
in the state of new hampshire for over
50 years i am here to testify today to
respectfully urge the committee to vote
in expedient to legislate on hb 1255. i
also understand that there does seem to
be some fluidity in the language but i
also so i also in in addition to
addressing the specific language that's
before us today i want to express some
of my concerns with what i understand
and as is being articulated as the
intent behind the bill given the chance
that i might not have an opportunity to
testify on any additional um amendment
that may be put forth
so
i just want to start by saying
that i think that we are better as a
state and a community when we can have
hard conversations and when we can learn
from them
and that's part of why it's so important
that our students when they are in the
classroom and in our schools are able to
get a full picture of america's history
that includes both
the good and the bad
and it is my sincere concern that this
bill as written would not allow uh for a
full representation of american history
um you know there's been a lot of
discussion about how we need to have
free discussion in our classrooms about
how free discussion in our classrooms is
important and
it is my opinion especially based on
what we have seen in new hampshire
schools over the last year that the
absolute worst way to encourage free
discussion and perhaps the best way to
limit free discussion in the classroom
is to uh impose very vague prohibitions
and limitations on what can be discussed
and then couple those limitations with
very serious
real and potentially career ending um
consequences
and i believe that that is exactly what
hb 1255 does do as currently written
um you know right now the bill as it's
written is
very vague in what it prohibits it
prohibits quote unquote advocating for
not only socialism or marxism but also
advocating any doctrine or theory that
promotes a negative account or
representation of the founding and
history of the united states of america
which does not include the worldwide
context of now outdated and discouraged
practices including that america was
founded on racism
and so i looked to this language
and not unlike the language that was
included in hb2 um that that put similar
limitations on what can be done in the
classroom i have to wonder how on earth
are teachers supposed to know what this
means in practice how are they supposed
to know what this means when it comes to
what they can and cannot discuss in the
classroom
what is a negative account what does
founded on racism mean
does it allow for the historical
discussion of the soviet uh russia or
communist china
does this language um
prohibit the exclusive discussion of uh
of racism against persons of color in
the united states our history like
redlining
like the three-fifths compromise
like the trail of tears
how the united states was in fact late
to abolish slavery compared to many
other european countries
is that allowed or does that violate the
bill
it seems to me that uh that that this is
is hardly clear from the bill's language
and i fear as has as others have
referenced that it's
that um any additional language that's
proposed will be equally vague
i also want to highlight that it does
seem from some of the testimony that i
have heard here that at least some
concepts such as the potential um
the disparate impact of our criminal
legal system on people of color
throughout the country does seem to be
something that is that that is
intentionally being targeted by the
language that is included in hb uh 1255.
so again i i'm concerned not only about
the language that is represented in this
bill as well as what uh what exactly
it's it's intending um to prohibit
and again this the vagueness and the
lack of clarity and what is being
prohibited has only come
is only made worse by the stiff
penalties that are associated with the
bill
this bill provides that a violation of
this section will be considered a
violation of new hampshire's code of
ethics and code of conduct for
educational professionals and shall
justify disciplinary sanctions and what
this means
is that an educator uh it could lead
that uh that a violation could
potentially lead to an educator's
license to work in the state
being revoked and that's essentially
ending a teacher's career so you have
these incredibly vague definitions of
what may or may not be prohibited in the
classroom and then you have teachers
that are looking at potentially losing
their career on the basis of violating
these vague prohibitions
and what this bill will do as much as
the the language that was in hb2 has
done and as we have seen it will chill
conversation in the classroom and it
will actively discourage
accurate instruction about um
topics in the classroom because they are
negative or or somehow portray the
united states in some type of negative
light
under this bill it could very well be
unlawful for a teacher to exclusively
teach the civil rights movement jim crow
segregation the impact of the end of
reconstruction on black americans or the
brutal realities of colonization for the
indigenous populations
and compelling this instruction to
somehow be in a worldwide context really
has the potential for diminishing the
unique american experiences of those of
color in the united states
students in new hampshire should be
taught their true history and not a
history that dilutes the true story of
america including the story of racism in
our country
i also want to highlight that it does
appear that this bill would apply not
only to k-12 which we have primarily i
think focused on thus far but would also
focus on would also apply to public
colleges and universities again
violating the first amendment and
protections of academic freedom
this is long-standing precedent going
back over 60 years that the supreme
court has recognized
and made clear that particularly in the
university setting it is unquestionable
that voip
viewpoint based suppression of speech is
not permissible uh silencing a
particular viewpoint here we're talking
about negative conceptions implicating
racism in american history is a clear
violation of the first amendment under
u.s supreme court precedent
so again it seems to me in some that
this bill is about censorship
no worries no worries of course
again
it appears to me that this bill is
fundamentally about censorship and
censorship is a dangerous concept
in schools we should be allowing ideas
to be discussed even those we don't
agree with so students are exposed to
alternative perspectives and can be
taught to evaluate these ideas for
themselves
but through 1255's inevitable chill
students are going to be robbed of
information and ideas and instructional
instructional approaches that they need
to effectively function as citizens in
america's democratic system and i want
to be clear we are already seeing
teachers
in new hampshire that are now not
allowing students to pick their own
report topics because they are concerned
that they might somehow pick up a topic
that would be in violation of the
prohibited concepts language that was
included in hb2 last year we are already
seeing teachers pull back and pull books
from their curriculum excuse me can you
kind of cut it short a little bit here
we've gone quite a long time here and we
still have seven more cards to go
yes yes uh chairman i want to be i just
want to be clear that we're already
starting to see that chill and i want to
end with a quote from the us supreme
court
it's from a 1943 decision
as governmental pressures towards unity
become greater so strife becomes more
bitter as to whose unity it shall be
probably no deeper division of our
people could proceed from any
provocation than from finding it
necessary to choose what doctrine and
whose program public educational
officials shall be compelled shall
compel youth to unite an embracing
compulsory unification of opinion
achieves only the unanimity of the
graveyard and for these reasons i
respectfully urge the committee to
recommend that hb 1255 be deemed
inexpedient to legislate thank you very
much thank you very much are there any
questions
not seeing any thank you very much
uh
is it johnna wheeler
here jonah jonah
from peterborough yes
welcome
thank you chairman ladd
i come before the committee today to
oppose this bill
i've spent my entire time in school here
in new hampshire
and i can attest to the fact i can
attest to being the only black person
in an all-white school having no one to
look to
having no
mentor
to say oh hey i'm feeling a little bit
something's going on i mean there's
someone calling me a name there's
someone saying i'm
wrong for this just because i did
nothing wrong you have no one to turn to
and you isolate those feelings you say
okay i'll just
put them down i'll squash them keep them
solid and there was one time in third
grade where i know i was a little bit of
a mischievous oblivious third grader so
i thought i was in trouble
my third grade teacher sat me down and
said i need to talk to you one-on-one
and this is the first of many of those
meetings
and she told me about martin luther king
sort of separate from
the conversation that we were having in
the classroom
because she knew that the conversation
around king the real the realities
around what he was doing in that time
it's too much for a third grader
um but if you're a third grader who has
no mentor to look to a third grader who
has no one who he can say hey that's
that's me
then you need to know that history
because you need to know who you are and
i had a white
uh old white lady teacher who was very
nice
and she missed jetkins and she sat me
down and she said look you need to know
the realities of what martin luther king
did what he stood for
and without that meeting without those
meetings
i can say honestly i probably wouldn't
be here with you today alive i mean i
probably would have already taken my
life
it's
it's really that real for people here in
new hampshire for black brown
indigenous people here in new hampshire
and i think what's sad about this
conversation is
some on the other side people who
support this bill and the the efforts to
sort of chill this speech i think it
comes from a misunderstanding about what
we're trying to do here i don't think
anyone hates america
i don't i mean very few people hate this
country here in this room if anyone i
think we all have some serious deep love
for this country or we wouldn't be here
otherwise
we all have some understanding of the
horrors
that government
or an unchecked government
can do to people
um
why would we not want the future leaders
of our country the future educators of
our country
to have a full and fruitful discussion
about those horrors you know it's not
a teacher's job to advocate for a
position i think everyone would agree
with that but it is a teacher's job
to present the facts and let the
students debate let them figure it out
and i think i i can it's you know i have
teachers who
from uh my time in commvault who are
have come to me because i'm an organizer
in this space and they said i'm already
feeling this chilling effect without
this legislation having even
truly been passed and all these other
legislation's been passed i'm already
feeling this chilling effect i already
feel like
there's some parents out there who would
report me to
you know that i could
maybe not face serious consequences but
why would you uh even go
through
minimal consequences just for teaching
you know why would you have to put
yourself through the wringer if no one's
going to stand with you and i think
really we should focus on uh the
serious problems that are happening in
this country and not um
this sort of culture war around
critical race theory because there are
you know i think of the the black kids
who are in conval now i mean i know a
couple of them who are in my school now
who
if they don't have that same
conversation with a third grade teacher
or one of their high school teachers
what if they feel as isolated as i did
and then they make the decision that i
was able not to make i mean that's
a real fear of mine and i just
in whatever decision the committee makes
i hope that
we try our best not to chill this speech
to make our education institutions of
one of fruitful discussion so that we
can move forward from the horrors that
our country our government and yes
sometimes our people have done i don't
think this is a racist country i don't
think uh any of you here are racist
don't think you'd let me in the room
otherwise or you'd be not listening
so i i don't believe this is from racist
motivations and i think we can all come
together and work together to create a
different world where we can all talk
about the facts and realities of our
country yes the horrors and the good
things in a fruitful and honest way
i don't want to take too much your time
but thank you very much chairman lad
thank you very very much appreciate it
are there any questions from the
committee
thanks
yes represent hops
hi
um i don't really have a question
formulated yet so i'm hoping that if i
take enough time to tell you thank you
for coming
and thank you for your testimony and
i appreciate your
honesty
i would like to know how we can have
these conversations
because there are not many people
willing to have them
and what would your
what would have helped you as a child in
third grade
i i think before you go into an in-depth
on that one i'll make it short because i
could talk all day about my third i'll
make it short don't worry
okay but thank you i was just gonna say
i don't really have a prescription for
it you know i'm not necessarily too sure
but i know for
a hundred percent uh if it wasn't just
me and the teacher if i could have a
discussion with my students about the
reality and if the teacher wasn't you
know she made a decision that i think
was a good one and she said i don't
think the third grader should learn
about this right now but if we could get
to a position where
high school students could have a
fruitful discussion that's not just
writing a paper and then handing it off
to the student but the teacher but a
fruitful discussion really sitting down
and having a conversation about what are
these issues why did this happen and
what can we do about it
that never happened in high school that
never happened in middle school that
never happened in elementary school
this idea of education being a place
where conversations happen it doesn't
happen you have kids writing
papers focusing on their own thing not
even talking to each other and now
wearing masks and all these things and
totally isolated so totally isolated
i think we need to not isolate our
children
and
create a fruitful discussion in the
schools
ending this sort of standardized
education i think that would do a lot
so thank you thank you very much
okay i'd like to recognize eric um
you're gonna have to you know
give me your last name
s-c-h-l
eric schlapak s-c-h-l-a-p-a-k
over new hampshire
well thank you thank you
my name is eric schleypack from dover i
am a teacher at dover high school
i'm able to be here today
because i'm honored to be the 2021
recipient of the christa mccall
sabbatical
miss macoff whose portrait hangs in this
room as the only portrait in this room
we know her story
and i won't dare to assume her reasons
for wanting to be a teacher in space but
i will use a few of our quotes
saying i want to demystify
nasa and space flight i want students to
see to understand the special
perspective of space and relate it to
them
humanize the experience
something this bill wants to stifle
it was also reported at the time in 1985
that mcauliffe's colleagues and friends
in new hampshire said that in and out of
the classroom mcauliffe was a historian
with the conviction
that the experience of ordinary people
was as proper a subject of history as
chronicles of wars and politicians and a
young student
named mike dillion was quoted in the new
york times
as saying she gives a lesson and then
she has a story to tell
and i look at the portrait that's in
this room
and i wonder if
miss mcauliffe would be able to tell her
stories under this bill and under the
conditions we have today
worrying that her credential is going to
get taken away
i'll leave you with one more quote from
miss mcauliffe who's inspired a
generation of educators including me
i realize there's a risk outside your
everyday life but it doesn't frighten me
please do the right thing
end this bill thank you thank you very
much are there any questions
congratulations on your honor thank you
very much well done
um jordan uh
uh jordan you're gonna have to give me
the last one too here
ste
stenstrum okay thank you
i want to thank the chairman and the
members of this committee for the
opportunity to speak today and i want to
begin by thanking the members of this
committee for their time and dedication
to this great state of new hampshire
as a proud lifelong new hampshire
resident i am aware that this position
comes with both a tremendous amount of
responsibility as well as a very limited
pay grade you guys only get about a
hundred dollars a year so i i really
want to thank you all for the public
service
despite
my dis my deeply seated disagreement and
borderline disgust that i feel towards
this bill it in no way diminishes the
tremendous amount of respect that i have
for each and every one of you
i come before you today not as someone
who is fundamentally anti-american
seeking to destroy this country or tear
down the incredible legacy and
tremendous bravery that is so deeply
intertwined with the founding of our
nation but rather is somebody who is
deeply proud of and grateful for our
past
engaged with the maintaining of the
present and hopeful towards the future
of this country
it is this pride in our country
including its history that compl compels
me to urge the members of this committee
to vote against the passage of house
bill 1255.
this law while written with the best of
intentions has an unparalleled capacity
to cause irreparable harm to this
country through the political precedent
that it sets
the restrictions to the fundamental
right of free speech that it places on
our public educators and the
irreversible impact that this bill would
have on our ability to openly and
honestly confront our past
our education system is one of the most
important parts of this country which is
another reason that i'm grateful that
every single member of this committee
and they're tasked with equipping future
generations with the vital skills and
knowledge that they need to be
productive members of society as well as
informed and responsible voters it is
because of this tremendous
responsibility that any and all attempts
at flagrant partisan tampering foisted
upon these institutions by the
government whether stated federal should
never be tolerated
they are beneath the values that
underpin the creation of this very
nation and betray the principles of free
speech open discussion and robust lively
national debate
we should strive to pass those values
the values that have had me sitting
before you today
on to the future generations and
hopefully as a citizen of new hampshire
and have been for my entire life i hope
that my kids will one day get to be a
part of that robust debate
i understand especially from
representative lackas testimony that the
goal of this bill
is to try and stand against
indoctrination and i can understand
exactly how important that is but with
the text as it's currently written i i
honestly fear
that the consequences of this
are
are ultimately going to be ones that
obfuscate and stand in the way of the
ability to have an honest discussion in
this country
well ideologically i think we can all
agree that racism was not necessarily
the foundation that america was laid on
it's not like people created a nation
and said we're going to be a nation of
slave owners it was founded on that on
the ideas of personal civil liberty it
was founded on the ideas of
enlightenment it was founded on the
ideas based on people like adam smith it
was founded on the the ideas of
alexander hamilton it was founded on on
the ideas of some of the most incredible
thinkers that have that have come out of
the world even to this day
but the truth is that at a at a
structural level not just at an
ideological one there are lots of ideas
inside of this country that
fundamentally are racist
the three-fifth compromise is not
something that is not baked into the
center of this country
inside of the legislation where the
three-fifth compromise shows up it also
directly talks about the fact that
indians are not counted inside of
representation inside of this country we
can't act like those aren't facts
i understand the purpose of this bill i
understand that it comes from the best
of intentions but ultimately
i
i have a severe worry that these aren't
issues that we can talk about openly and
honestly especially because the language
of advocation is so vague i i am not a
product of our public education system i
was very lovingly raised by two
homeschool parents who are both very
conservative
and and they they gave me the skills
necessary to learn how to think not just
what to think and it's because of that
that i got obsessed with both public
policy and debate which is something
that i spent my entire adolescence
studying and learning how to do
correctly
um
but but it's also because of that
education that i
i mean honestly i'm really concerned one
of the things that was brought up a lot
was this idea of indoctrination and
while i can understand why why there's a
legitimate concern there especially when
we're talking about a public institution
um i think that there's something that's
really important to recognize about
ideology and it comes from one of my
favorite quotes ever the the problem
really with ideology is that if you
don't see one it's yours
no matter what we do there are going to
be ideological elements to the way that
we teach there are going to be
ideological elements to the way that we
we speak to our children and and i can
understand the the desire to curtail
that and create a nation that's
that's proud of our history
but
and and one that wants to continue the
traditions that we have so far but
in the exact same breath we can't do
that unless we recognize that the trail
of tears is baked into the the history
of this country we can't do that
effectively if we don't talk about the
fact that
slavery was so embedded in the creation
of this country that we had to fight a
civil war for it and even after that
civil war was done we weren't truly
finished with the idea of
overcoming racism and even through the
work of martin luther king jr we still
have lots of issues we've had struggles
with redlining we've had struggles with
disproportionate policing and some of
those things are politicized and i can
certainly understand that not every
member of this committee is going to
agree with me but i think that it's
totally
perfectly honest that we need to
give our educators the ability to be
perfectly honest on these issues
um
i think that's about all i have to say i
i do want to thank you all very much for
for the ability to speak um i would have
had more of a prepared statement but i
kind of had to take off work really fast
yesterday and spend about three hours
writing about three paragraphs because
again i i really do take the
responsibility you all have here very
seriously um with that i i thank the
chairman and um i yield the floor back
thank you very much you are very
articulate and uh did a great job
any any uh questions from the committee
not seeing enhanced thank you
thank you
really
would you be willing to work with me to
help with the wording to try to get
the concept the idea behind it without
chilling conversation yeah i i'd
certainly be willing to do my best yeah
thank
you john dejoy i think i s uh
so it's written testimony we can enter
in okay good we will do that uh is
deborah house here
we have for the committee there's
including deborah there's two others
to go so about three
okay good morning chairman led and
members of the committee uh i'm happy to
be able to address you again today and i
you know did take in what you said about
not reading my testimony i do have
written testimony that i will be passing
around
i will try to
pull out some key points thank you i'm
here today representing the american
federation of teachers new hampshire we
have
3 500 teachers power educators school
support staff public service employees
and higher ed staff across the state of
new hampshire i'm happy to be able to
bring the perspective of my members here
to the committee
we obviously oppose hb 1255 and i did
listen carefully to the earlier speakers
about the intent of the bill and how
they felt it was not represented in what
was
written up in the bill
however
it did not address our concerns we feel
that what was written up and what i
heard earlier is so vague it will still
have that
chilling effect and make it almost
impossible for teachers to understand
what they can permissibly
teach in the classroom
and do their jobs well and faithfully by
their students our members are dedicated
to meeting the students needs by
engaging them in honest history lessons
that teach them to think critically
about information it would be a
disservice to our students to limit
their class materials or discussions
only to the parts of our history that
show our nation in a positive light
the problem with
saying you don't want endocrine
is indoctrination is in the eye of the
beholder
um
it is a very subjective term is a very
vague term and
frankly that's
the big problem with the divisive
concepts law from last year it's so
vague that there's a lawsuit over it
and when you tie that to people's
livelihoods
then
you have
put a punishment over
something that is vague and subjective
if you're a teacher this legislation
leaves you confused on how you can talk
about many subjects in your classroom
and we've heard several examples from
other speakers including the
three-fifths compromise
they will have such a chilling effects
the teachers will feel intimidated
uncertain and hampered from teaching a
full account of our nation's history
even worse
the bill undermines our children's
education and their ability to grow into
engaged citizens and critical thinkers
so
it's
taking away
from both our teachers ability to do
their jobs
thoroughly
and honestly
as taking away from our students it's
taking away the
tools they need
to be able to learn
to be able to get what they need from
their um from their teachers and from
their classes they need to be able to
have those open house discussions to be
able to explore topics
you know we have heard from our members
that they are afraid of going near
certain topics already and this would
double down on it
um
i will close with a quote here or get to
in just a moment public education is the
lifeblood of our democracy preparing the
next generation for college career and
life the core of our job as educators is
to teach the skills students need to
succeed
showing history as it really happened
isn't disloyalty
as historian james bryce wrote back in
1909 true patriotism consists not in
waving a flag not in shouting our
country right or wrong but in so value
you're valuing our country and
respecting its best traditions
as to desire to strive that our country
shall be righteous as well as strong
hiding the truth from our children both
wounds their trust in us and dishonors
the true meaning of patriotism
we need to be honest with them we need
to teach
true honest robust history and allow
them to have honest and open discussions
no one's indoctrinating
we need to let
it's subjective yes you see and that's
the problem with making a law that
punishes people
for
teaching
historic facts
these laws don't help kids learn they
don't help teachers teach what they will
do is deprive our children of a quality
education by instilling fear in the
classroom and pushing a sugar-coated
shallow version of our country's history
i urge you to vote this bill and
expedient legislate and i will pass this
around thank you
um we have two left here i first want to
recognize i think we have some girl
scouts here today do we
no yes
from a legislative program that you have
within
welcome
um
we have two to go here and for those
that are coming in for a one o'clock i'm
gonna not start that at one we're going
to be slipping behind the half hour and
all our bills
we're already there and the committee
needs to have a chance to get up and
refresh
and have a have a meal so i'm going to
try to get through these last two cards
quickly
the next one is from um
i i asked my i had a hard time with your
name the other day welcome back
is that asma
that is correct okay asma and it's
pronounced like the letter s
yeah okay thank you
well welcome
thanks um for having me here again today
uh so again my name is esmahini i'm with
rights and democracy um i speak to you
today as not only an employee with
rights and democracy but also an
immigrant and as i said yesterday a
global citizen of the world
um it seems that a lot of the provisions
of yesterday's bill 1632 was also stuck
into this
bill 1255 and so i'm not going to repeat
my arguments but i just wanted to just
give a gist which is it's great that
people want to teach about other
countries and i totally agree with that
but that is not what this bill is going
to do
and so i am definitely opposed to it
um
so basically again the bill the reason
why it would be good to learn about
other countries is because you want to
teach about a world view but again this
is not um a way to do it we instead
teachers would be downplaying our
mistakes by pointing to others which
teaches students to deflect their own
mistakes so we have to keep that in mind
i'm also quite disturbed that this bill
has expanded divisive concepts to
include other topics
and some of them are socialism and
marxism and if this passes there's
obviously going to be more topics that
are surely going to be added on to
divisive concepts so i'd like to explain
why this is egrogus
and also the fact that this bill poses
consequences disciplinary consequences
which further puts an already at edge
educational system and teaching force at
an even more vulnerable state
so several things i'd like to point out
when talking about marxism
there are things that marx got right
and there are things that marx got wrong
there are theories in marxism and
socialism that many of us here will
agree with for example abolishing child
labor so shall we teach
banishing that
because that's marxism marxism and
socialism is a con conglomerate of
theories many many theories it does not
mean just one thing
again some are right some are wrong
theories whatever theories they can be
are challenged and are challenged all
the time
it's a part of human history to have
theories and to wrestle with them the
danger is banning theories it keeps us
from being able to explore and
investigate our human condition
it is sad to think that marx and
socialism has just been summed up into
overthrowing the government which by the
way a democracy also a theory teaches
could happen
i don't think i need to remind people a
government for the people by the people
and one of the reasons the second
amendment was put in place many hold the
opinion including many on this committee
shall we ban democracy
what are we doing why are we limiting
the human ability to discern right from
wrong
we have to trust in the human ability to
think
last the part in this bill that gives
consequences for teachers teaching the
negative aspects of our history which is
well documented and can't be denied is
only creating an environment to control
teachers and robs students of the
ability to understand our history
because our history is a messy history
and that's just a fact it's messy
there's good and there is bad in it and
the greatest lesson that students can
take from that is that we will make
mistakes and that there is hope and the
possibility to fix our mistakes even
today
just as we have fixed some of our
mistakes in the past and see the
connection that our past mistakes affect
some of the mistakes that we make today
and can we and we can address them so
that we can truly live into the
multi-racial democracy that we should
and we can be
where white black and brown can thrive
together
thank you thank you very much
and our last speaker is rusan chester
do you have a pink card up here
okay if you sign up there it technically
we do it on the pink cards if you want
to speak before the committee so the
committee can
have that go ahead and fill that out
rousseau go ahead and then we'll
thank you and thank you for allowing me
to speak today i am in support of an
amendment on this bill i like that i
like the idea behind this bill
unfortunately because i feel it's
necessary in our in our um community
today i have children and grandchildren
here in new hampshire who have been
subjected to some of the indoctrination
policies
so
i can speak to that
i also have um i also worked very
closely with christy mcauliffe and
although she was she had strong
um
she had a strong moral ethical and um
individual compass she provided facts
she provided both
sides
and then she helped her children
learn to discern and make use their
critical thinking skills to develop
their
own positions
so and in my opinion that is the intent
of this
of this um bill before us
i grew up in a time where we didn't
notice black or white um
i grew up in a time where we called them
negroes or
african-american or i don't even
remember but i i grew up and i had some
black children in black students in my
school here in new hampshire in the 60s
but i can honestly tell you that i
didn't even realize that they were black
until i looked at my school pictures
because i did we didn't identify people
that way i didn't identify my teachers
as the old white teacher i identified
her as she was my favorite teacher
because she always made sure that i
could tie my shoe right
and that's something that's that's
something that we've lost we identify
people by the color of our skin we
identify people by their thoughts and
their opinions and their sexual
orientation and their preference and
that's just wrong we identify them
whether they're
on the right or on the left or it's just
ridiculous and the point is is that it
does happen the indoctrination does
happen in our school unfortunately
the good thing is is i don't think
anyone in this room
would stand for that i don't think any
one of these teachers would con would
think or believe that that's happening
however i'm talking from someone who has
seen it i have been in the classroom and
my jaw almost dropped when i've heard
some of the words that were coming out
of the teacher's mouth because they
thought that i was of the same mindset
one of the things that i've heard a lot
about is system systemic racism
the ugliness of our history the chilling
effect that this would cause for the
teachers um
i have a problem with calling our
educator our educators teachers
teachers are someone that
teaches a teacher is do it this way this
is the way you must do it because you're
teaching me to do it an educator
gives students all the information
and
all the facts all the theories
and lets them make their own decision
very similar to an attorney an attorney
doesn't take a position they they
they have no opinion you know no opinion
or a judge i should say a judge
um
so i would i would argue that it's not
our educators job to teach that slavery
is wrong although it is in my opinion
um
it's not the teacher's job to teach
about that jim crow laws were wrong or
what happened to the japanese americans
in our country
was wrong what's important is you teach
them the facts you provide them with the
facts you provide them with the with the
ability to understand
and form their own
philosophies and opinions about what is
and is not their truths
so although i um
i agree with the intent of this bill i
think it has a long way to go however i
think this bill is a
good beginning
where
we can develop
healing and healthy relationships
on the right and on the left
on the black and brown and on the white
on the
um
um individual identities so this is a
fantastic opportunity to start
developing that communication that
relationship
and if we turn around and we say
socialism marxism that's all bad
that's not that's theory that's theory
what was bat we need to say like the
last um
presenter just spoke we need to say this
is the facts about socialism
take what's good
throw away what's bad
you make the decisions of what's good
you make the decisions of what's bad
that is what's going to do that is
what's going to resolve the divide in
our classrooms
with our communities and with our
country
that's it
thank you very much
questions
thank you and our last speaker then is
bruce burke
thank you i will speak for less than two
minutes
uh i'm uh
retired uh history teacher of 35 years
i value succinctness in the classroom so
i'm going to uh
skip most of this and i think just make
a point that's been touched upon but
i think it's important so let me just
refer to one paragraph and i will be
done
i can speak to across the country we
have an educational crisis
right covid
is
creating an almost an epidemic of
teachers
being burnt out and retiring or choosing
other professions
and this bill is written will exacerbate
this problem for new hampshire
right just imagine for a moment
i've gone to undergraduate school i've
now gone to graduate school i'm a newly
minted
educator or teacher
and this bill exists in new hampshire
i'm not going to look to work here
we have a crisis
filling spots of highly motivated
curious educators who love our children
the bill is written won't do that
so
i would just say uh not to be too clever
uh but
we are the home of the brave
and not the fearful
and this bill is fearful
thank you thank you very much with that
i i appreciate all those that came today
and sat through this and offered us
input it's appreciated and i hope
everybody has a wonderful afternoon and
representative porter do you have the
numbers i do um signing in in support
26 signing in in opposition 2232
and one neutral thank you very much with
that uh this hearing is closed we will
come back at this we'll post on the door
the next will start at 1 30.
i tanked them so much
[Music]
privacy
thank you
what i do is
a ticket
[Music]
oh
yes
no thanks
legacy
[Music]
you know i think we got out of there
fairly unscathed yeah
this could have gone on all day long
yeah
i think that with people careful coming
in here they're 2 000 people oh
uh
why not
this is
is
i'm
[Music]
great society
i
is
yes
i
[Music]
is
okay
they don't worry
yes
is
teachers
oh
is
so in the last
last probably 10 years
um
is
all right
i think i think in the last like five
years
um
oh yeah of course
i think is okay
actually
um
too appropriately
it was
oh
because
good stuff
400 people
sometimes
well i'm in the criminal justice
committee
one side is yeah
[Music]
some of them yeah
so get started
those two together yeah
[Music]
okay
is
all these things
i'm okay with talking about biases
oh
[Music]
is
and eventually i'm like
because
is
you know writing a paper about why the
taliban is not
a terrorist organization
and if you don't
support that then my bad break
um representatives
right he says
um
yes
but it wasn't being
that's the thing there is a theory and
that was my point
and actually
put in there you should not teach all
these facts
a problem but like
i'm not sure that we can deal with it
like the issue teaches you through the
legislation
then what happens and we've learned this
in times where things were obviously
things were happening in schools that
everybody
i don't know if it was the teacher at
the end or a couple of
ones before me but someone said and i
know
i mean
you
you know and yeah analyze it and all
that kind of stuff
because that's
more education
and in particular
right and most people most people
okay
and making children
despair
based
i think it's more that we should be
taking on
again those powerful people like i feel
like the teachers who are
as a result of the culture we're
creating
we have to fight and that's because
everyone feels this sort of
there's no there's no help happening
from these legislators
everyone has to be their own health and
then
that bleeds into your job that leads
into your life and then however
passionate you are about these issues
you can't fight it's not 2007 anymore
you have to be able to bite your tongue
and be like okay here's math and it's a
little bit hard for teachers who feel so
wrapped up in this
what's happening in the world
what's going
it's incredibly difficult for them to do
their job correctly because
the
real
guiding principles
i'm incredibly proud
oh
yeah well i i think part of it too is
that a lot of historians are likely
taking issue with that claim
more because
in a lot of ways there's there is a
cardinality there and i can understand
there's a difference between the
ideological foundations of the country
and the structural foundations of the
country it's very hard to argue with the
idea that the transit landing strategy
is
sort of puts aside
uh
all right
[Music]
each other's humanities
is and we were there
oh
is
[Music]
it's not easy
oh
all right
thank you
okay uh right now
six
i will fill out the pink card
i just forgot
okay my name is representative alicia
lucas i represent hudson and pelham
i'm going to be real brief on this
because this is basically
a very simple idea
we spent a long time
and the school boards association and
the school teachers and everybody spent
a long time coming up with
the uh professional code of
the code of ethics and the professional
code of conduct but what we've learned
through many years is if you have
[Music]
something that has no teeth a lot of
people ignore it and so all this bill is
about is putting a little teeth behind
it that says
if you don't follow your own
professional code of conduct and code of
ethics
then
and you are found guilty of it so you
have actually violated it
then it shall
shall it shall result in one of these
three things and it would be determined
based on you know the severity like i
can ima cannot imagine
that um
somebody who for instance
engaged in sexual
uh conduct with a child would just get a
reprimand or the other hand somebody who
slipped up in class and inadvertently
said something without realizing what it
was that they would get a revocation of
their license i mean it would be
proportional to whatever it was that
they did
but it's just to say
yeah if you violate this then there are
consequences and that's it it's just to
put a little teeth behind it
absolutely
okay i have one for you um are you aware
that
the
consequences that are in this bill are
exactly the same consequences that are
in the professional code of teacher
ethics i think the difference is this
shall
yes the consequences are the same
but this says shall that yeah you shall
meet those consequences
are there further questions yes
representative tanner
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative
is where is the due process in this
um
i believe that's also in
the whole
thing i mean i there may be somebody
here who can explain exactly how it
works because i don't know how it works
i just know that in conversation we had
before that we were told that there's a
whole process
but
i think that's already in existence and
so maybe somebody else can answer it
further questions represent porter
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question representative um who
was involved in in ranking these and
giving these um titles reprimand
suspension etc were you working with an
organization that was helping you with
this or was this something that was
devised in another way as uh
representative ladd said
um this is in the code of professional
code of conduct
it's already in there
do you know where it came from
if you may we we have the department of
education here but it also came as a
result of a task force of teachers okay
working properly with the folks from doe
to develop this code thank you
no further questions for you
representative
uh megan tuttle
thank you chairman lad um members of the
committee megan tuttle president any new
hampshire um just a quick question on
this i guess um
and we're not against the kodokana code
of ethics we were any new hampshire was
part of the crafting of this and so
we're fully aware of what it is and we
fully do support that we should have it
we're just wondering why it needs to be
put into law if they're already in the
rules
administrative rules carry the weight of
law i believe and we heard this morning
the good thing about the rules though is
there is some flexibility from chairman
klein
so
i guess we're just wondering
you know why we needed to do this there
was a law that was passed to tell the
state board of education to create this
code of conduct that was done um
not really sure why it needs to be put
into life it's already there
that's all
are there
any questions or from the committee here
we do have uh
coming up right now the doe
um so uh i'm good
megan you're good okay
thank you have a good afternoon
good afternoon my name is diana fenton
i'm an attorney with the department of
education are you a senator or rep today
i haven't decided
i haven't decided you cut the lunch
break short so i'm leaning towards
senator a little bit
welcome thank you very much for having
me i'm happy to take any questions as it
pertains to house bill 1333 or 1336
rather um
i think historically it is important to
note that um due to legislation that was
passed uh the code of conduct was
created by a task force department of
education worked very closely with its
partners
nea aft school boards association
superintendents association
um it started out as a task force on the
code of ethics and that was a
commissioner's task force and then as
the legislation um that representative
ladd put forward was working its way
through the system the task force uh
finish its work on the code of ethics
and then did a pivot to address the
legislation that was passed and adopted
into law
to create the code of conduct but part
and parcel with the code of conduct the
department recognized that we had to
have
administrative procedures by which to
enact the code of conduct anytime you
put a code of conduct on a profession
any profession you have to have a system
by which it is administered and so the
511s deal with that process piece the
510s are the code of conduct and the
department has printed
those are available on our website and
we've printed booklets of those
and those are available those are the
five tens but the content and the
process piece which as a as an attorney
i think is the most important piece are
in the 511s
and i can tell you that um
these three sanctions
are set out in the 511s these three
sanctions
are what the department um
administers when there is a finding
of a violation of the code of conduct
those cases are not done on an island
and they're not done in a vacuum they
are done
with myself
as i oversee educator misconduct
investigations with the investigator for
the department
the commissioner and the deputy
commissioner
so
we decide these cases once we have all
the facts and there's been a
determination we will talk about what
the appropriate sanction is but it's
also really important to um
to note that the department and i've
said this to um
the commissioner and the deputy
commissioner
very much uh all the time probably i
have said to them the department is held
to its precedence
anything we do in this particular case
we will be held accountable to it in
another case because our actions are not
and cannot be arbitrary it is not
targeted towards the individual it is
targeted towards the action and so if we
are to
uh
impose a revocation for certain conduct
then we use that case as a guiding
principle for future cases and i think
that's really important to recognize
and i'm happy to take any questions
yes represent cordelia
thank you thank you for being here again
or still i don't know um
uh how has the code played out in
practice since it was uh first uh
implemented
thank you for the question um
the code
in in my opinion and speaking on behalf
of the department um
i think the code has had a lot of
success um in a number of ways i think
recognizing that educator misconduct is
not a local issue
it is a statewide issue because if there
is someone harming children that is a
statewide issue that is not a local
issue and we cannot have a local control
solution fix the statewide problem and
so we've really had the opportunity to
work with our districts work with our
partners and and have kind of a hand in
glove approach and i think the districts
appreciate the support in these cases
most notably we had a case
right here in concord um where the code
of conduct was instrumental in
identifying someone who was dangerous
around children and that person was
arrested for those those crimes um
criminally and it was a significant case
and it was one of the first cases right
out of the gate but that is not to
diminish the other cases that the
department has worked on uh which are of
equal importance and value although they
might not end up in the press
yes represent tanner
thank you i actually have two issues one
one was my question i asked
representative lakers um
what what is the due process and does
the person that's charged actually get
the ability to bring in an attorney like
you
uh well
you probably can't bring in me because
that would be that would be that would
be a conflict but uh i appreciate the
question so the the due process is set
out in the 511s and i appreciate the
question um
because that was
fundamental in the success of the of the
implementation of the code of conduct so
a couple of things as it pertains to the
due process
um
if someone is placed under investigation
by the department of education
that term investigation is a it is a
term of art and so that person is
notified via certified mail
and the superintendent of the district
of employment is also notified just via
regular mail and we also send
a copy of the letter to the union
whether it's nea or aft we actually have
a very close working relationship with
nea
on these cases
and so
everyone is notified and within that
letter we tell that individual this is
the allegation
um we tell them the provision of the
code that is alleged to have been
violated and we give them a factual
basis for it
um
and so then that
starts our process we will then be
notified i'll use nea as an example um
because we just work with them so much
uh nea will then send us a letter
telling us
uh this is the attorney who represents
them you're not to have any further
contact with
our client and we work exclusively with
the attorney for the union um
we will do our fact finding or we
receive a report from the district it
just depends on the circumstances of the
case
and then we will
have that discussion with the union to
say
these are these are the facts that we
can prove um this is where we come down
on this particular case
the person has a right to challenge that
we have had cases go to a hearing
and it is overseen by a hearing officer
and then we had a case recently get
challenged to the state board um and so
that's where you're finding those those
pieces of due process um
as
in terms of the
discipline which is
handed out
what i um take great pride in is
everything is documented and so a letter
of reprimand is written out and it says
exactly what
what the reprimand is what it's for um
how long it's on file for same with the
suspension and revocation everything's
listed out and then it's signed by all
the relevant parties
nothing is done
uh in secret and that was a really big
push by the department is just
transparency with the field of what the
expectations are and then how the
department will respond if there is an
alleged violation
thank you and
yes thank you
so
uh does this
how does this affect
people who are teaching
educating
who are not
credentialed so we have charter schools
where half the people are not
credentialed we we are giving money
public money to non-public schools
religious schools
educational vendors like prenda
and we have a number of teachers who are
not in union schools
so
how does this affect them and
in the realm of due process and
notification or does the ethics not
affect them because you you don't have
any jurisdiction over them
so the code the code of ethics is
not actionable
in the sense of what we're talking about
here the code of ethics is aspirational
and language
and it applies to all educational
personnel whether they are credentialed
by the department of ed or they're not
when we talk about the code of conduct
however the code of conduct is
actionable and it is only actionable
upon a credential
and so that is limited in scope to
people who are licensed by the
department of education to teach
as a fellow
yes
so
uh if if somebody for example in
a charter school who is not credentialed
commits a violation of the ethics part
of it
uh is recognized as or reported or
however that
goes along um what is it can does the
department do anything about it or are
they just uh get out of free get out of
jail free card
uh well i'm going to clarify your
question a little bit so
you mentioned the code of ethics
code of ethics again is not actionable
whether it's credentialed or
non-credentialed individual but if we
got a call from a charter school which
we do because um last session i believe
it was representative cordelie's bill
made the code of conduct applicable to
charter schools and so we are working
with charter schools
on the code of conduct
but if we have an individual who is not
credentialed by the department of
education and there is a violation of
the code of conduct
the department doesn't have any action
that it can take if there is not a
credential
uh for that individual
there's no direct action
it falls outside of our jurisdiction and
we have that issue even notwithstanding
charter schools we have that issue with
pair educators who some are credentialed
some are not and so when we receive a
call of a report one of our questions is
is this individual
credentialed or not it's just part of
our vetting process
we have that whether or not it's with a
charter school or not doesn't doesn't
that leave a lot of students
uh at risk
possibly
at risk
you know your your question calls for a
number and it's hard to quantify i can't
provide a number um what i can tell you
is that the code of conduct
was written to
attach to the license just like my
license to practice law um if you're an
attorney who never passed the bar or
didn't take the bar
the presumably the new hampshire
bar association doesn't have any direct
access to your license because you don't
have one
so what i can tell you is the
department's jurisdiction as it pertains
to the code of conduct is limited to
those individuals who have a credential
to teach
one more follow-up so
so a lawyer who doesn't pass the bar
doesn't get to practice law
but
a person who thinks that they're
educated enough to teach or has been
hired as a teacher
can teach they teach right beside people
who are credentialed
in charter schools they're right beside
them and get the probably the same
amount of money the same amount of
um respect the same amount of
you know gravitas of the job of being a
teacher so
uh and probably half the people
students going to the school or parents
that are sending their kids to the
school don't know
which ones are credentialed and which
ones aren't so if they're in that
equalized position
and yet haven't gone through the
professional
credentialing for the job which is
you know a lawyer couldn't do that right
lawyer couldn't stand in front of the
court and argue a case
without a
you know
professional certificate so
um what i'm saying is
the reason that they can't or you can't
practice medicine unless you have a
degree
is that um
doesn't that put students i'm not asking
for a number i'm just saying doesn't
that leave a big gaping hole
that um
leaves students in a position to be
subject to uh violations of the code of
conduct for for teachers
i well i'll give you the classic lawyer
answer since i
since i am licensed to stand in front of
a court and argue uh it depends
um i went to a lot of education to learn
that phrase
and paid a lot of money for it too um
it does depend but i i want to recognize
that there was a bill passed last
session which made the code of conduct
applicable to charter schools regardless
of the status of the individual
who was teaching and i think that is a
significant step forward what i will
again reiterate
um
is simply the department has that that
jurisdiction uh to just oversee
credentialed educators and i think
reasonable minds can differ as to the
value of that
however
we do have this new law that was passed
which we are now working with our
charter schools and i think that is the
significance do you mean the charter
schools are held to the code of conduct
another question this is getting to be a
one-way
just wanted to clarify because she said
the law said that they're held to the
code of conduct is that
that's true
so the code the the code of conduct is
now applicable to charter schools and i
just want to make sure that that's okay
that's it
representative walsh do you have a
question i do mr chairman i have a quick
question um i spent five years on the
guardian and lighting board when they
were doing their rulemaking and one of
the things that we did is we do not make
complaints public until they're founded
because there were a good number of
unfounded allegations i think the bar
does the same thing my question is is
when there's a complaint against the
code of conduct is that immediately
public or only when there's a finding of
cause
thank you for the question and we follow
very similar rules uh so if someone is
under investigation and again that is a
term of art within the department of
education found within our rules 511s um
that is not public information and we
have had press inquiries of individuals
um and the department has said that
that's just not public information
across the board um however if there is
a finding
for revocation or suspension and i will
go back to the idea of that
documentation where the individual and
their union lawyer both sign that
document as does the department of ed
um if someone has a suspension or
revocation they were then placed on the
the list the department's revoked and
suspended educator list and that
information is public
we will provide that upon request and we
provide it to school districts
on a regular basis to help them with
their hiring decisions and they have
requested that
so and then the reprimands are
private
uh i have one question to ask you uh
although the code of ethics which is
aspirational as you've mentioned
uh is uh in relation to uh relationships
with community parents
students
uh use of technology there's those
categorical areas within the code of
ethics
when it comes to the application of this
through the code of conduct
could you please
explain for those on the committee may
not be aware
is that involve administrators and
principals paraprofessionals etc that
have this certification because under
certification law
a principal is considered a teacher
yes thank you for the question so um as
additional clarity the four principles
that are set forth in the code of ethics
those were mirrored in the code of
conduct and those were set forth in in
the statute that was passed so you might
see a little difference in the language
but the the intent is the same they were
mirrored um there is one additional
principle in the code of conduct and
that is the duty to report
that you will not find in the code of
ethics and the code of conduct is again
it's applicable to all individuals who
hold a credential issued by the
department of education and it is
equally applicable to administrators
whether it's superintendents or
principals
and the department
has
taken action across the board when it's
appropriate
thank you
yes represent cordelia and
representative mullen
thank you mr chairman um
just
if i want to be clear
you're talking about actionable in terms
of
the ability of the department to take
action
but irregardless of whether someone has
a credential or not
they there could still be actionable
or action taken
within the judicial system based on the
offense
if yes thank you for the question if the
matter rises the level of a criminal
offense certainly the court system would
would take its action but i think to
kind of leap frog off of your question
um there's always the realm of
employment and so when you look at
someone who might not be credentialed
there is the employment realm and so
that is it really is a two-tiered system
and i go back to that hand and glove
approach
the department is relying upon the
districts and the districts rely upon
the department to make sure that
children are safe all over our state so
the department's not able to take action
there could be uh
appropriate employment action at the at
the local level at the district level
and so that's why i always go back to
that hand and glove approach because
there's employment which is dealt with
exclusively by the districts and then
there's credentialing and that is the
realm of the department of ed
representative mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question attorney fenton so
this bill calls for rsa21n93c
to be amended
can you tell me if these if the
reprimand the suspension and the uh
revocation are already in the rules
what will
codifying it in
21n92c what will it do what will the
effect be of
passing this
so the
um
the sanctions are already set forth
in 11.
um i i will probably defer your question
more to the sponsor as to what the
intent of this bill would be um i i
would
speculate and it's pure speculation that
uh it would be harder to get a repeal of
the code of conduct
um
by putting it in the in the statute but
again that's speculation i would defer
to the sponsor as to what the intent of
placing it in the statute would be
okay i just have one follow-up mr chair
um it also says a violation as
determined by the state board of
education
uh are you and the commissioner and
deputy and investigator deputized by the
state board to
make that determination or
is
chairman klein
now going to be wearing a badge
well
what chairman klein chooses to wear is
completely upset
i don't think i have any say over that
if he'd like a badge he certainly uh he
can have one um
so it's not that we're deputized but
when you look at other provisions of the
of the education law
outside of the code of conduct
you'll see there's that close
affiliation and so when you read the
state board it is it is assumed and it
has been interpreted to mean the
department of education and and the
staff and so there's not a formal deputy
deputizing process uh although
now i want one um but we can take care
of that thank you i appreciate that but
that's how it's always been interpreted
are there further questions represent
yes representative waltz
uh i know and you i'm sure know too from
law school the rules have the force and
effect of law but could you kind of give
a perimeter to people in this room about
the difference between rules and laws
and kind of the effectiveness of them in
the role of them
i hope so let's see um
thank you for the question
it's interesting
working for the department of education
is the first time that i've been engaged
in that rulemaking process so it was
certainly an eye-opening experience for
me that's not something we have in in
criminal law where i where i used to
practice so the way i explain it is this
the statute kind of sets out the
framework of the house if you will right
it's the foundation of the house and
it's the the outline of the house and
then i always think of the rules as kind
of flushing out the interior right it's
the tile it's the backsplashes it's the
uh the curtains it's the paint on the
walls it's things like that it's that
detail level um and it was uh definitely
an interesting experience uh for me to
engage with our stakeholders in that
process and i think what is so unique
about education is the work we do with
our partners and our stakeholders um i
can tell you
from my past uh employment and just
being a lawyer i was very lone wolf and
so this was a
great learning experience and i think
it's by working with our stakeholders
and our partners that we learn all the
different viewpoints of how what has to
be addressed and all the various
concerns and that's what i think the
strength of rulemaking
really is whether it's in this
particular subject area or any of the
areas that the department oversees um
we've had great opportunities to work
with a number of stakeholders on that
rule-making process the one that always
pops to my mind is special education
i think without our stakeholders we
would be lost
but that's just my
two cents i hope that answers your
question sufficiently
well i was more looking to the force of
law effect but than the how you make
rules effect but you know
well the to me the the force of law yes
it does have the same um
effect as law and that comes from the
adoption at jail car in the back and
forth with the um
ols
and then ultimately adoption by jalcar
thank you
okay on that note are there any further
questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you uh i don't think we have any more
pink cards on this one so i'm going to
close this hearing
thank you and we will prepare to go into
the next
order of business
which is
i just don't know anywhere i put my
calendar
sitting here somewhere what's the number
one three
okay we're going to go into hb1113
um
kind of looks like representative porter
is the sponsor of this build
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee and i'm going to put out that
plea this is my first time presenting a
bill to this committee so be kind
um for the record my name is marjorie
porter i represent the good towns of
hillsborough antrim and windsor which at
one point
advertise themselves as the switzerland
of new england
all during the pandemic
schools have been forced to adapt and
figure out ways to keep learning
happening
while also keeping kids
kids and staff
safe and healthy
this has been and continues to be
stressful for all involved
the governor and the state department of
education have for the most part left
the decisions about just how to do this
to school districts themselves saying
one size fits all policies were not wise
each district has different
circumstances and what is needed in
dover might not be good for bennington
districts needed to be flexible and
nimble and top-down mandates would
prevent that
districts themselves should decide
issues around masking for example or
when and whether to go hybrid or fully
remote
that's why i was surprised to learn
about the new doe rule around the use of
remote and hybrid learning options
under this new rule all schools must
remain open in order to meet the 180 day
requirement
any school going to hybrid or full
remote due to covet outbreaks or
absences will not receive credit for
those days but instead must make them up
in june
however the use of blizzard bags on
snowy days is still okay
i think i'm not out of line here to say
everyone wants to see our schools open
and our students students and teachers
learning together in our classrooms
for most kids
learning in school is simply better
remote learning is hard on families too
who stays home with the kids
but in this time of covert with large
numbers of kids and staff out sick
with substitutes hard to find or
non-existent
simply being in the building does not
necessarily mean
teaching and learning are happening
i asked some teacher friends to share
their experiences with me and i hope you
will indulge me while i read what they
sent
there was a classroom in my school which
developed a cluster
the teacher had five students in class
and the rest were home quarantining or
having tested positive and none of them
were receiving an education because
remote learning wasn't an option
the teacher did not feel as though she
could introduce new topics with only
five students so it was a wasted week as
far as any new learning for all students
as of right now the sub situation is
bleak another said we are using
paraprofessionals when we can
which means identified students aren't
receiving their hours of support
if we have a teacherless classroom that
class is split among the other grade
level classes which has caused clusters
in the past
under these conditions social distancing
is nearly impossible
all of this makes it hard to deliver
consistent rigorous instruction we're
just trying to make it through each day
from another
in my school we have absolutely no
substitutes
they have been pulling our title one
teachers to cover classrooms
which then cancels their services and
our daily rti or response to
intervention block
these small group lessons for the
students with the most academic needs to
review skills they haven't mastered yet
these students need consistent reading
practice every day and they can't get it
because the intervention teachers are
covering classrooms
if we were remote they would be on
screen together every day
from another there aren't any subs when
they can't move staff around and have a
para educator cover a class they combine
several classes together in the gym or
the auditorium
under those conditions the absent
teachers substitute lesson plan can't be
followed
student attendance is also low and very
inconsistent
students aren't getting the education in
school they should be under these
circumstances because of numerous
absences related to covid
25 to 30 percent of students are out on
any given day another said it's not
always the same students
someone is always missing something that
i present
i have to consistently come up with
alternative things for the students who
have been in class while i make up work
with the kids who miss something
i now have to have two things going at
all times regular work and makeup work
for every concept
it's a juggling act and it's exhausting
and finally
students whose teachers are out are
directed to the auditorium
to join the study hall
this makes hundreds of students
in the same room for upwards of 80
minutes at a time
they mostly go on their computers
the pandemic has forced schools and
teachers to adapt
most schools have the technology in
place to allow hybrid and remote
teaching and most teachers have learned
skills and techniques to make it work so
learning can occur
it may not be perfect but i dare to say
more learning will happen remotely than
it will in half empty open schools or
overcrowded cafeterias
schools are closed on snowy days to keep
kids safe
to keep kids safe
excuse me i've left a whole bunch
of stuff here
in this time of surge and covet in new
hampshire when numbers of daily new
cases is in the thousands when our
hospitals are groaning under the weight
of caring for all the ill
ill and the number of dead keeps going
up 26 yesterday
going hybrid or full remote might be the
best way to keep kids and staff safe
it seems ill-advised to remove this
option now
and i'm wondering what will happen if
the number of days to be made up exceed
the number of days in june
if indeed one size does not fit all as
we have been told and if districts know
what their needs are better than anyone
at a desk in concord does then i urge
you to consider this bill and uh and
vote it ought to pass
thank you and if you have questions i'll
try to answer
questions for representative porter
yes represent cordelie
thank you and
good job on your first
time
you mentioned snow days
to keep students safe
but aren't snow days made up also as
remote learning days would be
snow days can be if if a
a school has a blizzard bags system set
up they can send home work and work
together on computers at home and that
day will not need to be made up it's my
understanding as i saw the rules
further questions
i have a
a question to ask of you
during the recent pandemic and it's been
an awful period of time i agree but
we're going into our third year
and we're starting to notice that the
remote learning has not been as
successful as we would hoped it been
we've seen math scores drop from 48
proficiency to 38 percent proficiency
my observation of just comparing two of
my own grandkids
one went to school one was on remote the
whole time
the one that was in school even though
they were dealing with the covet in that
school
was able to
keep the path going towards where i
would like to see them going in terms of
learning
the one that was on remote
we saw drastic shrinkage emotional
mental
social issues yes
so which of those options is the best
option
you know representative and it's not an
easy decision here
remote learning constant remote learning
is not a good thing we understand that
it's had negative impacts for a lot of
kids but right now we're not talking
about having the school closed for
months like it was in the early days of
the of the pandemic right now we're
talking about a school that is so poorly
staffed that they are not safe
to have they don't have enough adults to
watch over the children that do come in
and they're forced to stay open when
they could close for a day or two go
remote and then come back as things
get better right now they're not allowed
to do that i don't think we're asking
communities to keep their schools closed
forever
but certainly i would want my child with
their teacher on their computer learning
a new skill than sitting with four other
children in an empty classroom where i
can't learn anything new because my
classmates aren't there so i'm there
doing other things
and it's a wasted
week for new learning
or jammed into an auditorium with 80 or
another 100 or 100 kids
working on my computer because there's
not enough teachers to teach me there
i just i think we have to be as the
commissioners often said we have to be
nimble and allow schools to make the
best decisions for their kids at the
time so they could close for a day or
two and then come back when things ease
up
but right now they can't do that and so
every time they close down because it's
not safe they have to add those days in
june and when when june is over
that's the end of the school year so if
they don't have enough days what's going
to happen
and for the teachers who are there and
are doing remote even though this this
the school decides to go remote and
teaching remote they are using up their
teaching days so if the days still have
to be made up at the end of the year
they're going to be over contract and
that's going to be expensive for
districts because they have to get
already used up 385 days or whatever
so we need to give them the flexibility
to do what's best for the kids under
their care
and they don't have it right now thank
you representative tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
questions and good job
do you think that it that not allowing
remote
learning
uh when there are clusters within the
school or when the school has a very
high
absentee
time
takes
out the possibility
of deep cleaning that the schools i know
have done
uh in the past when they've had these
clusters and then they take a couple
days
to go remote uh do you think it really
curbs that
you know i had i hadn't thought of that
representative but that's a very valid
point
thank you
representative mullen
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question representative porter
um
we're not talking about schools making
individual decisions we're talking about
the school board in a community
adopting some sort of uh
metric or policy or whatever correct
that's right okay thank you
further questions
yes representative litchfield
do you think maybe it would be good if
we were to address this at the source
which is why are these schools being
closed due to large clusters a lot of it
is due to possibly maybe children being
quarantined up to 10 days
at one point because they were possibly
a close contact or possibly maybe we
don't have enough testing sites
available and if a child coughs or
sneezes they're not allowed back in the
classroom it could take up to two or
three days
to find a test
i don't know representative i do know
that in hillsboro the town that i live
in the switzerland of new england
currently only 40
of our population is fully vaccinated
and the daily count of new cases
the daily count of cases is approaching
65 and 70. we're a small community
is that the fault of
having to quarantine
i don't know who to put place the blame
on but the reality is that my school has
to stay open
when they don't have enough staff and
when they're not there aren't enough
kids there to really do a full
educational program
are there another other questions for
the representative representative tanner
thank you uh one more question and that
is do you feel that if
schools had
the ability to have a school nurse
and testing
kits on a regular basis
that there wouldn't be the sniffles and
the people sent home
uh for quarantining and probably
reduce some of this uh problem as well
it's all very possible representative
all i know is that right now their hands
are tied and they are forced to remain
open or make up the time in june
further questions
thank you very much
uh
christina
school boards association
good afternoon chairman ladd good
afternoon members of the committee uh
bear christina school boards association
we are in support of house bill
1113.
um
everybody on the committee i presume
knows that i think it was just last week
the state board of education
adopted revisions to department of state
board rule
306.22
you know i nhsba we had very good
conversations with the department when
they were in the state board when they
were considering that i had a handful of
conversations with uh commissioner blue
i had a handful of conversations with
mr klein we provided some suggested
language
they understood nhsba's perspective in
allowing um multiple flexibility and
multiple options for local local school
boards and i certainly understand um the
position of the state board
the the learning loss with schools being
close has been significant nobody
disputes that um nobody disputes that
children are best educated when they're
in a school building in front of a
certified trained experienced teacher
nobody would dispute that
the question though is whether or not we
want to provide certain flexibilities to
our local school districts and we heard
the award was used flexibility was used
when we were talking about learn
everywhere earlier this morning we were
talking about flexibility with the
depart leaving and that having the
department having flexibility um with
respect to the code of conduct with the
bill that was previously before us
um the concerns nhsba has um with uh the
the current version of the department of
education rule that was just adopted is
that it only leaves two options open for
a school district um to close
a a school one is inclement weather and
the other is um i'm sorry to offer
distance education one was inclement
weather the other was upon parental
requests so
you know so a kid can take a vlax class
or find an online course to take latin
or mandarin or whatever it might be
there are
dozens of other reasons why a school
facility may need to be closed for a
certain number of days there may be a
chemical spill um you know near near the
facility uh when was it uh 2007 2008 we
had the ice storm that hit the southwest
region of the state and trees were down
and if there was even power to do remote
if you will um you know my understanding
was there was a fugitive on the run near
kearsarge high school
three or four years ago when the guy was
hiding out in the woods so they had to
close the school for three or four days
till they captured this this individual
so um you know we support um you know
everybody knows nhsba supports local
control over local educational matters
and the local school board should be
able to determine what's best for that
specific community representative porter
talked about a lot of the logistical
issues that our school districts are
facing right now
teachers are getting sick we don't have
substitutes we have
you know the lack of substitutes is so
severe
we've had to lower some of the standards
for
teachers aids and substitute teachers in
our school you know that you just want
somebody who is you know maybe at least
you know at least old enough to buy
alcohol
and now i'm not joking we're having 19
20 year old kids that are
being teachers aids and being
paraprofessionals and being student
teachers because we need we need the
bodies in there um
so uh there are the legit logistical
challenges um you know with what we're
facing still in the midst of of the
pandemic we think there are broader
operational reasons why school boards
should retain this level of flexibility
um
i had one other point i was i was going
to make as well too
and last um
you know
by and by limiting
the flexibility options you know we hope
that
the pandemic gets better
but
is it going to be better in june are we
able to you know stay fully open
you know the the eight o'clock till
three o'clock come june nobody seems to
know you know every time we think we're
sort of out of the woods with this
whether it's the delta or the omicron or
who knows what's going to be next um
seems to be popping up so anyway i just
wanted to you know certainly say we
understand the department's um point of
view in the state board's point of view
we had good conversations with chairman
klein and the commissioner
nhsba just happens to disagree with the
final rule um
but you know uh
we think more flexibility is is better
for local school boards to make these
local determinations so with that i'm
happy to answer any questions uh i have
a question for you first here uh barrett
i'm looking at the area of law where
we're shuffling this verbiage into
it's comes underneath school performance
accountability section 193
which seems to me that
the language which is already in there
speaks to the
the state can't shut down a school or
just take over the management of a
school that's in that's in relation to
uh
pro and most likely i'm
looking into this in terms of possible
intent that they're not doing the
not achieving what they should be in
terms of their accountability and their
performance
is there not a better place to put this
language like in 21n or someplace under
the responsibilities of the local or of
the state board or the department of
education
uh putting it underneath performance
economy ra accountability raises
questions in my mind if it's properly
placed yeah thank you very much for the
question representative i'll be honest
with you i didn't even notice the
placement of the statute i was looking
at just at the language of of the bill
um yeah i i i would be inclined to agree
that um the language would probably be
better placed in 21n perhaps 186 which
is a
lengthy list of of duties and
responsibilities of the state board of
education the language could also be
modified um and rather than you know
limiting depart rather than having a law
that limits
authority of the department of education
nhsba would certainly support a bill
that would enhance the authority of
local school districts local school
boards so you could put an amendment in
perhaps 189
but yeah i'll be honest with you i
didn't even look at the placement of of
of where this bill would go so
i mean we certainly agree with the
language of the bill where where you
want to put it is
is is not overly relevant to nhsba but i
agree mayor perhaps a different place
would be better
thank you very much uh i i always try to
word something the positive rather than
in the negative
this is coming out you can't do this but
let's put it somewhere else where you
can do this sure enabling or authorizing
exactly yes
representative lakers says we're here
yes represent like us
thank you i realized that a lot of this
bill seems to be in response to what the
department of education recently did and
we're talking about short-term closures
etc but from reading the language it
seems to be more encompassing than that
and what about when a school district
just decides regardless of what the
level of covet is
in the community to not be open for an
entire year
thank you for the question
representative um
you know
last
fall and i should not last for i guess
it was fall of
um
local school districts were still given
that flexibility we had some school
districts that were still going full
remote we had some school districts that
were
doing full in person and we had some
school districts that were doing hybrid
coupled you know kids were in a couple
days split schedules that's that sort of
stuff
um you know that seemed to be um you
know i think
the most ideal method and i don't know
of any school right now that is really
interested
or has any intentions of closing
for
a month six months a semester a year
nobody wants to do that and i haven't
heard from any school boards or
superintendents that they plan on doing
that my understanding and speaking with
the superintendents um that have called
on hsba asking for guidance about the
ability to close
prior to the recent rule being adopted
were you know they needed to do it
out of sheer necessity because you know
either they didn't have the staff they
didn't have the the substitute teachers
um they didn't have bus drive bus
drivers have gotten covert as well too
we know there's a bus driver shortage
across the state as well too
so you know one of the proposals or i
mean i don't want to call it a firm
proposal one of the conversations that
nhsba had with um commissioner edelblut
and mr klein
was
you know some flexibility where you
could go remote up to
10 days per se in a school year and
beyond that you would perhaps have to
file some sort of emergency petition
with the commissioner who would have
some sort of rubric to check the boxes
if these boxes are checked then yes you
can continue remote if not then you have
to come back in person that was at least
part of the conversation that that we
had anyway so there are a myriad of ways
that i think you could possibly go with
us
thank you very much thank you thank you
are there further questions
not seeing any hands thank you very much
thank you very much everyone uh drew
klein
board of education
all right
hello again everyone mr chairman thank
you um
this is not a comment on the previous
bill but i have no um desire to wear a
badge just so everybody knows um
so i just wanted to give uh i'll try to
be quick here i got some data i'd like
to go through but first i want to
understanding of what the rule that the
board of education passed actually does
and for clarity sake that rule
is not adopted yet we have to go to jail
car and then has to come back to the
board so it's not actually in effect yet
it's going to take probably till march
before it actually gets goes into effect
so right now we're that we're still
under the current rule which does allow
districts to go uh remote if they want
um
the i want to talk about why we did the
rule the way we did and we had a lot of
discussions a lot of back and forth it
wasn't really nilly we took months to to
work on this and
what we crafted was an option a rule
that gave parents
some say not total say but some buy-in
um
in real time when a district wanted to
go remote and just to clarify what the
rule says
there is zero prohibition
on closing the school
zero
if for health and safety reasons for
covet for any whatever reason a district
wants to close the school our rule does
not prohibit closures at all
so schools can close if their cases rise
and community spread if they have staff
shortages nothing prevents schools
closures i want to make that very clear
we were we very specific about that
because we
were concerned about public health and
safety we didn't want to prohibit a
school from closing what the rule says
is if you close
the instruction
can be remote only if you are closed for
inclement weather
so that would include a blizzard ice
storm snowstorm etc um and the reason we
included that was we wanted to be
consistent with the blizzard bag rule
that predated the pandemic we just
updated the blizzard bag rule for the
current technology to allow them to use
remote instruction if they chose
instead of sending actual paper homework
packets so that was for continuity there
um
the only other way you can go remote
under the rule
is for parents who request it
and i just want to talk about that for a
moment
um
we were very deliberate about that
and and the reason was the data that
we've uh found you don't have to go by
anecdote at this point we have massive
amounts of data globally and in the
united states and in new hampshire to
show the
horrible catastrophic
consequences of forced remote
instruction and i'm not being flippant
when i say forced i'm choosing that word
carefully because what i mean by that is
remote instruction
um
doesn't work well for every single
family there are some families who can
adapt to it really well and those kids
actually thrived in remote but there's a
large subset of families for her remote
instruction does not work
those children tend to be the more
vulnerable more disadvantaged
and that's what the data show and so
when they don't have an option
when they are told um
school is going to be conducted in your
home through a computer and some adult
in your home is going to have to
basically function as a paraprofessional
they're just not equipped to handle that
there are a lot of families that
struggled with that and that's borne out
in the data and what we wanted to do was
essentially protect those families so we
gave parents an option if remote
instruction is what you want go to your
school and request it
we do not require the school to offer it
we wanted to make sure that we weren't
putting that mandate on schools because
that we felt like would be
a bit of an imposition there and
technologically we didn't want to
require it
but
we didn't want to force remote
instruction within districts to force
remote instruction on families for whom
it was a really bad fit and for whom it
had negative consequences so that's why
we structured the rule the way we did
i'm going to just read really quickly
some of the data i'll try to get through
it quick but i think it's really
important when we wrote the rule that's
currently in place that allows districts
to go remote
we drafted that rule in the fall
of 2020
before we had this data so we were
starting to get tricklings of it but we
didn't really know the impact of
large-scale remote instruction and i'm
going to go through some of the numbers
that we've we now have
um in the netherlands they were one of
the first to close down
they did a short short closure and they
they studied the fact learning loss was
shown to equal roughly one-fifth of a
school year
with students from less educated homes
demonstrating losses up to 60 larger so
right away you're starting to see the
disparate impact of remote learning by
the way in the netherlands they had a
system where schools could close and go
remote
but
if you were a family
that that didn't work for
they had from the very beginning they
let you go in person so they did even
though they closed and went remote they
had facilities for low-income families
less educated families that needed that
in-person instruction they accommodated
them and gave them in person
and they still had those large learning
losses
a mckinsey study from last year found
that students nationwide in the u.s
wound up four months behind in reading
and five months behind in math by the
end of the 20-20-21 school year
researchers at mit brown university and
university of nebraska at lincoln
analyst test score data from last spring
they found and i'm quoting pass rates
declined compared to prior years and
these declines were larger in districts
with less in-person instruction end
quote
pass rates fell an average of 6.3
percentage points in english and 14.2
percentage points in math
but here's what they found that was most
interesting i'll quote offering full
in-person instruction rather than fully
hybrid or virtual instruction reduces
test score loss in math by 10.1
percentage points on the base of 14.
14.2 percentage points in ela the loss
is reduced
in fully in person settings by 3.2
percentage points so for percentage and
end quote
so that means
going in person reduced the learning
loss by 71
in math and 50 in reading
that
is perfectly clear that that forcing
families to go remote for whom it's not
a good fit
is really academically damaging i'm
going to quote harvard public health
professor joe allen he's director of
harvard's healthy buildings program this
was in the harvard gazette which is
harvard's official
university
um
public relations publication
quote we see that students are four or
five months behind in reading and math
we see even greater loss for black and
hispanic students and that's the kids
who are in school meaning in the remote
classes
millions of kids are not they're missing
from the system
there has been this casualness about
closing schools that i just don't
understand when you match up the long
list of harms when kids are out of
schools against this idea that we're
just going to close for two days or a
week or two weeks which might turn into
three weeks who knows i think that's a
mistake and it ignores what we've
learned over the past two years and all
the new tools we have schools should not
close
end quote
last july again this is not partisan i'm
now going to transfer to the biden
administration the u.s department of
education's office of civil rights
issued a report
um that report was ordered by president
biden on day one of his administration
to find out the disparities
that the pandemic had caused
or had exacerbated in schools
this is the u.s department of ed civil
rights office
they place particular
emphasis in their report on the effects
school closures had on minority
populations noting that quote
the pandemic's effects on pre-existing
race and ethnicity-based inequities as
indicated by early evidence have been
harsh and predictable end quote now i'm
going to transfer quickly to new
hampshire
um i'm not sure how many people know
this uh data but i'm just going to throw
it out there you may know it um
from the 2019 school year which is the
last week we tested before the pandemic
we didn't test in 2020 to 2021
proficiency in math fell from 48 percent
to 38 percent so that's a 10 percentage
point drop in reading proficiency fell
from 56 to 52
data from new hampshire's largest school
district manchester illustrate i think
very clearly what the negative impact
was the number of students in manchester
failing at least one class
rose 46 percent
i think i i think i typed that wrong i
think it's 36 percent um it from the
2019 to 2020 school year
to the 2020 21 school year and i'll give
you an example that i think really
illustrates this
um
in mclaughlin middle school
in the 2019 and 2020 school year they
had a single student get an f in any
class
one f in the whole middle school in that
school year
in 2020 21 school year they had 234
students get an f
that is the impact
and that's just academic
now we can move to the psychological
impact a study in chicago found that
students experience large gains in
feelings of anger loneliness stress and
depression when they were forced into
remote classes university college london
last year did a meta-analysis of studies
on psychological impacts i'll quote
school closures as part of broader
social distancing measures are
associated with considerable harms to
cyp that's children and young people
health and well-being available data uh
go through that um research i'm still
quoting clearly indicates that remote
learning or even a hybrid model has
significant negative effects on children
and parents mental emotional social and
physical health i'm sorry that quote is
a separate quote from psychology today
from last august
um
still quoting psychology today
parents of children in virtual schooling
were also more likely to report loss of
work emotional distress difficulty
sleeping and problems with finding child
care
the findings suggest that uh in-person
learning may be critical to the physical
and mental health of many families end
quote
i don't think i need to go any more on
the data
what is this we know the impact on
families
that is directly related to the loss in
public school students
that we experienced
i i can't stress enough
how families are frustrated by feeling
like they don't have input and don't
have a choice
new hampshire lost 8
000 students in the 2020 school year
four and a half percent of the entire
public school population left the school
districts and did not come back
they didn't come back this fall
i would associate that with a sense of
helplessness a sense of
loss of control a sense that things are
being imposed on their families that
they don't want and can't handle
um
i think
this particular law the way it's written
would allow districts to offer any
method of instruction they want at any
time for any reason
i'm not saying school districts want to
do this
but what you're enabling is a district
to go fully remote for as long as it
wants
i don't think that's going to happen i
think we've seen that districts don't
want to go remote but in the long run as
we're talking about population declines
we're talking about tax-based issues
we're talking about school districts
that are shrinking you could conceivably
have a school district particularly in
the remote parts of the state in a few
years or 10 years decide you know what
um
the money
makes more sense we're gonna go remote
and there's nothing to prevent that
um i think you've got to be careful with
what you're enabling here and parents
should have a buy-in and have a say if
parents don't have a say
you're just going to keep driving them
out of the system and i don't think
that's what any of us wants so that's
why we wrote the rule the way that we
did and i'm happy to take questions
thank you very much thank you very much
mr klein um i'm really worried about
where we're going with our kids when i
me too as a trustee for the university
system throughout america
we've lost one million
higher ed students in the last year yeah
now we're doing the same on the k
through 12 level here in our state in
terms of figures she just gave us
we're going to see a generation here
that's
they came in with covet a high school
student when they were maybe a freshman
this year when they're seniors they're
still experiencing this they've gone all
in and out all those years what have
they missed
could we not
solve that better by requiring them to
be in school
i don't need that i'm just i'm just
curious no we are we have a huge problem
and um or with options like holland or
the netherlands that you alluded to i'm
just concerned i'm looking for how do we
get out of this hole well and again i
just want to reiterate reporter
under our rules schools can close for
health and safety releases literally no
prohibition whatsoever if they want to
close they can close
that's
the difference is why would you force
families the most vulnerable families
that we demonstrated with data in new
hampshire
have had devastating consequences from
remote learning
the question is not where the schools
can close schools can close the question
is
when they're closed for these reasons
are we going to force families who can't
easily
manage remote learning
into remote learning that's the question
and what we're saying is no you
shouldn't do that you should offer them
a day in person at the end of the year
that's right i just have one follow-up
you know let the committee have it okay
so
okay i've gone through it with remote
learning with our our grandkids
and
has the department looked at what is
remote learning is it just the giving of
assignment and say kid you're on your
own get it done and then hammer into the
computer your your answers etc
i saw that
with one of my youngsters all last year
that's not supposed to happen
technically remote instruct it's called
remote instruction and it's supposed to
be instruction
so um technically under the rules you're
not supposed to just
give kids an assignment and then like
turn off the screen and have them do it
it's supposed to be live
teacher and so it can be recorded but
it's supposed to be instruction so
that's that's how it's supposed to work
kids have a um a right under the rules
um to
to be instructed
not just to be sent home homework packet
i'm pleased to hear that yeah um
questions from the committee
representative waltz and then
representative
and then anybody on that side thank you
mr client i don't think there's a member
of this committee i don't think there is
an administrator in their state i don't
think there's anybody that's a serious
educator that disagree that remote
learning is not the best approach for
kids
however
what we're talking about here is
allowing a district to have local
control under emergency circumstances
and you have set up a straw man here
talking about oh maybe in 10 years some
remote some northern districts want to
go remote full-time we are not
legislating for 10 years from now we're
religious heading for today we're
legislating from the middle of a
pandemic and i'm confused as to why it's
not better for our children
and better for our districts to have
local control let them shut for two
three or four days rather than as
representative porter talked about
warehousing them in a cafeteria with no
educational instruction
why it isn't better to let them be
online for a couple of days
actually have educational instruction
remotely
why it's better
to just pile on the days have them have
to go to july first have them have to do
something because we're in the middle of
a pandemic this is an unusual set of
circumstances my question to you is why
in this extraordinary time are we taking
away local control when i think the
local districts know best what's best
for their students
um okay well if i can just go back to my
points about the devastating
catastrophic impacts of remote
instruction that's what we're talking
about so again
nothing in this role i'll just keep
saying it um nothing in this rule
prevents a school from closing whether
it's for staffing shortages whether they
if a school says well gosh um we have to
warehouse five kids here and we can't
instruct them the school can close we're
not preventing that
i just i'm not sure that's getting
through
we're not preventing schools from
closing
what we're saying is
if a school decides to close
it can't force remote instruction on
families who don't request it
and that's
because
we have seen the devastating impacts of
remote instruction on families that
aren't
able to handle it and so i think the
question is whether districts are going
to
use that
that closure time to offer instruction
method that we know at scale is
inadequate and causes lots of damage and
harm we know that the data are clear
i'm not sure why we want to put kids and
families in that situation so what we're
saying is instead of that situation
close the school now if you need to
but treat it like an old-fashioned snow
day and just add it at the end of the
year that's that's all we're saying so
the kids have access to the in-person
instructions so those poor low-income
disadvantaged families that have a hard
time managing remote instruction can go
to school in person we want to make sure
they have access to in-person
instruction and they're not cheated
you know by the remote instruction that
has been demonstrated and not worked for
them
but isn't it a duplicitous position to
say yes it's okay to have remote
instruction for a snow day but not for a
covet day not really
well as i explained in the beginning um
that is to be consistent with the
pre-existing blizzard bag rule so we
didn't want to change that rule we were
trying to make that rule consistent so
we can continue to do that that's all it
was um
okay
okay uh next question was coming down
the line was you representing yes go
ahead thank you very much uh mr chair
and um and um uh chairman of the state
board for uh for taking my question
um
i'm looking at the um
at the rule proposal that went to the um
to the state board
and for 306 22 which i think is the rule
you cited um
i think that's where it is yeah i think
they'll touch your side i looked it up
and it's yeah it is where it is
um
the um
the appendix in the
in the uh
materials
in the draft of that rule
cite um rsa 21n and rsa 186 8
roman 1 and 2 as being the um the
underpinning statute for that both are
rule making statues for the state board
of education so i certainly see how
those two rules are relevant but
in um in sort of digging around in our
new books here
um i came across another rsa 189 colon 1
which talks about days in school
and then 189 colon 1a which talks about
duty to provide education
and days in school says the school board
of every district shall provide
blah blah blah
you know education 180 hours
sorry 180 days or the equivalent number
of hours
at such places in the quote at such
places in the district as will best
serve the interests of education and
give
to all the pupils within the district as
nearly equal advantages as are
practicable
and 189 colon 1a goes on to to read this
is roman 1 it shall be the duty of the
school board too
and it talks about providing education
to students until they reach an age of
of 21.
roman 2
um uh
school boards shall be responsible uh
for establishing
the structure accountability advocacy
and delivery of instruction
to accomplish this end and to support
flexibility in implementing diverse
educational approaches school board
shall establish an each school board
in each school operated and governed in
the district instructional policies
and then and then it goes on to roman
three um school boards again
the responsibilities of school boards
yeah and so my question to you um mr
chair is um is under you know how the
how the rule that the board has adopted
um
is uh not in conflict with uh with with
the statutes found in 189 colon um yeah
we looked at those statutes and we had
our attorney uh go through them and and
i think the conclusion that we came to
was that they're not in conflict and
that we did have the authority to write
this rule specifying the method of
instruction i mean if you look at 189 i
don't remember the exact dashing on at
such places in the district i mean that
is a obviously pre-pandemic uh law and
its pre-remote instruction law they
didn't anticipate the technology
um
and yet i i think the way it's written
is pretty clear the intent is the the
education would be physical in a
physical location so you could make an
argument that that law in itself
forbids remote instruction
um because it is not necessarily at a
place in the district where the kids can
come to so we we did go sort of work
through all of that stuff and uh you
know our conclusion was that we did have
the authority to write this rule on the
method of instruction there so follow up
on that mr sure
yes um the um um 189 colon one was at
least according to this book updated as
recently as 2017.
pre-pandemic but certainly post-distance
learning
and and i mean distance learning's been
in place for decades right and i think
i'm sorry to interrupt no no no no
as a result let me go ahead let me let
me continue sure um
and so i guess i'm i'm i'm wondering
about your interpretation or the board's
interpretation of 189 colon one right uh
when it refers specifically to quote and
delivery of instruction because you use
it unquote you use the word methods of
or method of instruction which i think
is different than delivery of
instruction maybe and and um and
you know in in my lay read right of this
um
i i would interpret delivery as as
meaning how it's delivered as opposed to
the the pedagogy so i'd like if you
could sort of expand on maybe what the
board's considerations were yeah
honestly
i appreciate the question and i
appreciate the thoroughness of your
review there and i do think um the the
fact that that was from 2017 would sort
of bolster my argument that um it's
clearly a word in a way that anticipates
in-person instruction in a physical
location which is how we looked at it um
so
i think that
kind of addresses that issue but in
terms of um
you know our authority and our
rulemaking authority um i i'm not gonna
try to remember all of our conversations
we had with our attorneys going through
the legal um place
but it was definitely something we
looked at and our conclusion was that we
did have authority to do it
okay if there's can we try to bring this
one down to a close because we're
falling farther and farther behind we
have some folks that are waiting for
several bills which are in front of us
still so if it's a serious question i'm
not a serious quote but a question that
has to be answered now
if you could get it from drew afterwards
or ask it now either way
go ahead uh thank you for taking my
question sure uh i believe the blizzard
bags actually were developed at
kearsarge and then uh spread across the
state so uh thank you for mentioning
that and thank you for mentioning the
fact that uh
you know uh schools um with certified
teachers are the best place for kids to
learn
i don't think i mentioned just to be
clear i didn't say anything about it
would like to say that
that one of the things uh one of or the
question is the blizzard bags offer
consistency in other words
we have snow days and and we've had snow
days for a long time but they developed
these blizzard bags because kids would
miss
a couple of days right and not do
anything and then come back and the
blizzard bags gave them consistency
don't you see that having remote
learning
on days when schools may have to close
would also offer some level of
consistency
that would be better than just say
don't have school make it up in june
um yeah thank you i appreciate the
question we actually uh talked about
that a lot and in the rulemaking process
we did get some feedback from um
from some superintendents who suggested
that that was
the reason like the one reason to to go
remote
in those close days was for consistency
purposes
and we did seriously consider that and
our calculation was that on balance
based on the data we had
of seeing the catastrophic uh impacts
psychologically emotionally and
academically on students for prolonged
remote learning that
we decided to strike a balance there the
snow days and blizzard bag portion um it
was our calculus that those are really
short periods you usually don't close
for a snow day for more than a couple of
days it doesn't usually drag out long
periods and so um we were willing to
have the continuity there
but for the
sort of nebulous any other reason to
close um
we just felt like the impacts on
students were too negative
to allow that and um
uh there was another point i was i was
going to make on that but i think i'll
just
run it out of time
thank you uh represent mullin thank you
mr chair and thank you for taking my
question chairman kline so um what
advice
would you or the state board of
education have for a school district in
which there literally were not enough
bodies to open on a given day close
and just worry about running out of june
later
look if you have to close you have to
close just like a snow day and you know
the school districts are required to
build a certain number of hours into the
calendar year to take the days on at the
end we have not had a heavy winter i
don't know that we've had any full snow
days maybe there's some districts that
have um
but
you know again we're trying to do what's
best for the students and based on the
data we have
the clearly best thing for the students
is to be in class and learning in the
building rather than uh particularly for
the most vulnerable students and that's
what we tried to strike that balance
there
thank you yep jefferson hall you had a
hand up just a quick one actually thank
you mr chair sure and thank you for
taking my question so what happens in
june so
[Music]
they decide to have to close school like
you say they have a right to culture
will they close it come june 30th
they haven't gotten their 180 days now
what happens
um
so under the existing lawn rule
if it happens and again i don't think
we're running that risk this winter we
haven't had
a severe winter we haven't had a lot of
school closures for covid so i don't
think we're
we're going to run that risk but if a a
district say had attacked three weeks
onto the end of the school year and they
ran up against that um
they are able to come to the department
and get a waiver of instructional hours
and um and we granted one waiver during
the pandemic um
so that that is an option if your
contract doesn't allow you to continue i
mean i
you know my personal preference would be
you continue to get those days
i guess i was thinking when you have the
teacher contracts teachers end on june
30th so it does impact student learning
it could it could but we again just we
have the data to show the remote
learning
impact okay not seeing any further hands
here we're going to close this hearing
right here and get ready for the next
thank you very much chairman klein
materials
would you open this one up please i i
gotta get the bag
it's uh
i'll be right back in about five minutes
oh
um
thank you all i think we're ready for uh
our next
hearing
which is house bill
1434 relative to the availability of
school curriculum materials
and i see the prime sponsor
already
and i welcome
representative mcbryan
hi good afternoon i'm really excited to
talk about this bill
all right so this bill came to
mind for me over the summer
when a few things came together
my name is catherine prudom o'brien and
i am from derry
and i was just going and i'm a former
library trustee and i was going through
some
old library minutes library trustee
minutes and i got them as
is
in adherence with state law they are
displayed at the library or you could
ask the librarians for them if you want
and at the same time that i was looking
through these old library trustee
minutes to find out about some issue
with the library i also noticed um
some people that i know were trying to
get more information about the
curriculum in their community
and were having some trouble with it and
unfortunately the person the people were
were feeling some
animosity and they were feeling on the
defense now that may have been perceived
it may have been factual i don't know
but the point is they felt that they
felt that trying to get information
about the curriculum
was uh putting they were they were on
the defensive so
i thought that was rather unfortunate
and i thought about all the reasons why
this curriculum that the curriculum that
is used in public schools should be as
transparent as
library trustee minutes you should be
able to go
and
read a notebook that explains the
curriculum that is used in the schools
in your community
and
this bill also
allows for it to be online i know some
communities don't have that but it would
be both and then
also in a notebook form at a charter
school which is a kind of public school
as well as i'm sure you know
um i try to keep this bill as simple as
possible so that it would not be
difficult for school personnel to
provide this information
now
i don't think this would really be extra
work my own opinion on that because
if i was a teacher at us at a public
school
i would have to have some sort of
framework some sort of curriculum no
matter what first grade 12th grade it
wouldn't really matter and
the reason for that is because i
couldn't just start the school year and
say to the principal
i'm going to teach you know whatever
this year no i would assume that every
teacher has
some framework a curriculum that they
have written down
and that when that already exists
and that the principal or the curriculum
committee has that when that already
exists it's not going to be difficult to
keep in a notebook for the public to
read
i feel like
this also allows all parties to be on
the same page when having discussions
about curriculum so if i were to go to
the school board and or school board
member and try to talk to them about
curriculum matters we're on the same
page
they're not going to be able to they're
not going to tell me that oh no we don't
teach
i don't know
latin or something
we don't teach that at our schools
because it will be well known it will be
information that's easily available to
every parent that that is what's in the
curriculum so these conversations will
be much easier to have with everyone on
the same page
this also will allow members of the
public to compare and contrast
so they can look at the curriculum used
in their community if they think that
their community is doing well they can
be
they will be proud of that if they think
that another community is doing very
well and they wish that their own
community was doing that well they can
think about what the other community is
using and they can go and look at what
the other community is using
and make those comparisons and that's
not just for parents but business owners
could could do the same thing people who
are just
enthusiastic about science
could think about the best ways to
improve science
outcomes in our in our state
who is concerned about uh
test scores in a certain community could
look at that and think about it i know
it's not the whole story and i'm sure
that experienced educators in this
on this um
committee will will know that and
but it's it's something that we can all
point to and understand have a a real
conversation about
their taxpayer-funded schools it makes
total sense to allow taxpayers to know
what is taught in them
this bill i i think is uh
is a no-brainer and i actually don't see
any reason why this cannot or should not
be done and i've talked to many people
about it and
everyone i've talked to feels the same
way they don't see a reason why this
cannot be done or should not be done
and that uh some people are surprised
that it's not already done
and
that's the that is the only response i
have gotten to this bill so far
so i'd be happy to take questions and
i'll answer them as best as i possibly
can
thank you for your testimony
representative paul
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question do you have any idea
how many schools don't already post
curriculum
no i don't know that but i know that
this
uh
that this does not already exist so it
should be no no no problem to do this
now
and if it were to exist if this were to
be made law
then
it would be every school that is doing
this and i think that would be that
would be good for the entire state and
the community
representative ellison thank you mr
chair thank you for taking two questions
actually
uh one you keep referring to curriculum
the the actual bill on line four talks
about
curriculum course materials
which
aren't necessarily that doesn't
encompass a curriculum but that's
another level
itch
this one off it should encompass
the curriculum and what is taught and
now it doesn't have to be the lesson
plan in
infinite detail
but it a guideline that people know what
is going to be taught if you have a
child in the 11th grade you want to know
what they're being taught in social
studies
you don't have to know you don't have to
get
five pages per week of the lesson plan
but if you know that they're studying
the vietnam war the civil war that would
be very helpful to you to have a
conversation about about the entirety of
their the child's education
okay thank you follow up mr chairman
uh second question
uh this appears to apply to
all classes all grade levels in the
school system yes you you're expecting
that the uh kindergarten teacher will
have tell you how they're gonna teach
addition and subtraction and reading and
so on i mean we're not just talking
about the vietnam war and social studies
and so on we're talking about
the kindergarten teacher as well is that
your understanding sure i don't see any
problem with that i taught my own
children
and if you ask me any questions about
what i was teaching them at any time i
would be able to tell you first grade
materials i can tell you what i taught
them i
was teaching them to read i was teaching
them addition i was teaching them
subtraction then as the later grades
progressed i taught them more
issues more more subjects
thank you
thank you representative baum
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question
you said the comprehensive list of all
curriculum course materials to me that
doesn't mean lesson plan it means list
of books
and those that are going to be used
because i know we had a problem in our
school with what books were being used
so is that what you really mean by
promptiento's cost of materials
sure yes
representative hopson
hi thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question i was just wondering
if you could speak to
the exp the expenditures uh
indeterminable
do you have a thought process on that
okay
if i had to pull something out of my hat
i would say five cents per page because
that's how much it costs to get maybe
it's 10 cents per page but that's how
much a copy costs at my public library i
haven't made a copy there for a long
time
but there we go
yep
any further questions for the
representative
uh see none thank you very much
i'm sorry question
thank you sorry mr chair i was slow
getting that hand up it's it's late it
happens to me so representative i just
want to piggyback a little bit on what
representative ellison said about the
difference between a curriculum outline
and curriculum materials
it's educational lingo but for those of
us that have been in a classroom when we
hear
curriculum materials
i think what you would find is that
people are picturing
worksheets and
activity boxes and
i noticed that your bill also requires
that public academies and public
charters go through the same exercise
who would be responsible because those
materials are going to be stored at the
public sau office correct yes so
would it be
the charter or academy's responsibility
to
get those things over there i i'm
i'm just wondering about the physical
space limitations and whether or not
they can
you know if you're in manchester and
there are four charter schools and a and
an academy
then what what do you what do you do
with all that stuff
i don't think that would be a problem
any more than the library trustee
minutes being kept in a notebook at the
public library are a problem for space
i don't see that that would be a pro i'm
talking about a notebook it might be a
large notebook the kind that we get we
seem to accumulate as representatives
over
by by may our notebook will be pretty
large right with all our bills so this
may be a large notebook or it may be
they a collection of notebooks such as a
notebook for the first grade and one for
the second grade and the third grade and
then
elementary school and so on at different
schools but i don't i don't i'm sorry
i'm trying to be close to this thing um
i don't see it would be
an insurmountable problem space will not
be an insurmountable problem for this
could i just have a quick follow-up
i would encourage you if you if you
would too i'm looking at bedford's
curriculum which is online
and it's every time you hit a link it
brings you to like six more pages of
whatever it's that physical copy
that um
i would just
ask whether or not you might
consider something other than a physical
copy
perhaps a master or
the ability to access it electronically
at the superintendent's office well the
the bill does say it can be on the
website and
and at the sau
i'm trying to keep it as simple as
possible and
accessible by every person in the state
so that would that would be physically
located at the sau for simplicity
purposes also we are we always consider
that some communities don't have an
online presence it's hard to imagine
that nowadays but in the event there is
a community that has a small elementary
school and does not have a website for
that
then that is taken into consideration
and everything is the same and and the
expectation of where you can find this
information would be the same in every
single community so that so that
citizens taxpayers residents parents
everybody will be on the same page
knowing where they can get the
information
are there any more questions
this time for the presenter
thank you very much okay i'm glad i was
able to answer all your questions thank
you thank you have a good day
okay are there any other cards
okay
ding dong over there okay
you want me to open it
oh he's right there
uh represent boom we don't have the
maker of the next bill here and you're
our expert at introducing bills when the
owners don't come especially
transportation especially transportation
which you're very familiar with
hb 1243
relative to the alternative
transportation of students for public
schools
thank you mr chairman members of
education
i'm ralph balboa district 20. i remember
that
litchfield
bill is
relative alternative transportation for
students for public schools and i know
we have a member from the department of
safety here to testify on that so with
that thank you yes and we also have the
department available here too
today regarding any issues we may have
regarding transportation and
vehicles that are addressed there so at
this point in time um
does the department of safety have any
uh information for us on this particular
bill
there has been some
questioning before
uh use of volunteer private vehicles for
transporting students
pardon me
oh come on up come on up
oh he put on the card all right
there we are
i don't want to do that but
greg hildreth yes sir
thank you
this on okay yes welcome
good afternoon members of the committee
my name is trooper first class gregory
hildreth i am currently the supervisor
of pupil transportation for the state of
new hampshire at the department of
safety
this bill uh i'm against it i have
concerns over this
basically
in order for someone to drive a school
bus in the state of new hampshire as
defined under 259.96
it gives clear
information about what a school bus
driver is and what they need to be and
that's basically transporting
via a municipal contract students to or
from school or school related activities
in this case this bill defines the part
the people that will end up doing the
driving as volunteers under the 189 law
now that would put them in basically as
a school employee
and assuming they're going to be
compensated
basically that would put them in a
situation outside of the department of
safety's oversight and regulation
and allow them to do everything a school
bus driver does without any of the
safety yards or checks that my
department puts into place so in new
hampshire for a school bus driver that
operates under 259.96
they have to submit what's called a dsmv
126 form it's a roster that is the first
page that we receive for anybody that's
going to drive for either a school or a
company that's contracted with the
school to drive and transport students
i run background checks right now on
them for via new hampshire and motor
vehicle record checks to determine their
fitness to drive
now
they are among if you see a school bus
driver they are among the highest
regulated drivers on the road i've had
many cdl drivers that have done
transportation that then want to take on
a school bus job and they'll find that
they find themselves denied for
something and they ask us you know why
was i denied i've been driving a you
know hazmat or doing this for this long
it's because we restrict and regulate
these drivers so carefully to make sure
the safest people out there to be
driving we don't do this just once we do
this annually and this is one of the
conflicts with the current bill under
the doe side they only run one
fingerprint check
and that's it they could run it for 30
years and a school employee well
everybody knows somebody you know just
got checked back in 1990 doesn't mean
you didn't do something in between i've
come in across
specific situations where
people that were cleared last year then
they get re-annually checked this year
and now they've done something that you
know is significant that we need to take
away there so we continuously run checks
on them additionally they also have to
undergo a minimum of 10 hours of
training
operating a school bus uh the safety of
operating and driving with kids
and all kinds of curriculum associated
with that again this bill would require
none of that
the
additional parts of the vehicle against
school buses the typical yellow buses
you see out there that they compose a
good number of the actual school buses
on the road that fall under the vehicles
that are authorized under the 1300 rules
and again they're reinforced steel belts
or bars around the uh the foot the hip
the shoulder level for the normal school
buses the short yellow buses all the way
up to the big full-size flat nose buses
there's also a significant number of
regular passenger vehicles out there
that are school buses they're called
multi-passenger vehicles now
we require not only a state safety
inspection which this bill also requires
but we also require school bus
inspection on those vehicles and that's
a center sticker that actually gets on
it's a completely different inspection
and it makes sure that all the
requirements and equipment requirements
that make these vehicles safer is
present this bill requires none of that
so no emerging medical clint required no
seat belt cutter no body fluid spill
kits no
hazard warning devices again so this is
just another example of some of the
stuff that gets skipped over by this
bill
when this bill goes in and actually
talks about
the volunteers one of the concerning
parts of the language in this bill
is right under paragraph two
it says students may be transported to
and from school activities or to and
from school when that school district
cannot provide legally required
transportation
that's vague i feel like an open to
interpretation you know what when they
can't provide does that mean they simply
don't budget for it and they don't want
to use the available safer vehicles and
drivers on the road and they decide
we're just going to keep this in-house
and operate our own
you know substitute teachers the lunch
lady whoever's going to end up going out
and transporting kids in their vehicle
via their own personal vehicle it
doesn't require scaleless safety
inspection doesn't require the extra
hours of training annually it doesn't
require the annual backup trucks so this
is the major concern here is this is
essentially a seesaw where you're taking
safety at the highest and lowering that
to lift the other side which would be
for convenience i do understand there is
a shortage of drivers and i certainly
can appreciate the intent of this bill
but i feel like this just opens a door
to you know undercutting the current
safer industry and operating outside of
my regulation the department of safety
and
things can happen uh you know people
they end up transporting kids around
things do happen and we'd like to keep
the safest drivers possible on the road
and with that i'd like to open myself to
questions thank you very much officer uh
may i start with the first question i
have i'm looking at the bill and i'm
looking at lines 16 and 17.
it says no school school district or
school administrative union shall be
held responsible for any loss damage or
legal liability
would that sentence alone
exempt a school district
who is using that to tr this mode of
transportation
from liability from you know
i'm having a hard time believing that
i mean i i have a lot of issues with
this bill but one of the things is i
mean i feel like that was just put in
there to try and give the school an out
in the end it's going to be put down on
the private insurance that they're
required to carry for this
again i don't i just i i don't deal with
the actual legislative law legal
definitions and all that but what i end
up seeing when i read this whole bill is
it's basically a way to avoid a lot of
the requirements and safeguards that are
currently in place under my regulations
which fall into the 259 laws and the
rsafc 1300 rules because they're
completely outside all the stuff that
pertains is not in this bill yeah and
that led to my you you approach a little
bit on where i was going to go with this
thing
um
you insure your car via through you know
geico or any hartford any of them
for purposes you sow state when you get
that insurance policy
now you're turning your vehicle into a
school bus transporter
type vehicle
is that something you would have to
modify your insurance policy for to say
now we're using on a regular basis to do
school business so there's a company
tucker transportation they're basically
a husband and wife team
and they have i don't know if they have
any other employees or just themselves
but they have their own house that's
where they work out of they have
vehicles that are school bus certified
they're standard type regular cars out
there but again they meet all the
requirements the vehicles pass a state
safety inspection they carry the proper
insurance that's required for this i
don't know what the threshold is
unfortunately i don't deal with that but
i do know that they have to have special
insurance in order to do this uh the
vehicles themselves are checked annually
to make sure they're also open to audit
which might if there's any other
complaints about the safety of the
vehicle i can go out and actually look
at these vehicles and make sure that
they're you know safe vehicles in this
bill i won't be able to do that it's
outside of my regulation so they can be
driving whatever they want to drive if
they can pass a safety inspection and i
can tell you working field enforcement
for a while
you can find a sticker for virtually
anything if you go to the right place
and that's why we have an entire
division that's dedicated to dealing
with these inspection stations so the
school bus inspection stations are much
more limited and uh
their their expertise and uh is unique
to these type of inspectors that's why
we require the additional second sticker
thank you are there questions from the
committee on on this bill
well
no questions great well i thank you for
your time well thank you very much for
being here today thank you sir
um
are there is there a need to hear
anything from the department on this or
are we good to go
are you asking to speak with diana
yeah you're gonna have to turn that mic
on please patty
thank you thank you
attorney fenton
the line 16 and 17 where it says in our
school school district or administrative
shelby how liable i mean to me it seems
like they're just sticking that in there
i mean just because you say it doesn't
make a soul
thank you for the question uh good
afternoon my name is diana fenton i'm an
attorney with the department of
education
um
we have seen
bills and subsequent laws in which
legislatures have decided to say you
can't help hold someone accountable um
i believe if you look at
the
bullying law there was that
language in there and that has since uh
been repealed by this legislative body
to allow um
for school districts to to be sued
so can it be done
yes and we've proven that and the court
upheld that legislative language however
i will say looking at this language it
does seem overly broad
it seems overly broad
and
for any loss damage or legal liability
um is associated to what
right
thank you
thank you representative mullen uh
it's easy to do uh so um
i i think in the right set of
circumstances and facts given this
overly broad language in the hands of a
competent attorney
there would be a very good argument to
be made
and so yes when i look at this language
similar to representative vlad and
yourself it causes me concern um
thank you are there any other questions
for the department of education
not seeing any questions thank you very
much thank you and i don't believe we
have any other people signed up to
testify no pink cards and that's the
last one on the docket for
representative porter
mr chair i just want to apologize i
spoke out of turn um and was rude to you
and i did not intend i should not have
done that and i apologize accepted and i
never even went that way of thinking
anyways
so
we're here to get business done
so thank you very much all for showing
up today and we have one more this week
it's tomorrow
we're getting there we're getting there
oh barrett
unfortunately
did he do it by way of the email
because that's where a lot of it is and
it gets provided to us by jennifer four
okay
okay well thank you very much for this
meeting is adjourned today this hearing
and
be re we start again
tomorrow never ending deal
it's like groundhog day over and over
you